[Music]
hello guys
welcome to this six sigma full course
video by simply learn
in this video we'll cover everything
you'll need to know about six sigma
and cover the major concepts of lean six
sigma
we will start out with an animated video
covering each of these concepts
and go into more detail on the dmeic
process
we will also cover the different six
sigma builds and much more
so without further ado let's jump right
into it before we do that
don't forget to get subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon so that you can never
miss an update from
simply learn now over to our training
experts
imagine you've been tasked with a really
important project at work the company
you're working for produces luxury cars
the production numbers are going down
and a lesser number of cars are getting
manufactured each day
there also seems to be an issue with the
quality of the windshield wipers that go
on these cars
the question you are faced with is there
a way for the company to stop the stall
in production
and increase the production per day from
1 000 to
2 000 also is there a way to find out
what's causing the drop in the wiper
quality there is
six sigma six sigma gives you the tools
and techniques to determine
what's making the manufacturing process
slow down how you can eliminate the
delays
improve the process and fix further
issues along the way
the concept was introduced in 1980 by
bill smith
while working for motorola since then
six sigma
has seen worldwide adoption six sigma
aims to reduce the time
defects and variability experienced by
processes in an organization
thanks to six sigma you can produce a
defect-free product
99.9996 percent of the time
allowing only 3.4 errors per 1 million
opportunities
six sigma also increases customer
loyalty towards the brand
improves employee morale leading to
higher productivity
six sigma has two major methodologies
dmaic
and dmadv let's look at the first
methodology
dmaic is an acronym for define
measure analyze improve and control
let's have a look at each of these
stages individually
and how it relates to your earlier
problem in the define
phase you determine what issues you're
facing what your opportunities for
improvement are
and what the customer requires of you
here you look at the process as a whole
and determine the issues with the
manufacturing process
in this case finding out why the cars
had varying windshield wiper quality
and how to optimize the current process
to manufacture
more cars in the measure phase you
determine how the process is performing
currently
in its unaltered state you determine the
current number of cars that are
manufactured in a day
in the current scenario 1000 cars are
manufactured in a day
and each of these cars are outfitted
with a pair of windshield wipers
by one of 30 machines used some of the
metrics measured are how many cars are
produced in a day
time taken to assemble a car how many
windshield wipers were attached in a day
time that takes them to do so defects
detected from each machine on assembly
completion
and so on following this in the analyze
phase
you determine what caused the defect or
variation
on analyzing previous data you find out
that one of the machines that installed
the windshield wiper
was not performing as well as it was
supposed to
production was taking longer since the
car chassis was being moved across the
different locations slower
as cranes had to individually pick and
drop the frame
this was because the wheels were
attached to the car only
in the last stage next in the improve
phase
you make changes to the manufacturing
process and ensure the defects are
addressed
you replaced the faulty machines that
installed the windshield wiper with
another one
you also find a way to save time by
attaching wheels on the frame
in the initial stages of the
manufacturing process unlike how it was
done
earlier now the car can be moved across
the assembly area
faster and finally in the control phase
you make regular adjustments to control
new processes
and future performance based on the
changes made
the company was able to reduce
production time and manufacture about
2 000 cars a day with a higher quality
of output
dmaic is one of the most commonly used
methodologies
in the world it focuses on improving the
existing products of the organization
the second methodology is dmadv which is
short for define
measure analyze design and verify
it is used when the company has to
create a new product or service from
scratch
it is also called dfss or design for
six sigma let's take the scenario where
the company decides to build a new model
a sports car in the define phase you
define the requirements of the customer
based on inputs from customers
historical data industry research you
determine what you need to ensure your
car becomes a success
the data collected indicates customers
are drawn to cars which can achieve more
than 150 miles per hour
customers are also more inclined towards
cars which have v6 engines
and an aerodynamic frame then in the
measure phase
you use the customer's requirements to
create a specification
this specification helps define the
product in a measurable method
so that data can be collected and
compared with specific requirements
some of the major specifications that
you focus on are the top speed
engine type and type of frame
in the analyze phase you analyze the
product to determine
whether there are better ways to achieve
the desired results
areas of improvement are determined and
tested
based on the analysis of the prototype
created in this phase
you find that the product satisfies just
about all of the customer requirements
except the top speed so research begins
on an aluminum alloy
that could possibly meet the speed
requirements of the customer
following this the design phase based on
the learnings from the analysis phase
the new process or product is designed
revisions are made to the model
and the car is manufactured with the new
material the analysis phase is repeated
based on the new design
you also bring a focus group and see how
they receive it
based on their feedback further changes
are made
and finally in the verify phase you
check whether the end result
meets or exceeds customer requirements
once you
launch your brand new sports card you
collect customer feedback
and incorporate it into future designs
and
guess what your customers are loving the
new design
and that is dmadv for you
six sigma has also found success in a
number of different industries
the petrochemical healthcare banking
government and software are some of the
industries that have utilized the
concepts of six sigma
to achieve their business goals another
commonly used methodology adopted by
companies around the world
is lean lean is a methodology that aims
to remove any part of the process
that does not bring value to the
customer it means
doing more with less while doing it
better
the philosophy behind lean comes from
the japanese manufacturing industry
by bob hartman who at the time was part
of toyota
since then across the world services and
manufacturing organizations
have incorporated lean within their
businesses
but what if you could have the best of
both worlds
a combination of both six sigma and
length
that's lean six sigma before we get into
lean six sigma
we've got a quiz for you what
methodology is used by companies when
they want to release a new product
created from scratch a design
measure analyze define verify
b define measure analyze
design verify c
demand measure analyze improve
control d define
measure analyze improve control
leave your answers in the comments
section below for a chance to be one of
three people
to win an amazon voucher now let's get
back to lean six sigma
lean six sigma is a methodology that
focuses on eliminating
problems removing inefficiencies and
waste
while improving the working conditions
to ensure the customer's needs are
better satisfied
it combines the tools methods and
principles of lean
and six sigma we'll have another video
detailing the process of lean six sigma
very soon imagine you're the manager of
a supermarket chain
you've noticed that two things need your
immediate attention
the first issue is how to handle the
different kinds of waste that you
encounter at your supermarket
the next one requires you to address the
supply chain issues at the supermarket
which are causing delays to the morning
delivery of milk
leading to customer dissatisfaction and
attrition
these problems can be solved by
incorporating two of the most popular
quality management methodologies
in the world lean and six sigma
one famous for its ability to handle
waste and another
known for process improvement but what
if there was a methodology that combined
the concepts of both six sigma
and lean one that could solve all your
issues
well there is lean six sigma
before we dive into lean six sigma let's
take a closer look at its parent
methodologies
first off lean is a methodology that
focuses on
providing value to the customer
eliminating waste
continuous improvement reducing cycle
time
lean and six sigma both aim to handle
waste
but what is this waste waste is any step
or action in the process that a user
does not gain
any value from in short things that
users
wouldn't want to pay for why would a
consumer want to pay
extra for the additional truck that was
required to deliver milk to the
supermarket
just because the other one broke down
this waste can be divided into eight
categories
let's have a look at each of them one
transportation
this waste refers to the excess movement
of people tools
inventory equipment and other components
of a process
than it is required two inventory
this waste occurs due to having more
products and materials
than required this can cause damage and
effects to products or materials
greater time for completion inefficient
allocation of capital
and so on three motion
this refers to the time and effort
wasted due to unnecessary movement of
people
equipment or machinery this could be
sitting through inventory double data
entry and
so on 4. waiting
this can be time wasted waiting on
information instructions
materials or equipment 5.
over-production this is the waste
created due to producing more products
than required 6.
it refers to more work more components
or more steps in a product or service
than required seven defects
this is the waste originating from a
product or service that fails to meet
customer expectations
8. skills this waste refers to the waste
of human potential
under utilizing capabilities and
delegating tasks to people with
inadequate training
for years now many systems have emerged
that use the lean methodology to
identify
and handle the different kinds of waste
some of the more popular and effective
ones are
jit or just in time 5s
and kanban the jit methodology focuses
on reducing the amount of time the
production system takes to provide an
output
and the response time from suppliers to
customers
5s is another methodology that focuses
on cleanliness in organization
while improving profits and efficiency
kanban is
also another popular methodology to
achieve lean
it is a visual method to manage tasks
and workflows
kanban enables users visualize the
workflow to identify issues
in the process and fix them these
methodologies help in optimizing the
waste production
and are often used together to maximize
results
so that's the first problem solved now
let's have a look at how you can improve
the supermarket supply chain efficiency
for that let's have a look at the other
part of lean six sigma
six sigma six sigma is a set of tools
and techniques that are used for process
improvement
and removing defects let's see how six
sigma
makes that possible six sigma has two
major methodologies
dmaic and dmadv
you can learn more about these two
methodologies by checking out our six
sigma in nine minutes video
by clicking on the top right corner
let's have a closer look at dmaic
since lean six sigma uses the dmaic
methodology of six sigma
dmaic is an acronym for define
measure analyze improve control
it is used to improve existing products
and processes
so that it can meet the customer's
requirements
in the define phase you determine what
the goals of the project
are in this case you want to reduce the
amount of time
taken to deliver milk from the warehouse
to the supermarket
so that it is stocked on the supermarket
shelves before 8 30 in the morning
in the measure phase you measure the
performance of the current
unaltered process the milk truck leaves
at 7 30 a.m
in the morning and can take one of three
routes
a b and c route a is
currently the preferred one as it takes
only 60 minutes to reach the supermarket
compared to the routes b and c which
takes 70 and 80 minutes respectively
in the analyze phase you find out why
the defects exist
since routes b and c were school bus
routes by reducing the starting time by
one hour at 6
30 instead of 7 30 meant avoiding the
traffic
routes b and c now take 40 to 45 minutes
to reach the supermarket route a
still takes the milk truck one hour to
get to the supermarket
even when the truck leaves at 6 30 a.m
in the improved phase
performance can be improved by
addressing and eliminating the root
causes
now that you've realized that advancing
the milk pickup by an hour
and changing the route to route b can
save time
you change the process accordingly
providing your workers with ample time
to stock the milk into the shelves
before the morning rush and finally
in the control phase you make regular
adjustments to control new processes
and future performance you continue to
monitor the delivery times
and try out alternate routes to
continually improve the process
and ensure even faster delivery this
process
change led to reduced man hours and cost
enhanced
sales and customer retention the lean
six sigma methodology
offers many such benefits to businesses
let's take a look at some of them
one increase in profits two
standardized and simplified process
three
reduced errors four employee development
five value to customers and
that is lean six sigma for you six sigma
is a set of tools and techniques that
have helped several companies around the
world
achieve business success hi guys i'm
raut from simply learn
and let's get started with our
introduction to six sigma now let's
understand this better with an example
here let's talk about how things were
before six sigma was introduced
here jenny and james are having a
conversation with each other jenny is
james's manager
and she's not happy at all she says
james is in a lot of trouble
this is because she found out that the
customers weren't happy with the
organization's service
and the operational costs were way too
high and as manager james had to make
sure that this did not happen
now let's have a look at the same
scenario in present day here we have
jenny congratulating james
she's very impressed with his work but
james says it's all thanks to six sigma
methodology so jenny asks
she wants to know more about six sigma
so to understand six sigma here's what
you need to know
firstly we'll have to understand what is
six sigma what its advantages are
some of its methodologies what are the
different roles in a six sigma team
what is lean what is a lean process and
what is lean six sigma
so now let's get started with
understanding what exactly is
six sigma the six sigma methodology
makes sure to find as well as eliminate
any sort of defect or variation that
could be affecting your product
service or process now this methodology
is statistics based
is data driven and focused on continuous
improvement now this means that there's
no
end goal in the horizon there's always
another goal to reach
there are three core ideologies behind
six sigma
the first one states that for any
business to be successful
there's continuous efforts that are
required so that you can achieve
stable as well as predictable process
results the second ideology states that
in any business
or manufacturing process there are
certain characteristics that can be
defined
measured analyzed and controlled the
final ideology says that along with the
rest of the organization
the top level management plays a very
important role to making sure that
there's sustained quality now let's talk
about the advantages of six sigma
six sigma can help produce a road map or
a path
through which you can easily find and
reduce any sort of organizational risk
and reduce the operational costs another
advantage is that it helps improve the
efficiency of the process
and making sure that it works in a
timely manner it decreases defects
improves the overall tracking and
monitoring process and ensures that the
products
are aligned with the company's policies
it is also reported that it greatly
helps improve
customer as well as vendor satisfaction
it helps improve the cash flow
and ensures that the products are
complying with the regulations of the
organization
now let me tell you about the process of
six sigma now six sigma projects
are of basically two methodologies the
dma ic
and the dma dv now let's talk about
dmaic
in detail that's short for define
measure analyze
improve and control this is one of the
most commonly used methodologies in the
world
this is commonly used by companies when
they have to fix or
improve an already existing product or
process that does not meet the company's
standards
now let's have a look at the process
first phase is the define phase
in this phase you define the problem
that the customers are facing
you find out where you can improve and
you clearly understand what the
customers require of you the second
phase
is the measure phase now in this phase
you actually identify
how well the process is doing in its
current unaltered state
in the analyze phase you process the
data that you get from the measure phase
and determine what exactly is the cause
of the delay or variation
in the improve phase you start by making
small changes to the business process
and make sure that the problem you
identified earlier is being taken care
of
and finally in the control phase you
control the new process so that it
doesn't go wrong and use the same
knowledge for future processes
now let's have a look at dmadv this is
short for define
measure analyze design and verify now
this is also commonly known as dfss
or the design for six sigma now this is
commonly used by companies around the
world
when they have a new product that needs
to be created all the way from scratch
in the first phase which is the define
phase you define
what the goal of the project is and what
the customers require of you
in the measure phase you measure as well
as determine what the customer needs
and how they respond to your products in
the analyze phase you perform
analyses to determine how you can
improve your product or service
so they can better serve your customers
in the design phase you set up
process details and make optimizations
to the design
to make sure your customer is satisfied
and finally in the verify phase
you check how well the design is working
out and how well
it meets the customer's needs now before
we go on let's talk about how
six sigma was used in reference to the
earlier example the situation that james
was facing
a survey conducted by the organization
james was working for
indicated that the customers weren't
very happy with the organization so they
decided to fix that with the help of six
sigma so they decided that the dmaic
methodology
would be best suited to solve their
problem so let's have a look at what
they did
firstly in the define phase they used a
tool called the voice of the customer
this tool represented the needs as well
as requirements of the customer
this showed that the customers expected
prompt delivery the correct product
selection
and a knowledgeable distribution team
from the company and now
on to the measure phase the company
wanted to know why the customers didn't
like them so they performed some data
collection
from there they found out that they took
56 percent longer than other companies
to deliver their product
so they decided to reduce the amount of
time it takes between order entry
and the delivery of the product and now
in the analyze phase
here they knew what the issue was but
they wanted to know
what exactly made their products
delivery so slow
why were the customers receiving the
product so late then they performed some
analysis
their analysis showed the possible
causes it could have been inaccurate
sales plans
issues with their safety stock issues
with their vendors delivery performance
and falling behind on the manufacturing
schedule further analysis also indicated
that most of their sales
almost 80 percent came from 30 of their
products the issue was that they didn't
have enough safety stock to satisfy the
customers who required that 30
of products and now on to the improved
phase so now that they knew what was
causing their problem they wanted to
solve it they began to have monthly
reviews and tried to make sure that
their in-demand products
stayed in demand another thing that they
wanted to focus on
was to make sure that they could order
and provide the customer with the
products that they wanted and finally
onto the control phase
they began to set up plans so that they
could monitor the sales of that 30
of products that were selling the most
each year they would review how well a
product was selling
and replace it if it had fallen out of
favor now let me tell you what a six
sigma team consists of
let's talk about the roles in a six
sigma team first up is level seven
now these are individuals who are at the
novice level
now these individuals don't know in
great detail about what the project is
but they have a basic understanding of
the principles and the methodology
behind the program
now they usually support with smaller
projects and with smaller issues
but these individuals found the
foundation for the people who decide
where the program is going and now we're
at level six
now these are individuals who have a
yellow belt certification
now they are core members of the six
sigma team who have an understanding of
how the basic metrics work
and how they can perform some sort of
improvement now they have their own
areas of expertise
and they're required to determine
certain processes that need to improve
at the same time they're also in charge
of smaller improvement projects
now level five these are people who have
a green belt certification
now these individuals are usually
part-time professionals who have a
number of different duties to fulfill
they focus on smaller six sigma projects
they are usually involved with gathering
data performing some sort of experiment
and analyzing information they also
assist with black belt projects
and now we're at level four these are
individuals who have a black belt
certification
they're usually team leaders of a six
sigma project they complete four to six
projects a year
and are experts in the principles
methodologies and lean concepts
thanks to their understanding of
statistical experimental design they can
also understand
the hidden reasons behind why a
particular product failed
and now we're at level three these are
individuals who have a master black belt
certification now these are individuals
who are
experts when it comes to resources the
practices and the methodologies that are
employed in six sigma
their main emphasis is to coach train
and certify black belts
they also are involved with other six
sigma leaders to ensure a company's
goals are met
now level two these individuals are
called
champions so they work really closely
with the executives and usually have a
role like a senior
or a middle executive level role they
also have a clear understanding of what
exactly is the company's vision
and mission they also understand metrics
so that they can set up a six sigma
project that lines up with the company's
goals they're responsible
for removing any sort of roadblock that
could hamper the success of a project
and finally we're at level one these are
the executives now these individuals
represent the highest level when it
comes to a six sigma team now they have
training as well as experience
through which they can set up six sigma
projects that clearly line up with the
company's goals
their main emphasis is to ensure that
the project is able to add value to the
organization
and at the end of the day is successful
now this is when jenny interjects
she wants to know about lean john tells
her that lean just like six sigma is
another methodology
so what exactly is lean now lean is a
methodology that has a very important
ideology
to make sure that there's continuous
optimization
of the processes and there's an
elimination of waste
so what's waste so waste is basically
any part of the process
that the customer doesn't want to pay
for it is a process that does not add
any value to the customer now coming
back to lean here are some of its
characteristics whenever decisions are
being made in a lean team
the main emphasis is to understand how
it exactly adds value to the customer
every member in a lean team has a clear
understanding of what exactly are the
goals of the organization
it also encourages employees to push for
further success
even if the organization is in a good
place or is already doing well
there's also an emphasis on
cross-functional collaboration
and communication lean focuses on
answering the difficult question or the
complex ones
rather than employing short-term fixes
and with lean you can easily prepare for
issues that can come up in the future or
improvise in unexpected circumstances
so let's talk about how lean and six
sigma are different from one another
the lean methodology aims to reduce
waste
it does so by analyzing the workflow it
also emphasizes
on minimizing resource usage and
improving
customer value now let's talk about six
sigma the aim of six sigma
is to provide near-perfect results it
wants to reduce costs
and improve customer satisfaction
basically both of them
are moving towards the same goal to
reduce the amount of waste
and to create efficient processes now
let's talk about the process
of lean now there are five different
steps let's start with the first one
identifying value you need to identify
value by determining what exactly is the
problem
you're trying to solve for the customer
the second step is to map your value
stream
you need to map the workflow of your
company you need to focus on the
different actions
and the people that are involved with
the process you need to be able to
identify which parts of the process are
able to add value
and the ones that don't the third step
is to create a flow
you need to break up your work into
smaller silos and visualize the workflow
so that you can easily identify
problems that might show up later the
next step is to establish
pull you need to set up a system through
which products are created only when
there is a demand or a requirement for
it
through this you can optimize resource
capacity and finally we're at the fifth
step which is continuous improvement
you need to ensure all your employees at
all levels
are involved in the continuous
improvement of the process so what
exactly
is lean six sigma what if you could
combine the best of both worlds
the combination of six sigma and lean
methodology
led to the creation of lean six sigma
lean six sigma
is a methodology that aims to solve
problems removes any form of waste or
inefficiency
and improving the working conditions of
employees to make sure that they can
serve the customers better now this is a
combination
of the tools methods and principles that
are employed in lean and six sigma
let's talk about some of its advantages
it aims to provide customers with a
better experience by streamlining the
process with
efficient power flows it aims to drive
higher results
it can reduce cost remove waste and
prevent effects
it can help the organization handle
day-to-day problems
the decreased lead times help increase
capacity and profitability
and finally it helps with people
development and improving the morale of
the organization
this lesson provides an overview of the
certified six sigma greenbelt
or cssgb course a process
is a series of steps designed to produce
a product and or service
according to the requirement of the
customer a process mainly consists of
four parts
input process steps output
and feedback input is something put into
a process
or expended in its operation to achieve
an output
or a result for example man
material machine and management output
is the final product delivered to
an internal or external customer for
example product or services
it is important to understand that if
the output of a process
is an input for another process the
latter process
is the internal customer each input can
be classified as controllable
represented as c non-controllable
represented as nc noise
represented as n and critical
represented as
x the most important aspect of the
process
is the feedback as can be inferred from
the image
any change in the inputs causes change
in the output
therefore y equals f of x
feedback helps in process control
because it suggests changes to the
inputs
let us learn about the process of six
sigma in the next screen
let us understand how six sigma works in
this screen
six sigma is successful because of the
following reasons
six sigma is a management strategy it
creates an environment where the
management
supports six sigma as a business
strategy and not as
a standalone approach or a program to
satisfy some public relations need
six sigma mainly emphasizes the dmacc
method of problem solving
focused teams are assigned well-defined
projects
that directly influence the
organization's bottom line
with customer satisfaction and increased
quality being
byproducts six sigma also requires
extensive use of statistical methods
the next screen will focus on some key
terms used in
six sigma let us look at the sigma
level chart in this screen as discussed
earlier
the six sigma quality means 3.4 defects
in 1 million opportunities
or process with a 99.99966 percent yield
the sigma level chart given on the
screen shows the values for other sigma
levels
please take a look at the values
carefully let us understand the benefits
of
six sigma in the next screen the
organizational benefits of six sigma are
as follows
a six sigma process eliminates the root
cause of problems and defects in a
process
sometimes the solution is creating
robust products and services that
mitigate the impact of a variable input
or output on a customer's experience for
example
many electrical utility systems have
voltage variability
up to and sometimes exceeding a 10
percent deviation
from nominal value thus most electrical
products are
built to tolerate the variability
drawing
more amperage without damage to any
components or the unit itself
using six sigma reduces variation in a
process
and thereby reduces waste in a process
it ensures customer satisfaction and
provides process standardization
rework is substantially reduced because
one gets it right
the very first time further six sigma
addresses the key business requirement
six sigma can also be used by
organizations to gain advantage and
become world leaders in their respective
fields
ultimately the whole six sigma process
is to satisfy customers
and achieve organizational goals in the
next screen
let us understand six sigma and quality
taking a process to six sigma level
ensures that the quality of the product
is maintained
the primary goal of improved quality is
increased profits for the organization
in very simple terms quality is defined
as the degree of excellence of a product
or a service provided to the customer
it is conformance to customer
requirement if the customer is satisfied
with the product or service
then the product or service is of the
required quality
let us look at the history of quality in
the next screen
in the mid 1930s statistical process
control
spc was developed by walter shoehart
and used extensively during world war ii
to quickly expand the us's industrial
capabilities
spc is the application of statistical
techniques to control
any process walter shoehart's work on
the common cause of variation
and special cause of variation
assignable has been used proactively in
all
six sigma projects the approach to
quality has varied from time to time
in the 1960s there were quality circles
which
originated in japan it was started by
kaoru ishikawa
quality circles were self-improvement
groups composed of small number of
employees belonging to a single
department
quality circles brought in improvements
with little or no help from the top
management
in 1987 iso 9000 was introduced
iso stands for international
organization for standardization
iso 9000 is a set of international
standards on quality management
and quality assurance to help
organizations implement quality
management systems
iso 9000 is still in effect
baldrige award now known as the malcolm
baldrige
national quality award was developed by
the u s congress in 1987
to raise awareness of quality management
systems as well as
recognize and award u s companies that
have successfully implemented
quality management systems in 1988
another quality approach was developed
known as benchmarking
in this approach an organization
measures its performance against the
best organizations in its field
determines how such performance levels
were achieved
and the information is used by the
organization to
improve itself then in the 1990s
there was the balanced scorecard
approach it is a management tool that
helps managers of all levels
to monitor their results in their key
areas
so that one metric is not optimized
while another is ignored
during the year 1996 through 1997
an approach known as re-engineering was
developed
this approach involved the restructuring
of an entire organization
and its processes integrating various
functional tasks into
cross-functional processes is one of the
examples of
re-engineering in the next screen let us
find out about the quality gurus
and their contribution to the field of
quality
let us focus on six sigma and the
business system
in this screen business systems are
designed to implement a process
or a set of processes a business system
ensures that process
inputs are at the right place and at the
right time
so that each step of the process has the
resource it needs
a business system design should be
responsible for collecting
and analyzing data so that continual
improvement of its
processes products and services is
ensured
a business system has processes sub
processes
and steps as its subsets human resources
manufacturing and marketing are some
examples of
processes in a business system
six sigma improves a business system by
continuously
removing the defects in its processes
and also by
sustaining the changes a defective item
is any product or service that a
customer would reject
a customer can be the user of the
ultimate product or service
or can be the next process downstream in
the business system
let us learn about six sigma projects
and organizational goals in the
following screen
let us understand the structure of the
six sigma team in this screen
there are totally five levels in the six
sigma screen
the first level consists of the top
executives of the organization
these people lead change and provide
direction as they own the vision of the
organization
for any improvement initiative to work
it is important that top management of
the organization be actively involved in
its propagation
the top executives own the six sigma
initiatives
next in the level are six sigma
champions
they identify and scope projects develop
deployment
and strategy and support cultural change
they also identify and coach master
black belts
three to four master black belts work
under every champion
six sigma master black belts train and
coach black belts
green belts and various functional
leaders of the organization
they usually have at least three to four
black belts under them
the fourth level in six sigma structure
is six sigma black belts
they apply strategies to specific
projects and
lead and direct teams to execute
projects
finally there are six sigma green belts
they support the black belt employees
by participating in project teams green
belts
play a dual role they work on the
project and
perform day-to-day jobs related to their
work area
in the next screen we will understand
the drivers and metrics of
organizational strategy
while financial accounting is useful to
track physical assets
the balanced scorecard or bsc offers a
more holistic approach to strategy
implementation
and performance measurement by taking
into account perspectives other than the
financial one
for an organization traditional
strategic activities that concentrate
only on financial metrics
are not sufficient to predict future
performance
they are not sufficient to implement and
control the strategic plan either
bsc translates the organizational
strategy
into actionable objectives that can be
met on an everyday
basis and provides a framework for
performance measurement
the balanced scorecard helps clarify the
organizational vision
and mission to workable action items to
be carried out and measured
it also provides feedback on both
internal business processes
and external outcomes by doing so
it enables continuous improvement in
strategic performance
toward achieving organizational goals
the balanced scorecard
achieves all this by integrating the
organizational strategy
with a limited number of key metrics
from four major areas of performance
finance customer relations internal
processes
and learning and growth many
organizations in the world
use balanced scorecard approaches and
the number
is increasing every day in the next
screen we will describe the balanced
scorecard framework
we will learn about developing a
balanced scorecard in this screen
while applying the balanced scorecard in
an organization
care must be taken to account for
interactions between different
perspectives
or strategic business units and avoid
optimizing the results of one
at the expense of another to outline the
strategy
a top-down approach is followed by
determining the strategic objectives
measures targets and initiatives for
each perspective the strategic
objectives refer to the strategy to be
achieved in that perspective
three or four leading objectives are
agreed upon
the progress towards strategic
objectives is assessed
using specific measures these measures
should be closely related to the actual
performance drivers
this enables effectively evaluating
progress
high level metrics are linked to lower
level operational measures
the target values for each measure are
set the initiatives required to achieve
the target value
are identified as already mentioned
this exercise is carried out for all the
perspectives
finally the scorecard is integrated into
the management system
in the next screen let us understand the
change in the approach to the balance
score card
from the four box model of bsc to
strategy maps
in earlier approaches to the balanced
scorecard the perspectives were
presented in a four box model
this kind of scorecard was more a
comprehensive glance at the key
performance indicators or metrics
in different perspectives however the
key performance indicators or
metrics of different perspectives were
viewed independent of each other
which led to a silo based approach and
lack of integration
however modern scorecards place the
focus on the interrelations between the
objectives
and metrics of different perspectives
and how they support each other
a well-designed balanced scorecard
recognizes the influence of one
perspective on another
and the effect of these interactions on
organizational strategy
to achieve the objectives in one
perspective
it is necessary to achieve the
objectives in another perspective
in short the four perspectives form a
chain of
cause and effect relationships a map of
interlinked objectives
from each perspective is created these
objectives represents the performance
drivers
which determine the effectiveness of
strategy implementation
this is called a strategy map the
function of a strategy map is to outline
what the organization wants to
accomplish
and how it plans to accomplish it the
strategy map is
one page view of how the organization
can create value
for example financial success is
dependent on giving customers what they
want
which in turn depends on the internal
processes
and learning and growth at an individual
level
in the next screen we will look at the
impact of the balanced scorecard on the
organization
the balance scorecard and strategy map
force managers to consider
cause and effect relationships which
leads to better identification of key
drivers
and a more rounded approach to strategic
planning the bsc
enables the organization to improve in
the following ways
being a one-page document a strategy map
can easily be communicated and
facilitates understanding
at all levels of the organization an
organization
is successful in meeting its objectives
only when
everyone understands the strategy the
balance scorecard
also forces an organization to measure
what really matters
and manage information better so that
quality of decision making
is higher creating performance reports
against a balanced scorecard
allows for a structured approach to
reporting progress
it also enables organizations to create
reports and dashboards
to communicate performance transparently
and meaningfully
as expected a balanced scorecard helps
an organization to better align itself
and its processes to the strategic goals
outlined
in the bsc the overall objectives of the
bsc
can be cascaded into each business unit
to enable that unit to work toward the
common organizational goal
all the activities of the organization
such as budgeting or risk management
are automatically aligned to the
strategic objectives
to conclude the balance scorecard is a
simple
and powerful tool that when implemented
correctly
equips an organization to perform better
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will look at what lean
is
and how lean is applied to a process
let us start with the lean concepts in
the next screen
let us look at the process issues in
this screen
lean focuses on three major issues in a
process
known by their japanese names muda mura
and marie muda refers to
non-value-adding work
mura represents unevenness and marie
represents
overburden together they represent the
key aspects
in lean let us look at the types of
waste
in the next screen
there are seven types of muda or waste
as
per lean principles let us understand
these seven types of muta
overproduction this refers to producing
more than is required for example a
customer needed 10 products
and 12 were delivered inventory in
simple words
this refers to stock the term inventory
includes finished goods
semi-finished goods raw materials
supplies kept in waiting and some of the
work in progress
for example test scripts waiting to be
executed by the testing team
defects repairs rejects any product or
service deemed
unusable by the customer or any effort
to make it usable to the original
customer
or a new customer for example errors
found in the source code of a payroll
module by
quality control team motion a waste due
to poor ergonomics of the workplace
for example finance and account teams
sit on the first floor
but invoices to customers are printed on
the ground floor
causing unnecessary personnel movement
over processing additional process on a
product or service to remove unnecessary
attribute or feature
is over processing for example a
customer needs a bottle
and you deliver a bottle with extra
plastic casing
a customer needs abec3 bearing and your
process
is tuned to produce more precise abec
7 bearings taking more time for
something the customer
doesn't need waiting when a part waits
for processing
or the operator waits for work the
wastage of waiting occurs
for example improper scheduling of staff
members
transport when the product moves
unnecessarily in the process
without adding value for example a
product is finished and yet it travels
10 kilometers to the warehouse
before it gets shipped to the customer
another example
an electronic form is transferred to 12
people
some of them seeing the form more than
once that is the form is traveling over
the same space
multiple times next we will look at lean
wastes other than the seven types of
waste discussed some
lean experts talk about additional areas
of waste
under utilized skills skills are
underutilized when the workforce has
capabilities that are not being fully
used toward productive efforts people
are assigned to jobs in which they do
not fit
underperforming processes automation of
poorly performing process
improving a process that should be
eliminated if possible
for example the product returns
department or product discounts process
a symmetry in processes that should be
eliminated
for example two signatures to approve a
cost reduction
and six signatures to reverse a cost
reduction that created higher costs in
other areas
in the next screen we will look at an
exercise on identifying the waste
type we will cover each step of the lean
process
in the next few screens in this screen
we will learn about the first step
identify value to implement lean to a
process
it is important to find out what the
customer wants
once this is done the process should be
evaluated
to identify what it needs to possess to
meet
customer requirements the next screen
will focus
on the next step of the lean process
value stream mapping
in this screen we will discuss the
differences between push and pull
processes
an organization can adopt either of
these processes depending on the
requirement
contrary to a pull process in a push
process
the first step is to forecast the demand
for a product or service
the production line then begins to fill
this demand and produced parts are
stocked
in anticipation of customer demand for
example
a garments manufacturer produces 200
shirts
based on expected demand and then waits
for customer orders for them
note that the demand is expected and not
actual
discounts offered to customers by big
retailers are examples of the push
process
if the garment company adopts a pull
process instead
it would start making the shirts only
after receiving
a confirmed demand from customers note
that although the pull approach
seems better it is not applicable to all
situations
for example a pharmacy uses a push
process
in the next screen we will learn about
theory of constraints
let us look at an example for the toc
methodology
in this screen the three sub processes
in the packing process are coding or
printing
filling and sealing the data for the
three
sub processes are observed and collected
as number of units produced in an hour
the data is as follows coding or
printing is 900 units per hour
filling is 720 units per hour and
ceiling is 780 units per hour
how can you implement the toc
methodology in this example
let us build the toc map for this
example
the first step in the toc methodology is
to identify the constraint
looking at the data the output per hour
from the filling process
is 720 this is the constraint
in the system in the second step the
constraint is exploited by analyzing the
performance
using data to break the constraint a
repair and maintenance personnel can be
assigned to maintain the filling machine
on a daily basis in the third step
the other fixes in the repair and
maintenance function are made as
subordinate decisions to the one taken
in step two in this example carry out
the maintenance of the filling machine
in the fourth step the constraint is
elevated by implementing the decisions
in this example remove the damages from
the filling machine
the next step is to go back to step one
and identify the next system constraint
as per the data collected after
implementation of the first cycle of the
toc
ceiling can be identified as the next
system constraint
let us now analyze the data before and
after toc
implementation in this example the
number of units produced per hour
before implementing the toc encoding or
printing process
was 900 units filling process was 720
units
and sealing process was 780 units
after implementing the toc the number of
units produced per hour for the filling
process
increased to 840 from 720 units
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson
in this topic we will discuss the
concepts in design for six sigma
or dfss let us first understand dfss
in the next screen dfss
or design for six sigma is a business
process methodology that ensures that
any new product or service
meets customer requirements and the
process for that product or service
is already at six sigma level dfss
uses tools such as quality function
deployment or
qfd and failure mode and effects
analysis
or fmea dfss
can help a business system to introduce
an entirely new product or service for
the customer
it can also be used to introduce a new
category of product or service for the
business system
for example an fmcg company plans to
make a new brand of hair
oil a type of product already in the
market
dfss also improves the product or
service
and adds to the current product or
service lines
to implement dfss a business system has
to know its customer requirements
dfss can be used to design a new product
or service
a new process for a new product or
service or
redesign of an existing product or
service to meet customer requirements
let us learn about processes for dfss
in the next screen
the two major processes for dfss are
idov and dmadv
idov stands for identify design
optimize and verify dmadb
stands for define measure analyze
design and verify in the idov
process the first step involves
identifying
specific customer needs based on which
the new product
and business process will be designed
the next step involves design
which involves identifying functional
requirements developing alternate
concepts
evaluating the alternatives selecting a
best fit concept
and predicting sigma capability tools
such as
fmea are used here the third step
optimize uses a statistical approach to
calculate tolerance with respect to the
desired output
when idov is implemented to design a
process
expected to work at six sigma level this
is checked in the optimize
phase if the process does not meet
expectations
the optimize phase helps in developing
detailed design elements
predicting performances and optimizing
design
the last stage of idov is to verify
that is to test and validate the design
and finally to check conformance to six
sigma standards
the other process dmadv has five stages
the first stage is to define the
customer requirements and goals for the
process
product or service next measure and
match performance to customer
requirements
the third stage involves analysis and
assessment of the design for the process
product or service the next step is to
design
and implement the array of latest
processes required for the new process
product or service the final stage is to
verify results and
maintain performance in the next screen
we will look at the differences between
idov
and dmadb
the primary difference between idov and
dmadb is that while i
is used only to design a new product or
service
dmadb can be used to design either a new
product or service
or redesign an existing product or
service
idov involves design of a new process
while dmadv involves redesigning an
existing process in idov
no analysis or measurement of existing
process is done
and the whole development is new the
design
step immediately follows the
identification of customer requirements
in contrast dmadv the existing product
service or process
is examined thoroughly before moving to
the design phase the design stage
comes only after defining requirements
and analyzing the existing product
service or process in the following
screen
we will learn about tool quality
function deployment
or qfd which is one of the dfss
tools qfd
also called voice of customer or voc
or house of quality is a predefined
method of identifying customer
requirements
it is a systematic process to understand
the needs of the customer
and convert them into a set of design
and manufacturing requirements
qfd motivates business to focus on its
customers
and design products that are competitive
in lesser time
and at lesser cost the primary learning
from qfd
includes which customer requirements are
most important
what the organization strengths and
weaknesses are
where an organization should focus their
efforts and where
most of the work needs to be done to
learn from qfd
the organization should ask relevant
questions to customers
and tabulate them to bring out a set of
parameters
critical to the design of the product
apart from understanding customer
requirements
it is also important to know what would
happen if a particular product or
service fails
when being used by a customer it is
necessary to understand the effects of
failure on the customer
to ensure preventive actions are taken
and to be able to answer the customers
in the event of failure in the next
screen
we will look at another dfss tool
failure modes and effects analysis
or fmea
failure modes and effects analysis or
fmea
is a preemptive tool that helps any
system to identify
potential pitfalls at all levels of a
business system
it helps the organization to identify
and prioritize the different
failure modes of its product or service
and what effect the failure would have
on the customer
it helps in identifying the critical
areas in a system on which the
organization's efforts can be focused
note that while fmea enables
identification of critical
areas it does not offer solutions to the
identified problems
we will look at the varieties of fmea
such as
dfmea and pfmea
in the next screen pfmea
stands for process failure mode and
effects analysis
and df-mea stands for design failure
mode
and effects analysis pfmea
is used on a new or existing process to
uncover potential failures
it is done in the quality planning phase
to act as an aid during production
a process fmea can involve fabrication
assembly transactions or services
dfmea is used in the design of a new
product service or process
to uncover potential failures the
purpose is to find out how failure modes
affect the system
and to reduce the effect of failure on
the system
this is done before the product is sent
to manufacturing
all design deficiencies are sorted out
at the end of this process
in the following screen we will
understand fmea
risk priority number
fmea risk priority number or rpm
is a measure used to quantify or assess
risk associated with the design or
process
assessing risk helps identify critical
failure modes
higher the rpn higher the priority the
product or process receives
rpn is a product of three numbers
severity of a failure
occurrence of a failure and the
detectability
of a failure all these numbers are given
a value on a scale of one to ten
the minimum value of rpn is one and the
maximum value is
one thousand a failure mode with a
higher currency rating means the failure
mode occurs very frequently
a mode with a high severity rating means
that the mode is really critical to
ensure
safety of operations a mode with a high
detection rating means that the current
controls are
not sufficient in the next screen we
will look at the fmea
table
the fmea table helps plan improvement
initiatives by underlining
why and how failure modes occur and
helps organizations plan
for their prevention typically fmea
is applied on the output of root cause
analysis
and is a better tool for focus or
prioritization as compared to
multi-voting one important aspect of
fmea
is that it does not need data experts in
a particular area
can form the fmea table without having
to look at data from
any source in functions such as
human resources the fmea table is very
useful
as there might not be much data
available to the problem-solving team
the sample fmea table is given on the
screen
please go through the contents for
better understanding
in the following screen we will discuss
severity of risk priority number
and scale criteria
let us first discuss severity severity
refers to the seriousness of the effect
of the failure mode
or how critical the failure mode is to
the customer
or the process the severity of a failure
mode is rated on a scale
of 1 to 10 using a severity table
different industries follow different
structures for the severity table
a high severity rating indicates a mode
is critical
to operational safety for example
a team working on fmea of a radioactive
plant
may insert fatal as the effect with
rating 10.
another example is the severity table
for a sports team
the team manager wants to rate the
severity of failure of the team in an
upcoming game
she might rate it at nine given that the
team would lose a big sponsorship
should they face defeat which could in
turn be hazardous to the team's future
shown here is a generalized table of
severity
the severity rating can never be changed
for example if a mode has a rating of
nine before improvement it will continue
to have a rating of 9 after improvement
2.
let us look at occurrence of rpm and
scale criteria
occurrence is the probability that a
specific cause will
result in the particular failure mode as
with severity
occurrences rated on a scale of one to
ten based on a table
like the severity table higher the
occurrence of a failure
higher is its rating again this table
might vary depending on the industry and
scenario
sometimes the project team can use data
here if available
based on past data the probability of
occurrence of a failure can easily be
rated
shown here is a generalized table let us
next look at detection of
rpn and scale criteria
detection is the probability that a
particular failure
will be detected the table shown here is
again
a generalized one the rating here is a
bit different from
severity or occurrence higher the
detectability of a failure
lower is its rating this is because if
the failure can easily be detected
then everyone would know of it and
therefore there would be less or no
damage
for example if detection is impossible
the failure is given a rating of ten
please note that at the start of a six
sigma project
the failure mode is given a relatively
high detection rating
let us look at an example of fmea and
rpn in the next screen
in this example a bank wants to
recognize and prioritize the risks
involved in the process of withdrawing
cash from an atm it can be observed from
the table that not having a control in
place for network issues
has the highest rpm this is due to the
detectability for a network issue being
very low
the next set of information in the table
shows the action
taken by the bank's management to
address the failure modes
following the implementation the new rpn
is calculated retaining the security
level
at nine this is because the actions were
not directed at reducing the severity
but at the causes of failure it can be
seen that the new rpn
is much lower and the risk for both
causes
has been mitigated this lesson will
cover the details of the define
phase six sigma can be applied to
everything around
it can be applied across almost 70
different sectors
however it cannot be applied to all
problems
the first step is to check if the
project qualifies to be
a six sigma project the questions that
need to be asked
are as follows is there an existing
process
to implement the dmac methodology of
problem solving
a process needs to exist the process
should be in operation for the
development of the product or service
is there a problem in the process
ideally the process should not have any
problem
if there is a problem in the process
performance
the process needs to be improved
is the problem measurable the problem
has to be measurable
in order to assess the root cause and
the impact of the problem
on the process does the problem
impact customer satisfaction if the
problem
affects customer satisfaction an action
needs to be taken immediately
else the customer may start finding
alternate products
or switch to competitors products
does working on the problem impact
profits of the company
it is very essential to assess the
impact of the project on the profits of
the company
if the project affects the profits of
the company adversely
then such a project is not feasible
is the root cause of the problem unknown
if the root cause of the problem is
visible
then a six sigma project is not required
other problem solving techniques can be
used in this case
is the solution unknown if the solution
to the problem is already
known then there is no need for any
project
the company can directly implement the
solution
the define phase of dmacc will be
introduced
in the next screen the six sigma project
process is known as a dmacc process
define is the first phase in the six
sigma project process
in the define phase the problem is
defined
and the six sigma team is formed
the objectives of the define phase are
as follows
clearly define the problem statement
through customer analysis
understand customer requirements and
ensure
that the six sigma project goals are
aligned to these requirements
define the objectives of the six sigma
project
plan the project in terms of time budget
and resource requirements define the
team structure for the project
and establish roles and responsibilities
in the next screen let us learn about
benchmarking
benchmarking is the process of comparing
an organization's business processes
practices and performance metrics with
that of
industry leaders there are various types
of benchmarking
let us briefly look at each type process
benchmarking
entails comparing specific processes to
a leading company
or an industry standard this is useful
to obtain a simplified view of business
operations
and enables a focused review of major
business functions
process benchmarking includes
comparisons of production processes
data collection processes performance
indicators
and productivity and efficiency reviews
financial benchmarking is performed to
assess overall competitiveness and
productivity
it is done by running a detailed
financial analysis
and analyzing the result performance
benchmarking
involves comparison of products and
services with those of competitors
with the intention of evaluating the
organization's competitiveness
product benchmarking involves designing
new products or services
or upgrading existing products or
services
this can involve reverse engineering a
competitor's products to study the
strengths and weaknesses
and modeling the new product on these
findings
strategic benchmarking refers to
studying strategies
and problem-solving approaches in other
industries
functional benchmarking is the focused
analysis
of a single function with the aim of
improving it
complex functions may need to be divided
into processes
before benchmarking is done competitive
benchmarking
includes standardizing organizational
strategies
process products services and procedures
against the competitors in the same
industry
collaborative benchmarking is a type of
benchmarking where the standardization
of various business parameters
is carried out by a group of companies
and the information
is shared if the subsidiary units of a
company
or its various branches carry out the
benchmarking
it is called collaborative benchmarking
let us take a look at best practices for
benchmarking
in the next screen
best practice is a method that ensures
continuous improvement
leading to exceptional performance it is
also a method to sustain and develop the
process continuously
some of the best practices in
benchmarking are as follows
increase the objectives or scope of
benchmarking
set the standards and path to be
followed at the initial stage
reduce unnecessary effort and comply
with the scope
recognize the best in the industry to
set a benchmark
share the information derived from
benchmarking
in the next screen we will discuss
project selection
let us understand process business
process
and business system in this screen
a process is a series of steps designed
to produce a product or service
to meet the requirement of a customer a
process
mainly consists of three elements input
process and output a business process
is a systematic organization of objects
such as people machinery and materials
into work activities designed to produce
a required product or service
as shown on the screen a process is a
subset
of a business process a business process
is in turn a part of a business system
a business system is a value-added chain
of various business processes
such as sales or finance for example
payroll calculation is a process in the
hr business process
of an i t company which is a business
system
in the next screen we will look at the
process elements
let us discuss the challenges to
business process
improvement in this screen the
improvement to a business process of an
organization
faces challenges due to the traditional
business system structure
because it is generally grouped around
the functional aspect
the main problem in a functionally
grouped organization
is the movement or flow of a product or
service
a product or service has to go through
various functions
and their functional elements to reach
the customer or
end user the other problem is management
of the flow of products or services
across various functional elements
this is difficult as usually there is no
one in charge
these business process improvement
problems can be solved
using the project management approach to
produce the product or service
in the next screen we will learn about
process owners
and different stakeholders of a project
the representation of where the process
owner and stakeholders are placed in the
organizational hierarchy is on the
screen
the process owner is a person at a
senior level in the hierarchy
he is the one who takes responsibility
for the performance and execution of a
process
and also has the authority and the
ability to make necessary changes
on the other hand a stakeholder is a
person
group or organization which is affected
or can affect an organization's actions
businesses have many stakeholders like
stockholders
customers suppliers company management
employees of an organization and their
families the society
etc let us discuss the effects of
process failure
on various stakeholders in the next
screen
while it is an absolute business
necessity to keep one stakeholder
satisfied at all times
failure to meet one or more process
objectives may result in negative
effects on them
in such situations for the stockholders
the perceived value for the company gets
reduced
customers may seek other competitors for
their deals
while imposing penalties and finding
recourse in legal action against the
company
suppliers may be on the losing front
with delayed payments
or not being paid at all company
management may require
cost cut down employees will receive
diminishing wages
the community and society will be
affected due to pollution
created by the organization in the next
screen
we will understand the relationship
between business and the stakeholder
in the diagram shown on the screen each
stakeholder is both a supplier as well
as a customer
forming many closed loop processes that
must be managed
controlled balanced and optimized for
the business to thrive
communication is the key in such
situations and is facilitated through
internal company processes the next
screen covers the importance and
relevance of stakeholder analysis
stakeholder analysis is an important
task to be completed before doing a six
sigma project
a business has many stakeholders and any
change to a business process
affects some or all of them when a
process
does not meet its objectives it results
in the stakeholders being negatively
affected
which in turn affects the organization's
performance
the six sigma team must factor in the
reasons why a stakeholder may oppose the
change effort
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will discuss voice of
the customer
let us start with how to identify the
customer in the following screen
customers are the most important part of
any business
a customer is someone who decides to
purchase pays
consumes and gets affected by a
particular product
or service it is critical to identify
and understand the customer requirements
the products or services can be designed
according to these requirements
consequently the company is able to
provide products or services
the customers are willing to purchase
there are
two types of customers internal and
external customers in the next screen
we will learn about internal customers
an internal customer can be defined as
anyone
within the business system who is
affected by the product or the service
while it is being developed most often
internal customers are the employees of
the company
for example let us assume that there is
a series of processes
in a particular business system in such
a scenario
the second process is the internal
customer for the first process
the third process is an internal
customer for the second process
and so on the basic needs of an internal
customer
are to be provided proper tools and
necessary equipment
imparted proper training and given
specific instructions to carry out their
responsibilities
however the needs are not limited to
these alone
other needs include the provision of
company newsletters projects storyboards
to display the letters etc
team meetings to share business news and
announcements
staff meeting to share information and
quality awards
from suppliers an internal customer
is important first of all the activities
of an
internal customer directly affect the
final or ultimate customer
secondly the activities of an internal
customer affect the next process in the
system
finally an internal customer also
affects the quality of the product
developed
or service provided when the needs of
the internal customers
in most cases employees are met
they are more likely to have higher
perceptions of quality
and also contribute to greater
productivity
the satisfaction levels of the internal
customers
can be improved in various ways these
include
a higher amount of internal
communication through company
newsletters and
team meetings recognitions for work
quality
awards etc constant training on how to
be ahead and well equipped in a
competitive environment
is very essential too in the next screen
we will learn about external customers
this screen focuses on the positive
effects of a project
on the customers the most important
aspect of any process
improvement project is the customers
internal customers
are the ones who drive the project hence
the effect of the project on internal
customers
is a critical factor that needs to be
considered
the positive impact of a project on the
internal customers
is as follows the project is driven by
highly
motivated individuals or internal
customers
who are aware of the project objectives
and scope
individuals belonging to a credible
project
understand the project deliverables and
display
high levels of job satisfaction these
individuals go the extra mile
to take up tasks beyond their job
description
such individuals make a highly motivated
team focused on delivering their
responsibilities in order to meet the
customer requirements
working together in a positive
environment also
improves team spirit and bonding
the positive impact of a project on the
external customers
is as follows process improvement
projects
analyze the problems and come up with an
effective solution
consequently ensuring a better product a
successful process
improvement project assists the
organization in effectively meeting
customer expectations
or requirements there is visible
improvement in customer service
good quality product and service ensures
high customer satisfaction
let us learn about different methods of
customer data collection
in the following screen
once you begin to identify the customer
types
you need to look forward to collecting
customer data
collecting data from customers is very
essential
as it helps consider the levels at which
these customers affect the business
begin by collecting feedback from both
internal as well as external customers
customer feedback helps fill the gaps
and improve the various business
processes
in the organization it helps define a
good quality product as perceived by the
customer
and identify qualities that make the
competitors products or service better
it also helps identify factors which
provide a competitive edge to the
product or service on
offer there are various methods to
collect feedback from the customers
many of you might be involved in a
similar activity at some point or the
other
popular and common methods are surveys
conducted through questionnaires
focus groups individual interviews with
the customers
customer complaints received via call
centers emails
and feedback forms are also quite
prevalent
feedback received in this form are from
dissatisfied customers
in the next screen we will learn about
questionnaires
let us discuss the advantages and
disadvantages of questionnaires
in this screen the advantages of a
questionnaire are that it costs less
the phone response rate is high anywhere
from around 70 to 90 percent
and it produces faster results also
analysis of male questionnaires requires
few trained resources
questionnaire is a method used to gather
data
however there are a few disadvantages
associated with it
there may be incomplete results and
unanswered questions
leading to a lack of clarity the
response rate of mail surveys
is about 20 to 30 percent only at times
phone surveys can produce undesirable
results
as the interviewer can influence the
person being interviewed
we will differentiate between telephone
survey
and web survey in the next screen
there are different methods to collect
data for a survey
the methods need to be based on the
requirements and needs of the
organization
the popular methods of survey are the
telephone survey
and web survey both have their own
drawbacks and benefits which are given
on the screen
the organization needs to choose a
method of collecting data
according to the situation it is
recommended to go through the content
for a better understanding
in the next screen we will learn about
focus groups
let us now discuss the advantages and
disadvantages of using a focus group for
data collection
the interaction in a focus group
generates information
provides in-depth responses and can
address more complex questions or
qualitative data
it is an excellent platform to get
critical to quality or ctq definitions
as well on the other hand the
disadvantages of focus groups are that
the learning only applies to those
within the group
and it is not possible to generalize
the information collected is more
qualitative than quantitative
which is another drawback additionally
they can also generate a lot of
information from anecdotes
and incidents experienced by the
individuals in the group
in the next screen we will discuss the
interview technique
this screen discusses advantages and
disadvantages of using the interview
technique for data collection
interviews have a capability to handle
complex questions
and a large amount of information they
also allow
us to use visual aids in the process it
is a better method to be employed when
people
do not respond willingly and or
accurately by phone or email
however there are some shortcomings as
well
interviews are time consuming and the
resources or
interviewer needs to be trained and
experienced to carry out the task
let us discuss the importance and
urgency of these inputs in the next
screen
the table shows the importance and
urgency of different kinds of input
to understand the kind of input to be
chosen
different kinds of methods for
collecting data are identified
telephone survey web survey and
interview are the data collection
methods identified
to select the best methods the criteria
or the factors which are important to
the organization
are listed the criteria are the factors
based on which an organization is going
to make decisions
the list of factors is then given
weightage based on the importance of
each factor in decision making
as seen cost is the most important
criterion for which the weightage is
given twenty
response rate of the customer is next
important factor
and the list follows visualizing feature
and compiling and analyzing data are the
factors which have the lowest impact on
the decision of selecting the methods
for data collection each of the data
collecting methods is rated between 1
and 10
based on its impact on the listed
factors with 10 being highly favorable
to the organization
and one being least favorable after
rating all the methods with the factors
listed the sum
or total is calculated the calculation
of the total
involves multiplying each methods rating
with the factor weightage
and adding all the multiplied values of
the column
that is for telephone survey the rating
is multiplied with factors rating
eight multiplied by twelve plus eight
multiplied by
six plus three multiplied by twenty
plus five multiplied by five plus three
multiplied by
five plus seven multiplied by fifteen
plus one multiplied by ten plus seven
multiplied by three plus zero multiplied
by two plus
three multiplied by two plus one
multiplied by ten
plus seven multiplied by five plus
eight multiplied by five and the total
of this is four hundred seventy one
in a similar way calculate the total
value for the remaining
two methods the total of other two
methods are 744
and 522 respectively
looking at the overall total of the
methods 744
is the highest hence web survey is the
best method for the organization to use
for data collection
let us look at the pros and cons of
customer complaints data
in the next screen there are pros and
cons in gathering information from
customer complaints
advantages include availability of
specific feedback directly from the
customer
and ease in responding appropriately to
every customer on the contrary
feedback in this method does not provide
an adequate sample size
and may lead to processed changes based
on one or two inputs from the customer
the next screen will discuss the
difference between product complaint
and expedited service request
product complaints and expedited service
requests
can act as inputs to the company for
improving their process
these details address the needs of the
customer in an indirect way
a product complaint means that the
customer is not happy with the product
that he has purchased from the company
an expedited service request means a
service request is being rushed
if the customer requires the items
immediately
then an expedited service request is
raised from the customer
and the organization tries to fulfill it
to please the customer
product complaint implies that a product
is not meeting customers specification
hence it has to be improved expedited
service request
implies that service timeliness are not
meeting customer requirements
hence service has to be improved product
complaint also
implies that the customer needs for
product are not completely identified
whereas expedited service request
implies that the customer timings
need to be recalculated let us discuss
the importance
and urgency of these inputs in the next
screen
the table shows the importance and
urgency of different kinds of input
to select the best methods the criteria
or the factors which are important to
the organization
are listed the criteria are the factors
based on which organization is going to
make decisions
these factors are then given weightage
based on the importance of each factor
in decision making
as seen cost involved and identification
of customer need
are the most important criteria for
which the weightage given is 15
and the list follows time consumption
and compiling and analyzing data are the
factors which have the least impact on
the decision
of selecting the methods for data
collection
each method is rated between 1 and 10
based on its impact of the listed
factors
with 10 being highly favorable to the
organization
and one being least favorable to the
organization
after reading all the methods with the
factors listed the summer total is
calculated
calculation of the total is derived by
multiplying each methods rating with the
factor weightage
and adding all the multiplied values
that is
for product complaint the rating is
multiplied with the factors rating
eight multiplied by fifteen plus four
multiplied by fifteen
plus three multiplied by two plus one
multiplied by ten plus one
multiplied by ten plus one multiplied by
ten
plus one multiplied by eight plus one
multiplied by ten
plus four multiplied by two plus one
multiplied by eight
plus one multiplied by ten and the total
of this
is two hundred sixty in the similar way
calculate the total value for expedited
service request
the total of expedited service request
is eight hundred seventeen
and hence it is effective to the
organization
let us discuss the key elements of data
collection tools in the next screen
data collection tools will be selected
based on the type of data to be
collected
the key elements that make these tools
effective are as follows
data is collected directly from the
primary source or customer
hence there is no scope for
miscommunication or loss of information
data is collected exclusively for the
stated purpose
hence data is highly reliable the data
is captured
is after understanding the
organizational purpose
this makes the data exclusively relevant
and serves the purpose of the
organization
data is collected instantaneously when
there is a requirement
this ensures that the data is up to date
hence the data
is valid the tools accurately define
customer requirements
the customer requirements could be
current needs or improvement to the
product or service that they are
currently using
the tools help to get enough information
about customer requirement
through which the process for improving
or creating the product or service that
the customer requires
can be developed in the next screen we
will discuss how the collected data can
be reviewed
collated data must be reviewed to
eliminate vagueness
ambiguity and any unintended bias
nutra worldwide buys laptops for its
employees from a company that is into
manufacture and sales of laptops
the company also provides servicing and
repairs for their products to the
customers
to understand the level of customer
satisfaction in neutral worldwide
and to improve its process the laptop
company is conducting a survey
the questionnaire which was prepared
initially questionnaire
before review had questions that led to
ambiguity
vagueness and unintended bias let us
look at each item on the survey
to understand the level of usage of the
laptop and to know their customer better
the survey is raising a question related
to the occupation of the customer
it gives the option of student or
professional
but with this low amount of information
the company is neither able to gather
the information
nor will the given option cover the
entire possible occupation in the market
including an option of other please
specify would help the customer to
choose and provide the information
if he does not belong to one of the two
given groups
hence the same is added in the review so
that the customer will not be in any
ambiguity
while filling the questionnaire the
question whether the sales executive was
supportive
with an option of yes or no is a
question which leads again to ambiguity
and unintended bias the customer might
be partially happy
or partially not happy but the choice
does not let them inform their exact
feeling
if the customer selects no as the option
then the company does not get enough
information to understand
where their sales executive went wrong
hence in the reviewed questionnaire
the customer is asked to rate the
qualities of their sales executive
which will provide better data to the
company in order to
improve the process next we will discuss
a technique
named voice of customer
the voice of customer is a technique to
organize
analyze and profile the customer's
requirements
voice of the customer is an expression
for listening to the external customer
the table shows the customer
requirements while purchasing an air
conditioner
in all cases the customer is purchasing
for his or her domestic usage
each customer is further categorized
according to his needs and requirements
when the customer says that he needs a
silent air conditioner
he needs sound sleep at night in the
bedroom this is primarily
to remain fresh the next morning and to
get rid of the noisy ceiling fan
being used currently in case the
customer says that he needs an efficient
ac
he needs a machine which provides good
cooling at night in the bedroom this is
mainly because it gets extremely hot in
summer
also he currently uses a ceiling fan
which is not so effective in summers
on the other hand when the customer
wants to buy an ac which is not too
costly
he has limited cash for the purchase he
wants to purchase
a low-cost ac let us discuss the
importance of translating customer
requirements in the next screen
customer requirement is the data
collected from customers
that gives information about what they
need or want from the process
customer requirements are often high
level vague and non-specific
some customers may give you a set of
specific requirements to the business
but broadly customers requirements are a
reflection of their experience
customer requirements when translated
into critical process
requirements that are specific and
measurable are called
critical to quality ctq factors
a fully developed ctq has four major
elements
output characteristic y metric target
and specification or tolerance limits
we will discuss the meaning of ctq in
the next screen
let us understand what quality function
deployment is
in this screen qfd is a process to
ensure that the customers
wants and needs are heard and translated
into technical characteristics
it is also known as the voice of the
customer or
house of quality qfd is a process to
understand the customer's needs
and translate them into a set of design
and manufacturing requirements
while motivating businesses to focus on
their customers
it also helps companies to design and
build more competitive products in less
time
and lesser costs qfd helps in
prioritizing customer requirements
recognizing strengths and weaknesses of
an organization
and recognizing areas that need to be
worked on and areas that need
immediate focus of efforts qfd is
carried out by asking relevant questions
to the customers
and tabulating them to bring out a set
of parameters
critical to the product design let us
discuss
phases of qfd in the next screen
quality function deployment involves
four phases
phase one product planning in this phase
the qfd
team translates the customer
requirements into product technical
requirements
phase two product design in this phase
the qfd team translates the identified
technical requirements
into key part characteristics or systems
phase three process planning
in this phase the qfd team identifies
the key
process operations necessary to achieve
the identified key part characteristics
phase four production planning or
process
control in this phase the qfd team
establishes process control plans
maintenance plans and training plans to
control
operations next we will understand the
structure
of qfd let us see what happens
after completing the hoq matrix
completing one hoq matrix is not the end
of the qfd process the output of the
first
hoq matrix can be the first stage of the
second
qfd phase as shown in the image
the translation process is continued
using
linked hoq type matrices until the
production planning targets are
developed
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will discuss the basics
of project management
let us start with a discussion on
problem statement
every six sigma project targets a
problem that needs to be resolved
the first step of project initiation is
defining the problem statement
a problem statement needs to describe
the problem in a clear and concise
manner
a problem statement needs to identify
and specify
the observed gap in performance it
should indicate the current performance
state of a process
and the required performance state
completely derived from
customer requirements a problem
statement should be quantifiable
this means it should have specified
metrics including the respective units
please note that the problem statement
cannot contain solutions
or causes for the problem in the next
screen we will discuss the
is or is not template
the is or is not technique was first
popularized by kepner trigo
incorporated in the seventies it is a
powerful tool that helps define the
problem
and gather required information an
example of a problem statement of
paper cup leaks is given on the screen
the six sigma team has to answer what is
the problem
what isn't the problem where is it where
isn't it
when is it when isn't it the problem to
what extent
is it a problem and to what extent isn't
it a problem
the information is then used to fill the
question areas in
the is and is not issue template in the
analysis phase
if a cause cannot describe the is and
the is not data
then it's not likely the main cause in
the next screen
we will list the criteria for the
project objectives
the project objectives must meet the
smarts criteria
smarts is an acronym of the
characteristics desired in project
objectives
specific measurable attainable
relevant time based and stretch
the project deliverables should be
specific
example hospitals maintain records of
all patients
often a few forms are rejected or missed
due to errors in recording the id
numbers
in this case setting the objective as
reduce form rejection
is very vague instead reduce
patient id errors in recording lab
results
is specific and effectively targets
solving the problem
the project objectives should be
quantifiable
example setting the objective as fewer
form rejections
is very vague instead reduce patient id
errors by 30 percent sets a specific
goal
the project objectives should be
achievable
and practical the project objectives
should be relevant to the problem the
project objectives
must specify a time frame within which
they should be delivered
the project objectives must not be
easily achievable
example most problems and errors can be
reduced by
creating awareness hence the objective
must stretch beyond
the easily attainable state in the next
screen
we will understand project documentation
project documentation refers to creating
documents to provide details about the
project
such documents are used to gain a better
understanding of the project
prevent and resolve conflict among
stakeholders
and share plans and status for the
project
documentation of a project is critical
throughout the project
some of the benefits achieved through
project documentation are mentioned
below
documentation serves as written proof
for execution of the project
it helps teams achieve a common
understanding of the requirements
and the status of the project it removes
personal bias as there is a documented
history of discussions
and decisions made for the project
depending on the nature of the project
each project produces
a number of different documents some of
these documents are the project
charter project plan and its subsidiary
plans
other examples of project documentation
include
project status reports including key
milestones report
risk items and pending action items
the frequency of these reports is
determined by the need and complexity of
the project
these reports are sent to all
stakeholders to keep them abreast of the
status of the project
another example of project documentation
is the final project report
this report is prepared at the end of
the project and includes a summary of
the complete project
project storyboard inputs generated from
statistical tools
outputs from spreadsheets checklists and
other miscellaneous documents
are also classified as project documents
in the next screen we will understand
project charter
we will list the project charter
sections in this screen
the major sections of a project charter
are project name and description
business requirements name of the
project manager
project purpose or justification
including roi
stakeholder and stakeholder requirements
broad timelines
major deliverables constraints and
assumptions
and the budget summary of the charter in
the next screen we will understand the
project plan
a project plan is the final approved
document
which is used to manage and control the
various processes
within the project and ensure its
seamless execution
the project manager uses the project
charter as an input to create a detailed
project plan
a project plan comprises various
sections
prominent among them being the project
management approach
the scope statement the work breakdown
structure
the cost estimates scheduling defining
performance baselines
marking major milestones to be achieved
and the key
members and required staff personnel for
the project
it also includes the various open and
pending decisions
related to the project and the key risks
involved
additionally it also contains references
to other subsidiary plans
for managing risk scope schedule etc
in the next screen we will learn about
project scope
we will look at different techniques
used for interpreting the project scope
in this screen project scope can be
interpreted from the problem statement
and project charter
using various tools like the burrito
chart and the cypoc map
the principle behind the burrito chart
or the 80
20 principle as we know it is a vital
few
trivial many the burrito chart helps the
teams to trim the scope of the project
by identifying the causes which have a
major impact on the outcome
of the project the cypac map is a high
level
process map which helps all team members
in
understanding the process functions in
terms of addressing questions
like who are the suppliers what are the
inputs they provide
what are the outputs that can be
obtained
and who are the customers as discussed
earlier
cypoc stands for suppliers inputs
process outputs and customers
in the subsequent screen we will learn
about process
maps scipok
is a macro level map that provides an
overview of the business process
where a process map is a micro level
flow chart
that provides an in-depth detail of a
process
the process map covers details at all
levels
and provides a walk through the current
process experience
the cypac map is used as a basis while
drawing a process map
a level one process map provides
in-depth information
but the final process map drills further
into detail
in the following screen we will
understand the project metrics
let us discuss consequential metrics in
this screen
consequential metrics measure any
negative consequences
these can be business metrics process
metrics
or both they measure the negative
effects of improving the primary
or key metrics they are used to measure
the indemnity
triggered by any damage in the project
the inconsistent use of consequential
metrics
can lead to loss of opportunity and
rework
after a project ends consequential
metrics
help to understand the cause and effect
relationship
between the primary and the secondary
metrics
and the impact it has on the
organization
let us take a look at an example for
consequential metrics
in the next screen
we will discuss the best practices in
this screen
the following are some of the best
practices of consequential metrics
setting consequential metrics during the
measure phase
and monitoring these metrics after
finalizing the project
will help to analyze whether the link
between previous primary
and secondary metrics has been
established
also linking consequential metrics with
primary metrics
and finally linking them with secondary
metrics
provides clarity on the impact of these
metrics
assessing and evaluating the cause and
effect relationship
between these metrics is helpful to the
organization
as a whole in the next screen we will
list some project planning tools
the project manager uses various tools
to plan
and control a project one of the tools
which he uses
is the burrito chart other prominent
tools include the network diagram
the critical path method also called cpm
the program evaluation and review
technique
which is also known as pert gantt charts
and the work breakdown structure also
known as
wbs in the next screen
we will discuss burrito chart
pareto chart is a histogram ordered by
the frequency of occurrence of
events it is also known as the 80 20
rule
or vital few trivial many
it helps project teams to focus on the
issues which cause the highest number of
defects
or complaints to explain further
the given chart plots all the causes for
defects in a product or service
the values are represented in descending
order by bars
and the cumulative total is represented
by the line
burrito chart emphasizes that 80 percent
of the effects
come from 20 percent of the causes
thus a burrito chart narrows the scope
of the project
or problem solving by identifying the
major causes affecting quality
pareto charts are useful only when
required data is available
if data is not available then other
tools
such as brainstorming and multi-voting
should be used to find the root cause of
any problem in the following screen we
will continue to discuss burrito chart
with an example
a hotel receives plenty of complaints
from its customers
and the hotel manager wishes to identify
the key areas of complaints
complaints were received in the
following areas cleaning
check-in pool timings minibar room
service
and miscellaneous cleaning and check-in
can be noted as areas of concern
with 35 and 19 complaints respectively
is calculated for each cause of
complaint and the cumulative is derived
burrito chart is plotted using this data
in the next screen we will discuss
network diagrams
network diagrams are one of the tools
used by the project manager
for project planning they are also
sometimes referred to as
arrow diagrams because they use arrows
to connect activities
and represent precedence and
interdependencies between
activities of a project there are some
assumptions that need to be made while
forming the network diagram
the first assumption is that before a
new activity begins
all pending activities have been
completed
the second assumption is that all arrows
indicate
logical precedence this means that the
direction of the arrow
represents the sequence that activities
need to follow
the last assumption is that a network
diagram must start from a single event
and end with a single event there cannot
be multiple start
and end points to the network diagram in
the next screen
let us discuss some terms related to
network diagram
for the network diagram to calculate the
total duration of the project
the project manager needs to define four
dates
for each task the first two dates relate
to the date by when the task
can be started the first date is early
start
this is the earliest date by when the
task can start
the second date is late start this is
the last date by when the task
should start the second two dates relate
to the dates when the task
should be complete early finish is the
earliest date by when the task
can be completed late finish is the last
date by when the task
should be completed the duration of the
task is calculated as the difference
between the early start and early finish
of the task
the difference between the early start
and late start of the task
is called the slack time available for
the task
slack can also be calculated as the
difference between
the early finish and late finish dates
of the task
slack time or float time for a task is
the amount of time the task can be
delayed
before it causes a delay in the overall
project timeline
in the next screen we will discuss
critical path method
critical path method also known as cpm
is an important tool used by project
managers to
monitor the progress of the project and
to ensure that the project is on
schedule
the critical path for a project is the
longest
sequence of tasks on the network diagram
the critical path in the given network
diagram is highlighted in orange
critical path is characterized by zero
slack
for all tasks on the sequence this means
that the smallest delay
in any of the tasks on the critical path
will cause
a delay in the overall timeline of the
project
this makes it very important for the
project manager to closely
monitor the tasks on the critical path
and ensure that the tasks go smoothly
if needed the project manager can divert
resources
from other tasks that are not on the
critical path to
task on the critical path to ensure that
the project is not delayed
when a project manager removes resources
from such tasks
he needs to ensure that the task does
not become a critical path task
because of the reduced number of
resources during the execution of the
project
the critical path can easily shift
because of multiple factors
and hence needs to be constantly
monitored by the project manager
a complex project can also have multiple
critical paths
in the next screen we will discuss
project evaluation and
review technique
we will understand the concept of risk
in this screen
risk is an uncertain event or
consequence
probable of occurring during a project
the main objectives
of any project are time cost quality
and scope risk affects at least one of
the four project objectives
it is important to understand that risk
can be both positive
as well as negative a positive risk
enhances the success of the project
whereas a negative risk is a threat to a
project's success
some of the terms used in risk analysis
and management
are risk probability issue and risk
consequences
the likelihood that a risk will occur is
called risk
probability to assess any risk is to
assess the probability and
impact of the risk issue is the
occurrence of a risk
risk consequences are the effects on
project objectives
if there is an occurrence of a risk or
issue
in the subsequent screen we will
understand the process of risk analysis
and management
we will list and understand some of the
elements of risk analysis
in this screen qualitative method
qualitative methods like interview
checklists and brainstorming
are used to identify potential risks
quantitative method quantitative methods
are databased and a computer is required
to calculate
and analyze these methods are used to
evaluate the cost
time and probabilistic combination of
individual
uncertainties feasibility
feasibility is the study of the project
risk
this is usually carried out in the
beginning of the project
when the project is most flexible and
risks can be reduced at a relatively low
cost
it helps in deciding different
implementing options for the projects
potential impact once the potential
risks are identified
the impact of these on the project is
determined
using this data possible solutions for
the risks are identified
rpn rpn of a failure
is the product of its probability of
occurrence severity
and detectability a failure is
prioritized
based on its rpn value a high
rpn indicates high risk rpn
assists to prioritize risks avoiding
risk
when potential risks are identified
their impact in terms of cost
time resources and objective perspective
is calculated if the impact is huge
then avoiding the risk is the best
option
mitigating risk mitigating is the second
option when dealing with risks
the loss that arises from mitigating a
risk is much less than the loss that
arises from the temporary avoiding a
risk
accepting the risk if a risk cannot be
avoided or mitigated then it has to be
accepted
the risk will be accepted if it doesn't
greatly impact the cost
time and product objective in the
following screen
we will discuss benefits of risk
analysis
benefits of risk analysis are as follows
once the risk has been identified it can
be either mitigated
transferred or accepted when risk is
identified in
a task slack time is provided as a
buffer
identifying risks also helps in setting
up an actual
timeline for a project slack time for an
activity in a project
could be the result of a risk identified
proactively
identifying risks helps in setting
realistic expectations
from the project by communicating the
risk probability
and consequence to stakeholders risk
analysis also helps to identify
and plan contingency activities if the
risk becomes an issue
the project team is then well prepared
to work on the issue
thereby reducing the impact of the risk
in the following screen we will take a
look at the risk assessment matrix
the potential risks of a project are
assessed using the risk assessment
matrix
it covers potential risk areas like
project
scope team personnel material facility
and equipment
and communication each of these areas is
assessed in terms of risk of loss of
money productivity
resources and customer confidence in the
subsequent screen
we will discuss project closure
by definition a project has a beginning
and an
end but without a formal closure process
project teams can fail to recognize the
end and then
the project can drag on sometimes at
great expense
every project requires closure for
larger complex projects
it's a good idea to close each major
project phase
for example design code and test
individually
project closure ensures that outcomes
match the stated goals of the project
customers and stakeholders are happy
with the results
critical knowledge is captured the team
feels a sense of completion
and project resources are released for
new projects
in the next screen we will list the
goals of a project closure report
the project closure report is created to
accomplish the following goals
review and validate the success of the
project
confirm outstanding issues limitations
and recommendations outline tasks and
activities accomplished to complete the
activity
highlight the best practices for future
projects
provide the project report or summary
provide a project background overview
summarize the planned activities of a
project
evaluate project performance provide a
synopsis of the process
generate discussions and recommendations
generate project closure recommendations
in the following screen we will list and
understand
project closure activities
during project closure the project
manager needs to take care of the
following activities
finalize the project documents much of a
project's documentation
is created during the life of the
project
document collection and update
procedures are well established during
the project lifeline
capture the project knowledge project
documents are helpful
for future projects in troubleshooting
the product
or in a future audit set up a project
library
ideally the project library is set up at
the beginning of the project
and team members add documents as they
produce them
document the project learnings project
learnings can be captured through team
meetings
meetings with stakeholders and sponsor
and through
feedbacks from consultants and vendors
provide knowledge transfer the project
manager
needs to provide a summary of the
project results to
team members either as a presentation at
a meeting
or as a formal document consultants
should not be relieved from their
position until they have transferred all
the important product maintenance
knowledge
to the team get a final sign off
schedule a meeting with the project
sponsor and key stakeholders to get
their final sign off on the project
close the project office if the project
team
used a project management office or a
dedicated work area
arrangements need to be made to return
that space for general use
recognize and reward the project manager
has the best understanding of which of
the team members have worked the best
have transformed themselves with new
skills and who might be ready for a new
level of responsibility
the project manager needs to report to
the team superiors
what each team member has brought to the
project
celebrate after completion of every
project
the team needs and deserves a
celebration
a team dinner a team outing gift
certificates or
other rewards are minor costs that
generate a large return
in terms of morale and job satisfaction
make a public announcement an
announcement to the organization
is a good way to highlight the success
of the project
and its benefits to the company conclude
formal project closure ensures that the
team has met
its objectives satisfied the customer
captured important knowledge and been
rewarded for their efforts
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will discuss management
and planning tools
let us start with the discussion on
affinity diagram in the next screen
the affinity diagram method is employed
by an individual
or team to solve unfamiliar problems
it is an effective medium where the
consensus of the group is necessary
the given affinity diagram is based on
an organization
where the employees are not satisfied
to begin with each member writes down
ideas and opinions on sticky notes
each note can have a single idea the
points which have
surfaced during the brainstorming
session are that the workers are
unkind pay is low and it is difficult to
survive on the pay structure
working hours are too long etc
in the next step all the sticky notes
are pasted on a table or wall
the sticky papers are arranged according
to categories
or thought patterns members happen to
arrange their ideas based on affinity
in case a particular idea is good to go
into more than one
category it is duplicated and added to
several categories
after the arrangement is done each
category is named with a header card
the header card captures the central
idea of all the cards in that category
and draws a boundary around them poor
compensation
combines ideas like low pay long working
hours
and complaints about wages poor work
environment
encompasses issues like poor lighting
uncomfortable rooms
and stuffy air similarly poor
relationships prevail in the workspace
as the workers are unkind and there is
mutual dislike
lack of motivation is due to repetitive
work and no work related challenges
you can see in the diagram on that slide
that once all the ideas are grouped
to the respective header cards a diagram
is drawn
and borders are placed around the group
of ideas
thus affinity diagram helps in grouping
ideas with the common theme
in the next screen we will discuss the
interrelationship
diagram
during problem solving the
inter-relationship diagram
technique helps in identifying the
relationship between
problems and ideas in complex situations
if the problem is really complex it may
not be easy to determine the exact
relationship between ideas
given inter-relationship diagram is the
result of a team
brainstorming session which identified
10 major issues involved in developing
an organization's quality plan
initially the problem is defined and all
the members put down
their ideas on sticky notes each note
contains only one idea
all the sticky notes are put on a table
for a random display
in the next step the causes or areas of
concern
are identified and a cause effect
arrangement of cards is constructed
by drawing an arrow between the causes
and effects of the cause
this is done until all the ideas on the
sticky notes are accounted for
and made a part of the interrelationship
diagram
take a large sheet of paper and
replicate the cause effect arrangement
on it
as depicted in the image a large number
of outgoing arrows indicate the root
cause
whereas a higher number of incoming
arrows indicates an
outcome there are as many as six arrows
originating from lack of quality
strategy
this leads us to understand that it is a
root cause
on the other hand there are three arrows
ending with the idea
lack of tqm commitment by managers
making it an outcome in the next screen
we will understand the tree diagram
the tree diagram is a systematic
approach to outline all the details
needed to complete a given objective
in other words it is a method used to
identify the tasks and methods needed
to solve a problem and reach a
predefined goal
it is mostly used while developing
actions to execute a solution
while analyzing processes in detail
during the evaluation of implementation
issues for several potential solutions
and also
as a communication tool to explain the
details of a process to others
the given tree diagram shows the plan of
a coffee shop
trying to set standards for the coffee
it delivers
first the objective is noted on a note
card and placed on the far
left side of the board the basic goal of
the coffee shop
is to provide a delightful cappuccino
experience
in the next step the coffee shop needs
to determine the means required to
achieve the goal
and furnish three different solutions in
other words
the answers to the how or why questions
of the objectives
in this case the cappuccino needs to be
at a comfortable temperature
and it should have strong and pleasing
coffee aroma
with the right amount of sweetness in
the next step
the three issues mentioned in the second
stage are addressed at length
each issue is answered by maintaining
the espresso
and steamed milk temperature the
cappuccino can be served at a palatable
temperature
strong flavored cappuccino can be
prepared using a good amount of finely
ground coffee beans
and a good quality sweetener used in the
right amount
makes a great cappuccino thus
the tree diagram can be used to achieve
a goal or define a process
in the following screen we will discuss
prioritization
matrices let us learn
about matrix diagram in this screen
matrix diagrams show the relationship
between
objectives and methods results and
causes
tasks and people etc their objective
is to provide information about the
relationship
they provide importance of task and
method elements of the subject
they also help determine the strength of
relationships between a grid of rows and
columns
they help in organizing a large amount
of inter-process related activities
let us discuss various types of matrices
in the next screen
let us learn about a process decision
program chart
in this screen process decision program
chart or the pdpc method
is used to chart the course of events
from the beginning of a process
till the goal while emphasizing the
ability to identify the failure
of important issues on activity plans
the pdpc helps create appropriate
contingency plans
to limit the number of risks involved
the pdpc
is used before implementing a plan
especially when the plan is
large and complex if the plan must be
completed on schedule
or if the price of failure is quite high
the given process decision program chart
shows the process which can help in
securing a contract
the process starts when the seller
receives an order request from a
potential buyer
this can lead to fixing an appointment
with the buyer
confirming the appointment date and
meeting the buyer
if the date is not fixed then buyers
should be contacted till the meeting is
confirmed
without a meeting there is a risk of
losing the order
considering an optimistic scenario where
a meeting is fixed with the buyer
the seller describes the price of the
product or service
if the price is competitive the order is
secured
if the price is not competitive the
seller may have to repeat the bid until
the buyer agrees
and the order is secure however the
buyer
may not agree to a revised bid either
in which case the seller might lose the
bid
in such a scenario the seller can
justify
the pricing and pursue the buyer to
agree to the bid
it might work and the seller might
secure the order
in the next screen we will discuss the
activity network diagram
an activity network diagram is used to
show the time required for solving a
problem
and to identify items that can be done
in parallel
it is used in scheduling and monitoring
tasks within a complex project
or process with interrelated tasks and
resources
moreover it is also used when you know
the steps of the project or process
their sequence and the time taken by
each of the steps involved
the original japanese name for this tool
is arrow diagram
the given activity network diagram shows
a house construction plan
and identifies the factors involved
separately
like the amount of time for each
operation in one situation
the relationship of work without time
for each operation
and an operation by itself the number of
days is denoted by
d so the time taken for an activity like
foundation to scaffolding takes around
five days
plus four days which is nine days in
total
the line joining electrical work and
interior walls
is dotted this shows relation between
them
but without any timeline basically it
means that
electrical work has to be done before
interior walls
but the time is either not important or
not available
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson
in the following screen
in this topic we will introduce business
results for projects
let us start with the discussion on
defect per unit
we will learn about throughput yield in
this screen
throughput yield or tpy is the number of
acceptable pieces
at the end of a process divided by the
number of starting pieces
excluding scrap and rework throughput
yield is used to measure
a single process only if the dpu
is known tpy can be easily calculated as
e to the power of the negative of dpu
here e is the mathematical constant and
has a value of 2.7183
the expression can also be stated as dpu
equals the negative of natural
logarithm e of tpy
in the next screen we will discuss
rolled throughput yield
rolled throughput yield or rty
is the probability of the entire process
producing
zero defects rty is the true measure of
process
efficiency and is considered across
multiple processes
it is important as a metric when a
process has excessive rework
tdpu is total defects per unit
and is defined for a set of processes
when the total defects per unit is known
rolled throughput yield is calculated
using the expression
e to the power of negative of tdpu
the expression can also be written as
tdpu
is equal to negative of natural
logarithm
of rty when the defectives are known
roll through foot yield can be
calculated as the product of each
process's
first pass yield or fpy
first pass yield is the number of
products which pass without any rework
over the total number of units first
pass yield is calculated as total number
of quality products over
total number of units total number of
quality products is
total number of units minus total number
of defective units
in the following screen we will
understand fby
and rty with an example
we will discuss process capability in
this screen
process capability or cp
is defined as the inherent variability
of a characteristic of a process or a
product
in other words it might also mean how
well a process
meets customer cp
is an indicator of capability of a
process
and is expressed as difference of usl
and lsl divided by product of six sigma
usl stands for upper specification limit
lsl is lower specification limit
and sigma is the standard deviation of a
process
the difference between usl and lsl
is also called the specification with or
tolerance in the following screen we
will discuss
process capability indices
process capability indices or cpk
was developed to objectively measure the
degree to which a process meets or
does not meet customer requirements it
was developed to account for the
position of mean
with respect to usl and lsl
to calculate cpk the first step
is to determine if the process mean is
closer to the lsl
or the usl if the process mean is closer
to
lsl cpkl is determined
cpkl is mean minus lsl
divided by product of 3 and sigma
if the process mean is closer to usl
cpku is calculated cpku
is usl minus mean divided by product of
three
and sigma here mean is the process
average
and sigma represents the standard
deviation
if the process mean is equidistant
either
of the specification limit can be chosen
cpk takes up the value of cpku
and cpkl depending on whichever is the
lower value
in the next screen we will understand
process capability indices
with an example in this screen
we will discuss cpk and cp
interpretations
a cp value of less than 1 indicates the
process
is not capable even if cp
is greater than one to ascertain if the
process really is not capable
check the cpk value a cpk value
of less than one indicates that the
process is definitely
not capable but might be if cp is
greater than one
and the process mean is at or near the
midpoint of the tolerance range
the cpk value will always be less than
cp
especially as long as the process mean
is not at the center
of the process tolerance range
non-centering can happen when the
process
has not understood the customer
expectations clearly
or the process is complete as soon as
the output reaches a specific limit
for example a shirt size of 40 has a
target
chest diameter of 40 inches but the
process
consistently delivers shirts with a mean
of 41 inches as the chest diameter
a machine stops removing material as
soon as the measured dimension is within
specified limit
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson
in the following screen
in this topic we will discuss team
dynamics and performance
let us start with the discussion on team
stages
there are five typical stages in the
team building process
each team passes through these stages as
they start
and proceed through the project the five
stages in the team building process
are as follows forming storming
norming performing and adjourning
in the next screen we will discuss the
first stage forming
the first stage in the team building
process is called the forming stage
in this stage the team comes together
and begins to formulate roles and
responsibilities
the team leader is identified and he or
she starts directing the team
and assigning responsibilities to other
team members
most team members at this stage are
generally
enthusiastic and motivated by desire to
be accepted
within the team the leader employs a
directive style of management
which includes delegating responsibility
within the team
providing a structure to the team and
determining
processes needed for the smooth
functioning of the team
toward the end of this phase the team
should achieve a commitment to the
project
and an acceptance of a common purpose
in the next screen we will discuss the
second stage
storming the second phase
in the team building process is called
the storming stage
as suggested by the name itself in this
stage
conflicts start to arise within the team
team members often struggle over
responsibilities and
control within the project it is the
responsibility of the team leader to
coach
and conciliate the team the leader
employs a coaching style of management
which is reflected through facilitating
change managing conflict
and mediating understanding between
different parties
towards the end of this phase team
members need to learn to voice
disagreement openly
and constructively while staying focused
on common objectives
and areas of agreement in the next
screen
we will discuss the third stage norming
the third stage in the team building
process is called the norming stage
in this stage people get along and the
team develops a unified commitment
toward the project goal
the team leader promotes the team and
participates in the team activities
team members look to the leader to
clarify their understanding
as some leadership roles begin to shift
within the lower
rungs of the group the leader employs a
participatory style of management
through facilitating change working to
build consensus
and overseeing quality control toward
the end of this phase
team members need to accept individual
responsibilities
and workout agreements about team
procedures
in the next screen we will discuss the
fourth stage
performing the next stage in the team
building process
is called the performing stage this is
the most productive stage for the
project team
in this stage team members manage
complex tasks and work toward the common
goals of the project
the leader employs a supervisory style
of management
by overseeing progress rewarding
achievement
and supervising process the team leader
leads the project on more or less an
automated mode
when the project has completed
successfully or when the
end is in sight the team moves into the
final stage
in the next screen we will discuss the
fifth stage
adjourning the last stage of team
building
is called the adjourning stage in this
stage
the project is winding down and the
goals are within reach
the team members are dealing with their
impending separation from the team
the team leader provides feedback to the
team the leader employs a supportive
style of management
by giving feedback celebrating
accomplishments
and providing closure the team leader
needs to adopt a different style of
leadership
at every stage it is therefore important
for a leader to understand these stages
and identify the current stage that a
team is
in the success of the team depends on
how well the leader can guide them
through these phases
in the next screen we will learn about
negative dynamics
team members can exhibit negative
behavior in more than one way
during the project life cycle this
behavior has a negative effect
on the dynamics of the team the first
kind of negative participants fall in
the category of
overbearing participants these
participants
use their influence or expertise to take
on a position of authority
discounting contributions from other
team members
to cope with such participants team
leaders
must establish ground rules for
participation
and reinforce that the group has the
right to explore any area pertinent
to team goals and objectives another
kind of negative participant
is often referred to as the dominant
participant
these participants take up an excessive
amount of group
time by talking too much focusing on
trivial concerns
and otherwise preventing participation
by others
team leaders need to be able to control
dominant participants
without inhibiting their energy or
enthusiasm
some other participants are reluctant
participants
who feel intimidated and are not happy
with the team process
owing to their reluctance they miss
opportunities to bring up data that is
valuable to the project
this can often lead to hostility within
the team
one way to deal with reluctant
participants
is to respond positively and with
encouragement
to any contribution from the team member
teamwork is more than a natural
consequence of working together
team management is more than building a
relationship with individual team
members
all teams face group challenges that
need group based diagnosis
and problem solving to ensure that
negative participants are able to
contribute
and perform as part of the team
in the next screen we will learn about
group challenges
six sigma team and their
responsibilities are described here
various roles assist the smooth
execution
of a six sigma project these roles are
required to support the project
by providing the information and
resources that are needed to
execute the project the first important
member of the six sigma team
is the executive sponsor sponsors are
the source or
conduit for project resources and they
are usually the recipients of the
benefits the project will produce
the sponsor is responsible for setting
the direction and priorities for the
organization
the sponsor may be a functional manager
or an
external customer the next important
role
is that of the process owners they work
with the black belts to improve their
respective processes
they provide functional expertise about
the process
to the project usually this role is
played by the functional managers in
charge of specific processes
the next role in the project is that of
the champions
they are typically upper level managers
who control
and allocate resources to promote
process improvements
they ensure the organization is
providing necessary resources to the
project
and the project is fitting into the
strategic plans
of the organization the first role
related to the execution of the project
is the role of the master black belt
this role
acts as a consultant to team leaders and
offers expertise in the use of
six sigma tools and methodologies
master black belts are experts in six
sigma
statistical tools and are qualified to
teach high level
six sigma methodologies and applications
each master black belt will have
multiple black belts under him
black belts are the leaders of
individual six sigma projects
they lead project teams and conduct the
detailed analysis required
in six sigma methodologies black belts
act as
instructors and mentors for green belts
and
educate them in six sigma tools and
methods
they also protect the interests of the
project by coordinating with
functional managers green belts are
trained in six sigma
but typically lead project teams working
in their own areas of expertise
they are focused on the basic six sigma
tools for acceleration of projects
green belts work on projects on a
part-time basis
dividing time between project and
functional responsibilities
an executive is the person who manages
and leads the team
to ensure smooth working of tasks and
has the power to execute decisions
a coach takes on a number of roles he or
she is the person who
trains mentors teaches and guides the
team
when required coach also motivates and
builds confidence of the members a
facilitator
is a guide for the team or group also
known as a discussion leader
facilitators help the group or team to
understand their common objective
and plan their activities a sponsor
is a person who supports the event or
the project
by providing all the required resources
a team member is an individual who
belongs to a particular project team
a team member contributes to the
performance of the team
and actively participates for
fulfillment of the project objectives
the progress achievements and the
details of the project
have to be effectively communicated to
the team
management customers and stakeholders
we will learn about modes of
communication in the next screen
let us understand communication within
the team in this screen
the purpose of communication within the
team
and the modes of communication used are
as follows
meetings and emails are suitable to
communicate the roles
and responsibilities of the team members
meetings memos and emails are used by
the team to understand the project
status workshops and meetings are
conducted to identify the outstanding
tasks
risks and their corrective actions
team meetings assist decision making
meetings and emails ensure coordination
and efficient work the next screen will
focus on communication
with stakeholders
the purpose of communication with
stakeholders and the modes of
communication used
are as follows meeting emails
and events are suitable to convey
project objectives and goals to
stakeholders
meetings emails and newsletters assist
stakeholders in understanding project
status
workshops meetings and events help
stakeholders to identify
the adverse effects of a situation
meetings with stakeholders assist
decision making process
in the next screen we will discuss the
communication technique
communication techniques can be grouped
in various ways
the first grouping of communication
techniques is based on the direction
in which communication flows vertical
communication
consists of two subtypes namely downward
flow of communication
and upward flow of communication
in the downward flow of communication
the managers
must pass information and give orders
and directives to the lower levels
in the organization on the contrary
upward communication consists of
information relayed from the bottom or
grassroot levels to the higher levels of
the company
horizontal communication refers to the
sharing of information across the same
levels of the organization
this can be in the form of formal and
informal communication
formal communications are official
company sanctioned methods of
communicating to the employees
the grapevine rumor mill etc are some of
the means of
informal communication in the
organization
the second grouping of communication
techniques
is based on the usage of words verbal
communication
includes use of words for communication
via telephone
face to face etc non-verbal
communication
conveys messages without the use of
words through body language
facial expressions etc the last grouping
of communication techniques
is based on participation of the people
involved in communication
one way communication happens when
information is
relayed from the sender to the receiver
without the expectation
of a response like memos and
announcements
two-way communication is a method in
which both parties are involved in the
exchange of information
team tools are a part of the team
dynamics
and performance the various team tools
that are used are
brainstorming nominal group technique
and multi-voting if getting your
learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
this lesson will cover the details of
the measure phase
the key objective of the measure phase
is to gather as much information as
possible
on the current processes this involves
three key tasks that is creating a
detailed process map
gathering baseline data and summarizing
and analyzing the data let us understand
process modeling in the following screen
process modeling refers to the
visualization of a proposed
system layout or other change in the
process
process modeling and simulation can
determine the effectiveness or
ineffectiveness of a new design or
process
they can be done using process mapping
and flow charts
we will learn about these in the
forthcoming screens
let us understand process mapping in
this screen
process mapping refers to a workflow
diagram
which gives a clear understanding of the
process
or a series of parallel processes
it is also known as process charting or
flow charting
process mapping can be done either in
the measure phase
or the analyze phase the features of
process mapping are as follows process
mapping is
usually the first step in process
improvement
process mapping gives a wider
perspective of the problems
and opportunities for process
improvement
it is a systematic way of recording all
the activities performed
process mapping can be done by using any
of the methods
like flow charts written procedures
and detailed work instructions let us
learn
about flowchart in the following screen
a flowchart is a pictorial
representation
of all the steps of a process in
consecutive order
it is used to plan a project document
processes
and communicate the process methodology
with others
there are many symbols used in a
flowchart
and the common symbols are shown in the
given table
it is recommended you take a look at the
symbols and their description
for better understanding click the
button to view an example
of a flowchart
the given flowchart shows the processes
involved in
software development the flowchart
starts with the start box which connects
to the design box
in a software project a software design
is followed by coding
which is then followed by testing in the
next step
there is a check for errors in case of
errors
it is evaluated for the error type if it
is a design
error it goes back to the beginning of
the design stage
if it is not a design error it is then
routed to the beginning of the coding
stage
on the contrary if there are no errors
the flowchart ends
let us learn about written procedures in
this screen
a written procedure is a step-by-step
guide to direct the reader through a
task
it is used when the process of a routine
task
is lengthy and complex and it is
essential for everyone to strictly
follow the rules
written procedures can also be used when
you want to know what is going on during
product or process
development phases there are a number of
benefits of documenting procedures
writing procedures help you avoid
mistakes and
ensure consistency they streamline the
process
and help your employees take relevant
decisions and save
a lot of time written procedures help in
improving quality
they are simple to understand as they
tend to describe the processes
at a general level in the next screen
we will discuss how work instructions
are helpful in understanding the process
in detail work instructions define how
one or more activities
involved in a procedure should be
written in a detailed manner
with the aid of technology or other
resources like flowcharts
they provide step-by-step details for a
sequence of activities
organized in a logical format so that an
employee can
follow it easily and independently
for example in the internal audit
procedure
how to fill out the audit results report
comes under work instructions
selection of the three process mapping
tools is based on the amount of detail
involved in the process for a less
detailed process
you can select flowchart and for a
detailed process
with lots of instructions you can select
work instructions
click the button to view an example of
work instructions
this example shows the work instructions
for shipping
electronic instruments the company name
is nutri worldwide inc
the instructions are written by brianna
scott and approved by andrew murphy
it is a one-page instruction the work
instructions are documented for the
shipping of electronic instruments by
the shipping department
the scope of the project states that it
is applicable to shipping operations
the procedure is divided into three
broad steps
as a first step the order for the
shipment must be prepared
in this step the shipping person
receives an order number from the sales
department
through an automatic order system the
quantity of the instrument and its card
number
are looked up from the system file and
the packaging is done as per the
instructions on the card
the next step is packaging special
packing
instructions must be checked the
instruments are then
marked as per the instructions on the
card and packed in a special or standard
container
as per the requirement the order number
is written in the shipping system
and the packing list and shipping
documentation are
obtained finally the quantity of
instruments
and the documents is checked
let us understand process input and
output variables
in this screen any improvement of a
process
has a few prerequisites to improve a
process
the key process output variables kpov
and key process input variables kpiv
should first be measured metrics for key
process variables
include percent defective operation cost
elapsed time backlog quantity
and documentation errors critical
variables are best identified by the
process owners
process owners know and understand each
step of a process
and are in a better position to identify
the critical variables initially
once identified the relationship between
the variables
is depicted using tools such as cypoc
and cause and effect matrix the process
input variables results are compared to
determine which
input variables have the greatest effect
on the output variables
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will discuss
probability and statistics
in detail let us learn about probability
in the following screen probability
refers to the chance of something
occurring or happening an outcome is the
result of a single trial of an
experiment
suppose there are n possible outcomes
that are equally likely
the probability that a specific type of
event or outcome
say f can occur is the number of
specific outcomes
divided by the total possible outcomes
click the button to view an example of
probability
in the event of tossing a coin what is
the probability of the occurrence of
heads a single trial of tossing a coin
has two outcomes heads and tails
hence the probability of heads occurring
is one divided by two
the total number of outcomes let us look
at some basic properties of probability
in this screen there are three basic
properties of probability
click each property to know more
property 1 states that the probability
of an event
is always between 0 and 1 both inclusive
according to property 2 the probability
of an event that cannot occur
is zero in other words an event that
cannot occur
is called an impossible event
property 3 states that the probability
of an event that must occur
is one in other words an event that must
occur
is called a certain event if e
is an event then the probability of its
occurrence is given by
p of e it is also read as the
probability
of event e
in this screen let us look at some
common terms used in probability
along with an example the commonly used
terms in probability are
sample space venn diagram and event
sample space is the collection of all
possible outcomes for a given experiment
in the coin example discussed earlier
the sample space consists of one
instance each of heads and tails if two
coins are tossed
the sample space would be four in total
a venn diagram
shows all hypothetically possible
logical relations between
a finite collection of sets an event
is a collection of outcomes for an
experiment which is any subset of the
sample space
click the button to view an example of
probability
what is the probability of getting a 3
followed by
two when a dice is thrown twice
when the dice is thrown twice the first
throw can have
any number from one to six similarly
the second throw can also have any
number from one to six
so the total sample space is six times
six that is thirty six
the event in this case is three followed
by two
this can happen in only one way so the
probability
in the question is one divided by
thirty-six
let us discuss the basic concepts of
probability
in this screen some basic concepts of
probability are
independent event dependent event
mutually exclusive and mutually
inclusive
events click each concept to know more
when the probability of occurrence of an
event does not affect the probability of
occurrence of another event
the two events are said to be
independent
suppose you rolled a dice and flipped a
coin at the same time
the probability of getting any number on
the dice in no
way influences the probability of
getting heads
or tails on the coin
when the probability of one event
occurring influences the likelihood of
the other event
the events are said to be dependent
events are said to be mutually exclusive
if the occurrence of
any one of them prevents the occurrence
of all the others
in other words only one event can occur
at a time
consider an example of flipping a coin
when you flip a coin you will either get
heads or tails
but not both you can add the
probabilities of these two events
to prove they are mutually exclusive
any two events wherein one event cannot
occur without the other
are said to be mutually inclusive events
in this screen let us learn about the
multiplication rules
also known as and rules the
multiplication rules or
and rules depend on the event dependency
for independent events that is if two
events are independent of each other
the special multiplication rule applies
for mutually independent events the
special multiplication rule
is as follows if the events
a b c and so on are independent of each
other
then the probability of a and b and c
and so on
is equal to the product of their
individual probabilities
click the button to view an example of
this rule
suppose there are three events which are
independent of each other
such as the event of flipping a coin and
getting heads
drawing a card and getting an ace and
throwing a dice and getting
a one what is the probability of
occurrence of
all these events the answer is
the probability of a and b and c
is equal to the product of their
individual probabilities
which is half multiplied by
one-thirteenth
multiplied by one-sixth the result is
0.0064 which is 0.64
hence there is 0.64 probability
of all of the events occurring
we will continue the discussion on
multiplication rules in this screen
the multiplication rule for
non-independent or
conditional events which is also the
general multiplication rule
is as follows if a and b are two events
then the probability of a and b is equal
to the product of probability of a
and the probability of b given a
alternatively we can say that for any
two events
their joint probability is equal to the
probability that one of these events
occurs
multiplied with the conditional
probability of the other event
given the first event click the button
to view an example
of this rule a bag contains
six golden coins and four silver coins
two coins are drawn without replacement
from the bag
what is the probability that both of the
coins are silver
let a be the event that the first coin
is silver
and b be the event that the second coin
is silver
there are ten coins in the bag four of
which are silver
therefore p of a equals four divided by
ten
after the first selection there are nine
coins in the bag
three of which are silver therefore p
of b given a equals three divided by
nine
therefore based on the rule of
multiplication
probability of a intersection b
equals four divided by ten multiplied by
three divided by nine the answer is
twelve divided by ninety
which is zero point one three three four
hence there is thirteen percent
probability that both the coins
are silver in this screen
we will look at the definitions and
formula of permutation
and combination permutation is the total
number of ways
in which a set group or number of things
can be arranged
the order matters to a great extent in
permutation
the manner in which the objects or
numbers are arranged will be considered
in
permutation the formula for permutation
is npr equals p of n
and r equals n factorial divided by n
minus r
factorial where n is the number of
objects
and r is the number of objects taken at
a time
the unordered arrangement of set group
or number of things
is known as combination the order does
not matter in combination
the formula for combination is ncr
equals c of n and r equals n factorial
divided by r factorial multiplied by
n minus r factorial where n is the
number of objects
and r is the number of objects taken at
a time
let us look at an example for
calculating permutation
and combination in the following screen
from a group of ten employees a company
has to select four
for a particular project in how many
ways can the selection happen
given the following conditions when the
arrangements of employees
needs to be different when the
arrangement of employees
need not be different click the button
to know the answer
in the given example the values of n and
r
are ten and four respectively let us
consider the first
condition from a group of ten employees
four employees need to be selected the
arrangement needs to be different
using the permutation formula n p r
equals p of n and r equals n factorial
divided by
n minus r factorial
10 p four equals p of ten and four
equals ten factorial
divided by ten minus four factorial
equals five
thousand forty therefore the four
employees can be selected
in five thousand forty ways
let us now consider the second condition
from a group of ten employees four
employees need to be selected
the arrangement of employees need not be
different
using the combination formula n c r
equals c of n and r equals n factorial
divided by r factorial multiplied by
n minus r factorial
10 c 4 equals c of ten and four equals
ten factorial
divided by four factorial multiplied by
ten minus four factorial equals two
hundred and ten
therefore the four employees can be
selected from a group of 10 employees
in 210 different ways
let us understand the two types of
statistics in this screen
statistics refers to the science of
collection analysis
interpretation and presentation of data
in six sigma statistical methods and
principles are used to measure
and analyze the process performance and
improvements
there are two major types of statistics
descriptive statistics and inferential
statistics
descriptive statistics is also known as
enumerative statistics
and inferential statistics is also known
as
analytical statistics descriptive
statistics
include organizing summarizing and
presenting the data in a meaningful way
whereas inferential statistics includes
making inferences and drawing
conclusions from the data
descriptive statistics describes what's
going on
in the data the main objective of
inferential statistics
is to make inferences from the data to
more general conditions
histograms pie charts box plots
frequency distributions and measures of
central tendency
mean median and mode are all examples of
descriptive statistics
on the other hand examples of
inferential statistics are
hypothesis testing scatter diagrams etc
the main objective of statistical
inference
is to draw conclusions on population
characteristics
based on the information available in
the sample
collecting data from a population is not
always easy
especially if the size of the population
is big
the easier way is to collect a sample
from the population
and from the sample statistic collected
make an assessment about the population
parameter
click the button to see an example of
statistical inference
the management team of a cricket council
wants to know if the team's performance
has improved
after recruiting a new coach the
management conducts a test to prove this
statistically
let us consider y a and y b
where y a stands for efficiency of coach
a and yb stands for efficiency
of coach b to conduct the test
the basic assumption is coach a and
coach b
are both effective this basic assumption
is known as null hypothesis here
let us assume the status quo is null
hypothesis
hence null hypothesis h o can be given
by
y a equals yb the management team also
challenges their basic assumption by
assuming the coaches are not
equally effective this is their
alternate hypothesis
the alternate hypothesis states that the
efficiencies of the two coaches differ
if the null hypothesis is proven wrong
the alternate hypothesis
must be right hence alternate hypothesis
h1 can be given y a is not equal
to yb these hypothesis statements are
used
in a hypothesis test which will be
discussed in the later part of the
course
in this screen we will learn about the
types of errors
when collecting data from a population
as a sample
and forming a conclusion on the
population based on the sample
you run into the risk of committing
errors there are two possible errors
that can happen
type 1 error and type 2 error
the type 1 error occurs when the null
hypothesis
is rejected when it is in fact true
type 1 error is also known as producer's
risk
the chance of committing a type 1 error
is known as
alpha alpha or significance level
is the chance of committing a type one
error and
is typically chosen to be five percent
this means the maximum amount of risk
you have for committing a type one error
is five percent let us consider the
previous example
arriving at a conclusion that coach b is
better than coach a
when in fact they are at the same level
is a type one error
the risk you have of committing this
error is 5
which means there is a 5 chance your
experiment can give
wrong results the type 2 error occurs
when the null hypothesis
is accepted when it is in fact false
also when you reject the alternate
hypothesis
when it is actually true you commit a
type 2
error type 2 error is also referred to
as
consumer's risk in comparing the two
coaches
the coaches were actually different in
their efficiencies
but the conclusion was that they are the
same
the chance of committing a type 2 error
is known as beta
the maximum chance of committing a type
2 error is
20 in the next screen we will learn
about
central limit theorem
central limit theorem clt states that
for a sample size greater than 30
the sample mean is very close to the
population mean
in simple words the sample mean
approaches the normal distribution
for example if you have sample 1 and its
mean
is mean 1 sample 2 and its mean is
mean 2 and so on take the means of mean
one
mean two etc and you will find that it
is the same as the population mean
population mean is the average of the
sample means
in such cases the standard error of mean
also known as sem that represents the
variability between the sample means
is very less the sem is often used to
represent the standard deviation of the
sample
the formula for sem is population
standard deviation
divided by the square root of the sample
size
selecting a sample size also depends on
the concept called
power also known as power of the test
we will cover this concept in detail in
the later part of the course
let us look at the graphical
representation of the central limit
theorem
in the following screen the plot of the
three numbers 2
three and four looks as shown in the
graph
it is interesting to note that the total
number of times each digit is chosen
is six when the plot of the sample mean
of nine
samples of size two each is drawn it
looks like the red
line which is plotted in the figure the
x-axis
shows numbers of the mean which are two
two point five
three and four on the y-axis the
frequency is plotted
the point at which arrows from number
two and three converge
is the mean of two and three similarly
the point at which arrows from two and
four converge
is the mean of the numbers two and four
let us discuss the concluding points of
the central limit theorem
in the next screen the central limit
theorem concludes that the sampling
distributions
are helpful in dealing with non-normal
data
if you take the sample data points from
a population
and plot the distribution of the means
of the sample you get the sampling
distribution of the means
the mean of the sampling distribution
also known as the mean of means
will be equal to the population mean
also
the sampling distribution approaches
normality as the sample size
increases note that clt
enables you to draw inferences from the
sample statistics about the population
parameters
this is irrespective of the distribution
of the population
clt also becomes the basis for
calculating
confidence interval for hypothesis tests
as it allows the use of a standard
normal table
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will cover the concept
of statistical distributions
let us start with discrete probability
distribution in the following screen
discrete probability distribution is
characterized by the probability mass
function
it is important to be familiar with
discrete distributions while dealing
with discrete data
some of the examples of discrete
probability distribution
are binomial distribution poisson
distribution
negative binomial distribution geometric
distribution
and hyper geometric distribution
we will focus only on the two most
useful discrete distributions
binomial distribution and poisson
distribution
like most probability distributions
these distributions
also help in predicting the sample
behavior that has been
observed in a population let us learn
about binomial distribution in the
following screen
binomial distribution is a probability
distribution for
discrete data named after the swiss
mathematician jacob bernoulli
it is an application of popular
knowledge to predict the sample behavior
binomial distribution also describes the
discrete data
as a result of a particular process like
the tossing of a coin for a fixed number
of times
and the success or failure in an
interview
a process is known as bernoulli's
process
when the process output has only two
possible values like
defective or okay pass or fail
and yes or no binomial distribution is
used
to deal with defective items defect is
any non-compliance with a specification
defective is a product or service with
at least one defect
binomial distribution is most suitable
when the sample size
is less than 30 and less than 10 percent
of the population
it is the percentage of non-defective
items
provided the probability of creating a
defective item remains the same
over a period let us look at the
equation
the probability of exactly r successes
out of a sample size of n is denoted by
p of r which is equal to ncr
whole multiplied by p to the power of r
and one minus p
whole to the power of n minus r
in the equation b is the probability of
success
r is the number of successes desired and
n is the sample size to continue
discussing the binomial distribution
let us look at some of its key
calculations in the following screen
the mean of a binomial distribution is
denoted by
mio and is given by n multiplied by p
the standard deviation of a binomial
distribution
is denoted by sigma which is equal to n
multiplied by p multiplied by 1 minus p
the method of calculating factorials say
factorial
of 5 is the product of five four
three two and one which is equal to
one hundred twenty similarly factorial
of four
is the product of four three two and one
which is equal to twenty four let us
look at
an example of calculating binomial
distribution
in the next screen suppose you wish to
know the probability of getting heads
five
times in eight coin tosses you can use
the binomial equation for the same
click the answer button to see how this
is done
the tossing of a coin has only two
outcomes heads
and tails it means that the probability
of each outcome
is 0.5 and it remains fixed over a
period of time
additionally the outcomes are
statistically independent
in this case the probability of success
denoted by p
is 0.5 the number of successes desired
is denoted by r which is five and the
sample size is denoted by
n which is eight therefore the
probability of five heads
is equal to factorial of eight c r which
is eight divided by
factorial of five and factorial of eight
minus five whole multiplied by zero
point five to the power of five
multiplied by one minus zero point five
whole to the power of eight minus five
this calculation gives a result of zero
point two one
eight seven which is equal to twenty one
point eight seven
percent let us learn about poisson
distribution in this screen
poisson distribution is named after
simeone denis
on and is also used for discrete data
poisson distribution is an application
of the population knowledge to predict
the sample behavior
it is generally used for describing the
probability distribution of an event
with respect to time or space some of
the characteristics of poisson
distribution are as follows
poisson distribution describes the
discrete data resulting from a process
like the number of calls received by a
call center agent
or the number of accidents at a signal
unlike binomial distribution which deals
with binary discrete data
possum distribution deals with integers
which can take any value
poisson distribution is suitable for
analyzing situations wherein the number
of trials
similar to the sample size in binomial
distribution
is large and tends towards infinity
additionally it is used in situations
where the probability of success in each
trial
is very small almost tending towards
zero
this is the reason why poisson
distribution is applicable
for predicting the occurrence of rare
events like plane crashes
car accidents etc and is therefore
widely used in the insurance sector
poisson distribution can be used for
predicting the number of defects as well
given a low defect occurrence rate let
us look at the formula for calculating
poisson distribution
in the next screen the poisson
distribution for a probability of
exactly x occurrences is given by p
of x equals to lambda to the power of x
multiplied with log e to the power of
minus lambda
whole divided by factorial of x
in this equation lambda is the mean
number of occurrences during the
interval
x is the number of occurrences desired
and e
is the base of natural logarithm which
is equal to 2.71828
the mean of the poisson distribution is
given by the lambda
and the standard deviation of a poisson
distribution
is given by sigma which is the square
root of lambda
let us look at an example to calculate
poisson distribution in the next screen
the past records of a road junction
which is accident prone
show a mean number of five accidents per
week at this junction
assume that the number of accidents
follows up with song distribution
and calculate the probability of any
number of accidents happening in a week
click the button to know the answer
given the situation you know that the
value of lambda or mean
is five so p of zero that is the
probability of zero accidents per week
is calculated as five to the power of
zero
multiplied by e to the power of minus
five whole
divided by factorial of zero the answer
is zero point zero zero six applying the
same formula the probability of one
accident per week is 0.03
the probability of more than two
accidents per week
is one minus the sum of probabilities of
zero
one and two accidents which is 0.884
in other words the probability is 88.4
percent
let us learn about normal distribution
in this screen
the normal or gaussian distribution is a
continuous probability distribution
the normal distribution is represented
as n and depends on two factors
me u which stands for mean and sigma
which gives the standard deviation of
the data points
normal distribution normally has a
higher frequency of values
around the mean and lesser occurrences
away from it
it is often used as a first
approximation to describe
real valued random variables that tend
to cluster around
a single mean value the distribution is
bell shaped and symmetrical
the total area under the normal curve is
one which is
p of x various types of data such as
body weight height
the output of a manufacturing device etc
follow the normal distribution
additionally normal distribution is
continuous and
symmetrical with the tails asymptotic to
the x-axis
which means they touch the x-axis at
infinity
let us continue to discuss normal
distribution in the following screen
in a normal distribution to standardize
comparisons of dispersion
or the different measurement units like
inches meters grams etc
a standard z variable is used the uses
of
z value are as follows while the value
of z
or the number of standard deviations is
unique for each probability within the
normal distribution
it helps in finding probabilities of
data points
anywhere within the distribution it is
dimensionless as well
that is it has no units such as
millimeters liters
columns etc there are different formulas
to arrive at the normal distribution
we will focus on one commonly used
formula for calculating normal
distribution
which is z equals y minus mu
whole divided by sigma here z is the
number of standard deviations between
y and the mean denoted by mu
y is the value of the data point in
concern
me u is mean of the population or data
points
and sigma is the standard deviation of
the population
or data points let us look at an example
for calculating normal distribution
in the following screen suppose the time
taken to resolve customer problems
follows a normal distribution with a
mean of 250 hours
and standard deviation of 23 hours
find the probability of a problem
resolution taking more than
300 hours click the button to know the
answer
in this case y is equal to 300 me u
equals 250 and sigma equals 23.
applying the normal distribution formula
z
is equal to 300 minus 250 whole
divided by 23 the result is 2.17
when you look at the normal distribution
table the z
value of 2.17 covers an area
of 0.98499 under itself
this means the probability of a problem
taking 0 to 300 hours to be resolved
is 98.5 percent and therefore the
chances of a problem resolution
taking more than 300 hours is point five
percent
let us understand the usage of z table
in this screen
the graphical representation of z table
usage is given here
the probability of areas under the curve
is one
for the actual value one can identify
the z
score by using the z table
as shown this probability is the area
under the curve
to the left of point plus a to zero
using the actual data when you calculate
mean and standard deviation
and the values are 25 and 5 respectively
it is the normal distribution if the
same data is standardized to a mean
value of zero and standard deviation
value of one
it is the standard normal distribution
in the next screen we will take a look
at the z table
the z table gives the probability that z
is between
zero and a positive number there are
different forms of normal distribution z
tables followed globally the most common
form of z table
with positive z scores is shown here
the value of a called the percentage
point
is given along the borders of the table
in bold
and is to two decimal places the values
in the main table
are the probabilities that z is between
0 and plus a
note that the values running down the
table are to one decimal place
the numbers along the column change only
for the second decimal place
let us look at some examples and how to
use a z
table in the following screen
let us find the value of p of z less
than zero
the table is not needed to find the
answer once we know that the variable
z takes a value less than or equal to
zero first the area under the curve is
one
and second the curve is symmetrical
about z
equals zero hence there is 0.5
or 50 percent above chance of z equals
zero
and zero point five or fifty percent
below chance of
z equals zero let us find the value of p
of z greater than one point one two
in this case the chance of z is greater
than a number
in this case 1.12 you can find this
by using the following fact the opposite
or
complement of an event of a is the event
of
not a that is the opposite or complement
of event a
occurring is the event a not occurring
its probability is given by p of not
equal
a equals one minus p of a in other words
p of z greater
than 1.12 is 1 minus the opposite
which is p of z lesser than 1.12
using the table p of z less than 1.12
equals 0.5 plus p of 0
less than z less than 1.12 equals 0.5
plus 0.3686 which is
0.8686 hence the answer is
p of z greater than 1.12 equals 1
minus 0.8686 which is
0.1314 note the answer is less than 0.5
let us find the value of p of z lies
between 0
and 1.12 in this case where z falls
within an interval
the probability can be read straight off
the table
p of z lies between 0 and 1.12
equals 0.3686
we will learn about chi-square
distribution in this screen
chi-square distribution is also known as
chi
squared or chi-square distribution chi
squared with k minus 1 degrees of
freedom
is the distribution of a sum of the
squares of k
independent standard normal random
variables
the chi-square distribution is one of
the most widely used probability
distributions
in inferential statistics it is also
known as hypothesis testing
and the distribution is used in
hypothesis tests
when used in hypothesis tests it only
needs one sample for the test to be
conducted
conventionally degree of freedom is k
minus one
where k is the sample size for example
if w x y and z are four random variables
with standard normal distributions then
the random variable
f which is the sum of w square x
square y square and z square has a
chi-square distribution
the degrees of the freedom of the
distribution df
equals the number of normally
distributed variables used
in this case df is equal to four
let us look at the formula to calculate
chi-square distribution
in the following screen chi-square
calculated or sigma or the chi-square
index equals f of o minus f
of e whole square divided by f of e
here f of o stands for an observed
frequency
and f of e stands for an expected
frequency
determined through a contingency table
let us understand
t distribution in the next screen
the t distribution method is the most
appropriate method to be used in the
following situations
when you have a sample size of less than
30
when the population standard deviation
is not known
when the population is approximately
normal
unlike the normal distribution a t
distribution
is lower at the mean and higher at the
tails as seen in the image
t distribution is used for hypothesis
testing
also as seen in the image the t
distribution is
symmetrical in shape but flatter than
the normal distribution
as the sample size increases the t
distribution approaches normality
for every possible sample size or
degrees of freedom
there is a different t distribution
let us learn about f distribution in the
following screen
the f distribution is a ratio of two
chi-square distributions
a specific f distribution is denoted by
the ratio of the degrees of freedom
for the numerator chi-square and the
degrees of freedom for the denominator
chi-square the f-test is performed
to calculate and observe if the standard
deviations or
variances of two processes are
significantly different
the project teams are usually concerned
about reducing
the process variance as per the formula
f calculated equals s1 square divided by
s2 square where s1 and s2
are the standard deviations of the two
samples
if the f calculated is one it implies
there is no difference in the variance
if s1 is greater than s2
then the numerator must be greater than
the denominator
in other words df1 equals n1
minus 1 and df2 equals n2
minus 1. from the f distribution table
you can easily find out the critical f
distribution at
alpha and the degrees of freedom of the
samples of two different processes
df1 and df2 let us proceed to the next
topic of this lesson in the following
screen
in this topic we will discuss collecting
and summarizing data
in detail let us learn about types of
data
in the following screen data is
objective information which everyone can
agree on
it is a collection of facts from which
conclusions may be drawn
the two types of data are attribute data
and variable data
click each type to know more
discrete data is data that can be
counted
and only includes numbers such as two
forty or
thousand fifty attribute data is
commonly called
pass fail or good bad data
attribute or discrete data cannot be
broken down
into a smaller unit meaningfully it
answers questions such as
how many how often or what type
some examples of attribute data are
number of defective products
percentage of defective products
frequency at which a machine is repaired
or the type of award received
any data that can be measured on a
continuous scale
is continuous or variable data
this type of data answers questions such
as how long
what volume or how far examples of
continuous data
include height weight time taken to
complete a task
temperature and so on
let us understand the importance of
selecting the data type in this screen
deciding the data type facilitates
analysis and
interpretation therefore the first step
in the measure phase
is to determine what type of data should
be collected
this can be done by considering the
following
the first consideration is to identify
what is already known
for this the values already identified
for the process
are listed these include critical to
quality parameters or
ctq's key process output variables or
kpovs and the key process
input variable or kpivs
next to understand how to proceed with
the data gathered
it is necessary to determine the data
type that fits the metrics
for the key variables identified
the question now arises why should the
data type
be identified this is important
as it enables the right set of data to
be collected
analyzed and used to draw inferences
it is not advisable to convert one type
of data into another
converting attribute data to variable
data is difficult
and requires assumptions to be made
about the process
it may also require additional data
gathering including retesting units
let us look at measurement scales in the
following screen
there are four measurement scales
arranged in the table
in increasing order of their statistical
desirability
in the nominal scale the data consists
of only
names or categories and there is no
possibility of ordering
an example of this type of measurement
can be a bag of colored balls
which contains ten green balls five
black balls
eight yellow balls and nine white balls
this is the least informative of all
scales
the most appropriate measure of central
tendency for this scale
is mode in the ordinal or ranking scale
data is arranged in order and values can
be compared with each other
an example of this scale can be the
ratings given to different restaurants
three for a five for b two for c
and four for d the central tendency for
this scale
is median or mode the interval scale
is used for ranking items in step order
along a scale of equidistant points
for example the temperatures of three
metal rods are 100 degrees
200 degrees and 600 degrees fahrenheit
respectively
note that three times 200 degrees is not
the same as 600 degrees
as a temperature measurement the central
tendency here is mean
median or mode mean is used if the data
does not have any
outliers the ratio scale represents
variable data
and is measured against a known standard
or increment
however this scale also has an absolute
zero
that is no numbers exist below zero
an example of the ratio scale are
physical measures
where height weight and electric charge
represent
ratio scale data note that negative
length is not possible
again here you would use mean median or
mode
as the central tendency measure in the
next screen
we will learn about assuring data
accuracy
to ensure data is accurate sampling
techniques are used
sampling is the process act or technique
of selecting an appropriate test group
or sample
from a larger population it is
preferable to survey 100 people to
surveying
10 000 people sampling saves the time
money and effort involved in collecting
data
the three types of sampling techniques
described here
are random sampling sequential sampling
and stratified sampling click each type
to know more
random sampling is the technique where a
group of subjects
or a sample for study is selected from a
larger group or population
at random sequential sampling is similar
to
multiple sampling plans except that it
can in theory
continue indefinitely in other words it
is a
non-probability sampling technique
wherein the researcher
picks a single subject or a group of
subjects
in a given time interval conducts the
study
analyzes the results and then picks
another group of subjects if needed
and so on in stratified sampling
the idea is to take samples from
subgroups of a population
this technique gives an accurate
estimate of the population parameter
in this screen we will compare simple
random sampling with stratified sampling
simple random sampling is easy to do
while stratified sampling takes a lot of
time
the possibility of simple random
sampling giving erroneous results
is very high while stratified sampling
minimizes the chances of error simple
random sampling
doesn't have the power to show possible
causes of variation
while stratified sampling if done
correctly
will show assignable causes in the next
screen
we will look at the check sheet method
of collecting data
the process of collecting data is
expensive wrongly collected data leading
to wrong analysis
and inferences results in resources
being wasted
a check sheet is a structured form
prepared to collect and analyze data
it is a generic tool that is relatively
simple to use
and can be adopted for a variety of
purposes
check sheets are used when the data can
be observed and collected repeatedly by
the same person
or at the same location they are also
used while collecting data from a
production process
a common example is calculating the
number of absentees in a company
the table shows absentee data collected
for a week
we will discuss data coding and its
advantages
in the following screen data coding is a
process of converting
and condensing raw data into categories
and sets
so that the data can be used for further
analysis
the benefits of data coding are listed
here
data coding simplifies the large
quantity of data that is collected from
sources
the large amount of data makes analysis
and drawing conclusions difficult
it leads to chaos and ambiguity data
coding
simplifies the data by coding it into
variables
and then categorizing these variables
raw data cannot be easily entered into
computers for analysis
data coding is used to convert raw data
into
process data that can be easily fed into
computing systems
for calculation and analysis
coding of data makes it easy to analyze
the data
converted data can either be analyzed
directly
or fed into computers the analyst can
easily draw conclusions when all the
data is categorized
and computerized data coding also
enables organized representation of data
division of data into categories helps
organize
large chunks of information thus making
analysis
and interpretation easier data coding
also ensures that data repetition does
not occur
and duplicate entries are eliminated so
that the final result
is not affected in the following screen
we will discuss measures of central
tendency of the descriptive statistics
in detail a measure of central
tendency is a single value that
indicates the central point in a set of
data
and helps in identifying data trends
the three most commonly used measures of
the central tendency
are mean median and mode click
each measure to know more mean
is the most common measure of central
tendency
it is the sum of all the data values
divided by the number of data points
also called arithmetic mean or average
it is the most
widely used measure of central tendency
also known as positional mean median is
the number
present in the middle of the data set
when the numbers are
arranged in ascending or descending
order
if the data set has an even number of
entries
then the median is the mean of the two
middle numbers
median can also be calculated by the
formula
n plus one divided by two where n
is the number of entries
mode also known as frequency mean is the
value that occurs
most frequently in a set of data data
sets that have
more than one mode are known as bimodal
data
let us look at an example for
determining mean
median and mode in this screen the data
set has the numbers
one two three four five five
six seven and eight click the button to
know the answer
as previously defined mean is the sum of
all the data items divided by the number
of items
therefore the mean is equal to 41
divided by 9
which is equal to four point five six
the number in the middle of the data set
is five
therefore the median is five mode is the
most frequently occurring number
which is again five in this screen
we will understand the effect of
outliers on the data set
let us consider a minor change to the
data set
a new number 100 is added to the data
set
on using the same formula to calculate
mean
the new mean is 15.11 ideally 50 percent
of values
should lie on either side of the mean
value
however in this example it can be seen
that almost 90 percent of values
lie below the mean value of 15.11
and only one value above the mean
the data point 100 is called an outlier
an outlier is an extreme value in the
data set
that skews the mean value to one side of
the data set
note that the median remains unchanged
at five
therefore mean is not an appropriate
measure
of central tendency if the data has
outliers
median is preferred in this case in the
next screen
we will look at measures of dispersion
of the descriptive statistics
apart from central tendency another
important parameter to describe
a data set is spread or dispersion
contrary to the measures of central
tendency such as
mean median and mode measures of
dispersion
express the spread of values higher the
variation of data points
higher the spread of the data the three
main measures of dispersion
are range variance and standard
deviation
we will discuss each of these in the
upcoming screens
let us start with the first measure of
dispersion range
the range of a particular set of data is
defined as the difference between the
largest
and smallest values of the data
in the example the largest value of the
data is
nine and the smallest value is one
therefore the range is nine minus one
eight
in calculating range all the data points
are not needed
and only the maximum and minimum values
are required
let us understand the next measure of
dispersion
variance in the following screen
the variance denoted as sigma square or
s square is defined as the average of
squared mean differences
and shows the variation in a data set
to calculate the variance for a sample
data set of 10
numbers type the numbers in an excel
sheet
calculate the variance using the formula
equals
v-a-r-p or v-a-r-s
the v-a-r-p formula gives the population
variance
which is 7.24 for this example
the v a r s formula gives the sample
variance
8.04 population variance
is calculated when the data set is for
the entire population
and sample variance is calculated when
data is available only for a sample
of the population population variance is
preferred over
sample variance as the latter is only an
estimate
sample variance allows for a broader
range of possible answers for the true
mean of the population
that is the confidence levels are higher
in sample variance
note that variance is a measure of
variation and cannot be considered as
the variation in a data set
in the following screen we will
understand the next measure of
dispersion
standard deviation standard deviation
denoted by sigma or s is given by the
square root of variance
the statistical notation of this is
given on screen
standard deviation is the most important
measure of dispersion
standard deviation is always relative to
the mean
for the same data set the population
standard deviation
is 2.69 and sample standard deviation
is 2.83 as in variance calculation
if the data set is measured for every
unit in a population
the population standard deviation and
sample
standard deviation can be calculated in
excel
using the formula given on the screen
the steps to manually calculate the
standard deviation are
first calculate the mean then
calculate the difference between each
data point and the mean
and square that answer next calculate
the sum of the squares
next divide the sum of the squares by n
or
n minus 1 to find the variance lastly
find the square root of variance which
gives the standard deviation
in the next screen we will look at
frequency distribution
of the descriptive statistics frequency
distribution is a method of grouping
data
into mutually exclusive categories
showing the number of observations in
each class
an example is presented to demonstrate
frequency distribution
a survey was conducted among the
residents of a particular
area to collect data on cars owned by
each home
a total of 20 homes were surveyed
to create a frequency table for the
results collected in the survey
the first step is to divide the results
into intervals
and count the number of results in each
interval
for instance in this example the
intervals would be the number of
households with no car
one car two cars and so on
next a table is created with separate
columns for the intervals
the tallied results for each interval
and the number of occurrences or
frequency of results
in each interval each result for a given
interval
is recorded with a tally mark in the
second column the tally marks for each
interval
are added and the sum is entered in the
frequency column
the frequency table allows viewing
distribution of data
across a set of values at a glance in
the following screen
we will look at cumulative frequency
distribution
a cumulative frequency distribution
table is similar to the frequency
distribution table
only more detailed there are additional
columns for
cumulative frequency percentage and
cumulative percentage
in the cumulative frequency column the
cumulative frequency
or the previous row or rows is added to
the current row
the percentage is calculated by dividing
the frequency
by the total number of results and
multiplying by one hundred
the cumulative percentage is calculated
similar to the cumulative frequency
let us look at an example for cumulative
frequency distribution
the ages of all the participants in a
chess tournament
are recorded the lowest age is 37
and the highest is 91. keeping
intervals of 10 the lowest interval
starts with the lower limit as 35
and the upper limit as 44.
similar intervals are created until an
upper limit of
ninety four in the frequency column
the number of times a result appears in
a particular interval
is recorded in the cumulative frequency
column
the cumulative frequency of the previous
row is added to the frequency of the
current row
for the first row the cumulative
frequency is the same
as the frequency in the second row the
cumulative frequency
is one plus two which is three and so on
in the percentage column the percentage
of the frequency is listed
by dividing the frequency by the total
number of results
which is 10 and multiplying the value by
100 for instance in the first row
the frequency is one and the number of
results
is ten therefore the percentage is ten
the final column is the cumulative
percentage column
in this column the cumulative frequency
is divided by the total number of
results
which is ten and the value is multiplied
by hundred
note that the last number in this column
should be equal to one hundred
in this example the cumulative frequency
is one
and the total number of results is ten
therefore the cumulative percentage of
the first row
is ten let us look at the stem and leaf
plots
which is one of the graphical methods of
understanding distribution
graphical methods are extremely useful
tools to understand how data is
distributed
sometimes merely by looking at the data
distribution
errors in a process can be identified
the stem and leaf method is a convenient
method of manually plotting data sets
it is used for presenting data in a
graphical format
to assist visualizing the shape of a
given distribution
in the example on the screen the
temperatures in fahrenheit for the month
of may
are given to collate this information in
a stem and leaf plot
all the tens digits are entered in the
stem column
and all the units digits against each
tens digit are entered in the leaf
column
to start with the lowest value is
considered
in this case the lowest temperature is
51.
in the first row five is entered in the
stem column
and zero in the leaf column the next
lowest temperature is 58.
eight is entered in the leaf column
corresponding to five in the stem
the next number is fifty-nine all the
temperatures falling in the fifties are
similarly entered
in the next row the same process is
repeated for temperatures in the sixties
this is continued till all the
temperature values are entered in the
table
let us understand another graphical
method in the next screen
box and whisker plots
a box and whisker graph based on medians
or quartiles
is used to display a data set in a way
that allows viewing the distribution of
the data points easily
consider the following example the
lengths of 13 fish caught in a lake
were measured and recorded the data set
is given on the screen
the first step to draw a box and whisker
plot is therefore
to arrange the numbers in increasing
order
next find the median as there is an odd
number of data entries
the median is the number in the middle
of the data set which
in this case is 12. the next step is to
find
the lower median or quartile this is the
median of the lower six
numbers the middle of these numbers is
halfway between 8 and 9
which would be 8.5 similarly
the upper median or quartile is located
for the upper six numbers to the right
of the median
the upper median is halfway between the
two values
fourteen and fourteen therefore the
upper median
is fourteen let us now understand
how the box and whisker chart is drawn
using the values of the median
and upper and lower quartiles the next
step is
a numbered line is drawn extending far
enough to include
all the data points then a vertical line
is drawn
from the median point 12. the lower and
upper quartiles
8.5 and 14 respectively
are marked with vertical lines and these
are joined with the median line
to form two boxes as shown on the screen
next two whiskers are extended from
either ends of the boxes
as shown to the smallest and largest
numbers in the data set
5 and 20 respectively the box and
whiskers graph is now complete
the following inferences can be drawn
from the box and whisker plot
the lengths of the fish range from five
to twenty
the range is therefore fifteen the
quartiles split the data into four equal
parts
in other words one quarter of the data
numbers is less than 8.5
one quarter between 8.5 and 12
next quarter of the data numbers are
between 12 and 14
and another quarter has data numbers
greater than 14.
in this screen we will learn about
another graphical method
scatter diagrams a scatter diagram
or scatter plot is a tool used to
analyze the relationship or correlation
between two sets of variables x and y
with x as the independent variable and y
as the dependent variable a scatter
diagram is also useful
when cause effect relationships have to
be examined
or root causes have to be identified
there are five different types of
correlation that can be used in a
scatter diagram
let us learn about them in the next
screen
the five types of correlation are
perfect positive correlation
moderate positive correlation no
relation
or no correlation moderate negative
correlation
and perfect negative correlation click
each type
to learn more in perfect positive
correlation
the value of dependent variable y
increases proportionally
with any increase in the value of
independent variable
x this is said to be one is to one
that is any change in one variable
results in
an equal amount of change in the other
the following example is presented to
demonstrate perfect positive correlation
the consumption of milk is found to
increase proportionally
with an increase in the consumption of
coffee the data is presented in the
table on the screen
the scatter diagram for the data is also
shown
it can be observed from the graph that
as x increases
y also increases proportionally hence
the points are linear
in this type of correlation as the value
of the x variable increases
the value of y also increases but not
in the same proportion to demonstrate
this
the following example is presented the
increase in savings for
increase in salary is shown in the table
as you can notice in the scatter diagram
the points are not linear
although the value of y increases with
increase in the value of x
the increase is not proportional
when a change in one variable has no
impact on the other
there is no relation or correlation
between them
let us consider the following example to
study the relation between
the number of fresh graduates in the
city and the job openings available
data for both was collected over a few
months and tabulated as shown
the scatter diagram for the same is also
displayed
it can be observed that the data points
are scattered and there is no trend
emerging from the graph
therefore there is no correlation
between the number of fresh graduates
and the number of job openings in the
city
in moderate negative correlation an
increase
in one variable results in a decrease in
the other variable
however this change is not proportional
to the change in the first variable
to demonstrate modern negative
correlation
the prices of different products are
listed along with the number of units
sold for each product the data is shown
in the table
from the scatter diagram shown it can be
observed that
higher the price of a product lesser are
the number of units of that product sold
however the decrease in the number of
units with increasing price
is not proportional
in perfect negative correlation an
increase
in one variable results in a
proportional decrease
of the other variable this is also an
example of
one is to one correlation as an example
the effect of an increase in the project
time extension
on the success of project is considered
the data is shown in the table the
scatter diagram for the data
shows a proportional decrease in the
probability of the project's success
with each extension of the project time
hence
the points are linear perfect
correlations are rare in the real world
when encountered they should be
investigated and verified
in this screen we will look at another
graphical method
histograms histograms are similar to bar
graphs
except that the data in histograms is
grouped into
intervals they are used to represent
category wise data graphically
a histogram is best suited for
continuous data
the following example illustrates how a
histogram
is used to represent data data on the
number of hours spent by a group of 15
people
on a special project in one week is
collected
this data is then divided into intervals
of two
and the frequency table for the data is
created
the histogram for the same data is also
displayed
looking at the histogram it can be
observed at a glance
that most of the team members spent
between two to four hours on the project
in the following screen we will look at
the next graphical method
normal probability plots normal
probability
plots are used to identify if a sample
has been taken from a normal distributed
population
when sample data from a normal
distributive population
is represented as a normal probability
plot
it forms a straight line the following
example
is presented to illustrate normal
probability plots
a sampling of diameters from a drilling
operation is done
and the data is recorded the data set is
given
to create a normal probability plot the
first step is to construct a cumulative
frequency distribution table
this is followed by calculating the mean
rank probability
by dividing the cumulative frequency by
the number of samples plus one
and multiplying the answer by one
hundred
the fully populated table for mean rank
probability estimation
is shown on the screen please take a
look at the same
in the next step a graph is plotted on
log paper
or with minitab using this data minitab
is a statistical software used in six
sigma
minitab normal probability plot
instructions are also given on the
screen the completed graph
is shown on the screen from the graph it
can be seen that the random sample forms
a straight line
and therefore the data is taken from a
normally distributed population
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson
in this topic we will discuss
measurement system analysis
or msa in detail let us understand what
msa is in the following screen
throughout the dmac
process the output of the measurement
system ms
is used for metrics analysis and control
efforts
an error prone measurement system will
only lead to incorrect data
incorrect data leads to incorrect
conclusions
it is important to set right the ms
before collecting the data
measurement system analysis or msa
is a technique that identifies
measurement error or
variation and sources of that error in
order to reduce the variation
it evaluates the measuring system to
ensure the integrity of data used for
analysis
msa is therefore one of the first
activities in the measure phase
the measurement systems capability is
calculated
analyzed and interpreted using gauge
repeatability and reproducibility
to determine measurement correlation
bias linearity
percent agreement and precision or
tolerance
let us discuss the objectives of msa in
the next screen
a primary objective of msa is to obtain
information about the type of
measurement variation
associated with the measurement system
it is
also used to establish criteria to
accept and release
new measuring equipment msa also
compares measuring
one method against another it helps to
form a basis for evaluating a method
which is suspected of being deficient
the measurement system variations
should be resolved to arrive at the
correct baselines for the project
objectives
as baselines contain crucial data based
on which decisions are taken
it is extremely important that the
measurement system be free of error
as far as possible let us look at
measurement analysis
in detail in the next screen
in measurement analysis the observed
value is equal to the sum
of the true value and the measurement
error
the measurement error can be a negative
or a positive value
measurement error refers to the net
effect of all sources of measurement
variability
that cause an observed value to deviate
from the true value
true variability is the sum of the
process variability
and the measurement variability process
variability and measurement variability
must be evaluated and improved together
measurement variability should be
addressed before looking
at process variability if process
variability is corrected
before resolving measurement variability
then any improvements to the process can
not be trusted to have taken place
owing to a faulty measurement system in
the following screen
we will identify the types of
measurement errors
the two types of measurement errors are
measurement system
bias and measurement system variation
click each type to know more measurement
system
bias involves calibration study in the
calibration study
the total mean is given by the sum of
the process mean and the measurement
mean
the statistical notation is shown on the
screen
measurement system variation involves
gauge repeatability and reproducibility
or grrr study in the grr
study the total variance is calculated
by adding the process variance with the
measurement variation
the statistical notation is shown on the
screen
in this screen we will discuss the
sources of variation
the chart on the screen lists the
different sources of variation
observed process variation is divided
into two
actual process variation and measurement
variation
actual process variation can be divided
into
long-term and short-term process
variations
in a gauge rr study process variation
is often called part variation
measurement variation can be divided
into variations caused by
operators and variations due to the
gauge
the variation due to operators is owing
to reproducibility
variation due to gauge is owing to
repeatability
both actual process variation and
measurement variation
have a common factor that is variation
within a sample
let us understand gauge repeatability
and reproducibility
or grr in the next screen
gauge repeatability and reproducibility
or grr
is a statistical technique to assess if
a gauge or
gauging system will obtain the same
reading each time a particular
characteristic or parameter
is measured gauge repeatability
is the variation in measurement when one
operator
uses the same gauge to measure identical
characteristics
of the same part repeatedly gauge
reproducibility
is the variation in the average of
measurements when different operators
use the same gauge to measure identical
characteristics
of the same part the figures on the
screen illustrate gauge repeatability
and reproducibility in the next screen
we will discuss the components of grr
study
the figure on the screen illustrates the
difference between
gauge repeatability and reproducibility
the figure shows the repeatability and
reproducibility
for six different parts represented by
the numbers
one to six for two different trial
readings
by three different operators as can be
observed
a difference in reading for part one
indicated by the color green
by three different operators is known as
reproducibility error
a difference in reading of part 4
indicated by
red by the same operator in two
different trials
is known as the repeatability error in
the following screen
we will look at some guidelines for
gauge repeatability
and reproducibility studies
the following should be kept in mind
while carrying out gauge repeatability
and reproducibility
or grr studies grr studies
should be performed over the range of
expected observations
care should be taken to use actual
equipment for gr studies
written procedures and approved
practices should be followed as would
have been in actual operations
the measurement variability should be
represented as is
not the way it was designed to be after
grr
the measurement variability is separated
into casual components
sorted according to priority and then
targeted for action
in the following screen let us look at
some more concepts
associated with grr
bias is the distance between the sample
mean value
and the sample true value it is also
called accuracy
bias is equal to mean minus reference
value
process variation is equal to six times
the standard deviation
the bias percentage is calculated as
bias divided
by the process variation the next term
is linearity
linearity refers to the consistency of
bias over the range of the gauge
linearity is given by the product of
slope and process variation
precision is the degree of repeatability
or
closeness of data smaller the dispersion
in the data set better the precision the
variation
in the gauge is the sum of variation due
to repeatability
and the variation due to reproducibility
in the following screen we will
understand measurement resolution
measurement resolution is the smallest
detectable increment that an
instrument will measure or display the
number of increments in the measurement
system
should extend over the full range for a
given parameter
some examples of wrong gauges or
incorrect measurement resolution are
given here
a truck weighing scale is used for
measuring the weight of a t-pack
a caliper capable of measuring
differences of 0.1 millimeters
is used to show compliance when the
tolerance limits are
plus or minus 0.07 millimeters
thus the measurement system that matches
the range of the data
should only be used an important
prerequisite for grr
studies is that the gauge has an
acceptable resolution
in the next screen we will look at
examples for repeatability
and reproducibility
repeatability is also called equipment
variation or
ev it occurs when the same technician
or operator repeatedly measures the same
part or process
under identical conditions with the same
measurement system
the following example illustrates this
concept
a 36 kilometer per hour pace mechanism
is timed by a single operator
over a distance of 100 meters on a
stopwatch
and three readings are taken trial one
takes
nine seconds trial two takes ten seconds
and trial 3 takes 11 seconds
the process is measured with the same
equipment in identical conditions by the
same operator
assuming no operator error the variation
in the three readings is known as
repeatability or equipment variation
reproducibility is also called appraiser
variation or
av it occurs when different technicians
or operators measure the same part or
process
under identical conditions using the
same measurement system
let us extend the example for
repeatability to include data measured
by
two operators the readings are displayed
on the slide
the difference in the readings of both
operators is called reproducibility
or appraiser variation it is important
to resolve equipment variation
before appraiser variation if appraiser
variation
is resolved first the results will still
not be identical due to variation in the
equipment itself
in this screen we will learn about data
collection in grr
there are some important considerations
for data collection in grr
studies there are usually three
operators
and around ten units to measure general
sampling techniques
must be used to represent the population
and each unit must be measured two to
three times
by each operator it is important that
the gauge be calibrated
accurately it should also be ensured
that the gauge has an acceptable
resolution
another practice is that the first
operator measures all the units in
random order then this order is
maintained by all
other operators all the trials must be
repeated
in the next screen we will discuss the
anova method of analyzing
grr studies the anova method is
considered to be the best method for
analyzing grr studies
this is because of two reasons the first
being anova
not only separates equipment and
operator variation
but also provides insight on the
combined effect
of the two second anova uses standard
deviation
instead of range as a measure of
variation
and therefore gives a better estimate of
the measurement system variation
the one drawback of using anova is the
considerations of time
resources and cost in the next screen
we will understand how msa can be
interpreted
two results are possible for an msa
in the first case the reproducibility
error
is larger than the repeatability error
this occurs when the operators are not
trained and calibrations on the gauge
dial are not clear
the other possibility is that the
repeatability error
is larger than the reproducibility error
this is clearly a maintenance issue and
can be resolved by calibrating the
equipment
or performing maintenance on the
equipment this indicates that the gauge
needs redesign to be more rigid and the
location needs to be improved
it also occurs when there is ambiguity
in sops
msa is an experiment which seeks to
identify the components of variation
in the measurement in the following
screen we will look at a template used
for grr studies
a sample gauge rr sheet is given on this
screen
the operators here are andrew murphy and
lucy wang
who are the appraisers in this study
they have measured and rated the
performance of three employees
ibrahim glasoff brianna scott and jason
schmidt
this is a sample template for a gauge r
r study
the parts are shown across the top of
the sheet
in this case the measurement system is
being evaluated
using three parts the employees abraham
glasoff
brianna scott and jason schmidt
the operators measure each part
repeatedly
from this data the average x and ranges
are for each inspector and for each part
are calculated the grand average for
each inspector
and each part is also calculated
in this example a control limit ucl
in the sheet was compared with the
difference in averages of the two
inspectors to identify
if there is a significant difference in
their measurements
their difference is 0.111
which is outside the ucl of 0.108
given the r average of 0.042
in the next screen we will look at the
results page for this
grr study the sheet on the screen
displays the results for the data
entered in the template in the previous
screen
please spend some time to go through the
data for a better understanding of the
concept
in the following screen we will look at
the interpretation
to this results page the percentage
grrr value is highlighted in the center
right of the table in the previous
screen
there are three important observations
to be made here about the gauge
rr study first this study also
shows the interaction between operators
and parts
if the percentage grr value is less than
30
then the gauge is acceptable and the
measurement system does not require any
change
if the value is greater than 30 then the
gauge
needs correction the equipment variation
is checked and resolved first followed
by the appraiser variation
second if ev equals zero it means the ms
is reliable
the equipment is perfect and the
variation in the gauge is contributed by
different operators if the av is equal
to zero
the ms is precise third if
ev is equal to zero and there is a v
the operators have to be trained to
ensure all operators follow identical
steps
during measurement and the av is minimal
the interaction between operators and
parts can also be studied under grr
using part variation the trueness and
precision cannot be determined in a grrr
if only one gauge or measurement method
is evaluated
as it may have an inherent bias that
would go
undetected merely by varying operators
and parts
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will discuss process
and performance capability
in detail in the following screen we
will look at the differences between
natural process
limits and specification limits
natural process limits or control limits
are derived from the process data and
are the voice of the process
the data consists of real-time values
from past
process performance therefore these
values
represent the actual process limits and
indicate variation in the process the
two control limits are
upper control limit ucl and lower
control limit
lcl specification limits are provided by
customers
based on their requirements or the voice
of the customer
and cannot be changed by the
organization
these limits act as targets for the
organization
and processes are designed around the
requirements
the product or service has to meet
customer requirements
and has to be well within the
specification limits
if the product or service does not meet
customer requirements
it is considered as a defect therefore
specification limits are the intended
results or requirements from the product
or service
that are defined by the customer the two
specification limits are
upper specification limit or usl
and lower specification limit or lsl
the difference between the two is called
tolerance
an important point to note is that for a
process
if the control limits lie within the
specification limits
the process is said to be under control
conversely if specification limits lie
within the control limits the process
will not meet
customer requirements in the following
screen
we will look at process performance
metrics and how they
are calculated the two major metrics
used to measure process performance are
defects per unit or dpu and
defects per million opportunities or
dpmo dpu
is calculated by dividing the number of
defects by the total number of units
dpmo is calculated by multiplying the
defects per opportunity with 1 million
in the following screen we will look at
an example for calculating process
performance
in this example the quality control
department checks the quality of
finished goods by sampling
a batch of 10 items from the produced
lot every hour
the data is collected over 24 hours
the table displays the data for the
number of defectives for the sampling
period
if items are consistently found to be
outside the control limits on any given
day
the production process is stopped for
the next day
let us now interpret the results of the
sampling
in this example as the sample size is
constant
dpu or p-bar is used to calculate the
process capability
the total number of defectives is 34 and
the subgroup size
is 10. the total number of units is 10
multiplied by 24 which is 240.
the defects per unit is 0.0124
the defects per million opportunities is
obtained by multiplying the defects per
unit with 1 million
which is 141 666.66
therefore by looking at the dpmo table
it can be said that the process is
currently working at 2.6 sigma
or 86.4 percent yield
we will learn about process stability
studies in this screen
the activities carried out in the
measure phase are
msa collection of data statistical
calculations
and checking for accuracy and validity
this is followed by a test for stability
as changes cannot be made to an
unstable process with a set of data
believed to be accurate
the process is checked for stability
this
is important because if a process is
unstable
no changes can be implemented why does a
process become
unstable a process can become unstable
due to special causes of variation
multiple special causes of variation
lead to instability
a single special cause leads to an out
of control condition
run charts in minitab can be used to
check for process stability
let us look at the steps to plot a run
chart in minitab
in the following screen to plot a run
chart in minitab
first enter the sample data collected to
check for stability
next click stat on the minitab window
followed by
quality tools next click run charts
select the column and choose the
subgroup size as two
click ok the graph shown on the screen
is interpreted by looking at the last
four values
if any of the p values is less than 0.05
the presence of special causes of
variation can be validated
this means there is a good chance that
the process will become
unstable in the following screen
we will look at process stability
studies causes
of variation variation can be due to
two types of causes common causes of
variation
and special causes of variation click
each type to learn more
common causes of variation are the many
sources of variation within a process
which have a stable and repeatable
distribution over a period
they contribute to a state of
statistical control where the output is
predictable
some other factors which do not always
act on the process
can also cause variation these are
special causes
of variation these are external to the
process
and are irregular in nature when present
the process distribution changes and the
process output is not stable over a
period
special causes may result in defects and
need to be eliminated to bring the
process
under control run charts indicate the
presence of special causes of variation
in the process if special causes are
detected
the process has to be brought to a stop
and a root cause analysis
has to be carried out if the root cause
analysis
reveals the special cause to be
undesirable
corrective actions are taken to remove
the special cause
we will learn about verifying process
stability and normality
in this screen based on the type of
variation of process
exhibits it can be verified if the
process is in control
if there are special causes of variation
the process output is not stable over
time
the process cannot be said to be in
control
conversely if there are only common
causes of variation in a process
the output forms a distribution that is
stable and predictable
over time a process being in control
means the process does not have any
special causes of variation
once a process is understood to be
stable
the control chart data can be used to
calculate the process capability indices
in the following screen we will discuss
process capability studies
process capability is the actual
variation in the process specification
to carry out a process capability study
first
plan for data collection next collect
the data
finally plot and analyze the results
obtaining the appropriate sampling plan
for the process capability study
depends on the purpose and whether there
are any customer or standard
requirements for the study
for new processes or a project proposal
the project capability can be estimated
by a pilot run
let us look at the objectives of process
capability studies
in the next screen the objectives of a
process capability study
are to establish a state of control over
a manufacturing process
and then maintain the state of control
over a period of time
on comparing the natural process limits
or the control limits within the
specification limits
any of the following outcomes is
possible
first the process limits are found to
fall between the specification limits
this shows the process is running well
and no action is required
the second possibility is that the
process spread
and the specification spread are
approximately the same
in this case the process is centered by
making an adjustment
to the centering of the process this
would bring the batch of products within
the specifications
the third possibility is that the
process limits fall outside the
specification limits
in this case reduce the variability by
partitioning the pieces of batches
to locate and target the largest
offender a design experiment can be used
to identify the primary source of
variation
in the following screen we will learn
about identifying characteristics in
process capability
process capability deals with the
ability of the process to meet customer
requirements
therefore it is crucial that the
characteristics selected for a process
capability
study indicates a key factor in the
quality of the product or
process also it should be possible to
influence the value of the
characteristic by
adjusting the process the operating
conditions that affect the
characteristic
should also be defined and controlled
apart from these requirements other
factors determining the characteristics
to be measured
are customer purchase order requirements
or industry standards
in the following screen we will look at
identifying specifications or tolerances
in process capability
the process specification or tolerances
are defined either by
industry standards based on customer
requirements or by the organization's
engineering department in consultation
with the customer
a stability study followed by a
comprehensive capability study
also helps in identifying if the process
mean meets the target
or the customer mean the process
capability study
indicates whether the process is capable
it is used to determine if the output
consistently meets specifications
and the probability of a defect or
defective
this information is used to evaluate and
improve the process to meet the
tolerance requirements
in the following screen we will learn
about process performance indices
process performance is defined as a
statistical measurement of the outcome
of a process characteristic
which may or may not have been
demonstrated to be in a state of
statistical control
in other words it is an estimate of the
process capability of a process
during its initial setup before it has
been brought into
a state of statistical control it
differs from the process capability in
that for process performance
a state of statistical control is not
required
the three basic process performance
indices are
process performance or pp process
performance index or
ppk and process capability index denoted
as
ppm or cpm click each index to know more
pp stands for process performance
it is computed by subtracting the lower
specification limit
from the upper specification limit the
whole divided by natural process
variation
or six sigma
ppk is the process performance index
and a minimum of the values of the upper
and lower process capability indices
the upper and lower process capability
indices are calculated as
shown on the screen ppu or upper process
capability index
is given by the formula usl minus x
divided by
3s ppl or lower process capability index
is given by x minus lsl divided by
3s here x is process average
better known as x bar and s is sample
standard deviation
cpm denotes the process capability index
mean
which accounts for the location of the
process average relative to a target
value
it can be calculated as shown on the
screen
here myu stands for process average
sigma symbol denotes the process
standard deviation
usl is the upper specification limit
and lsl is the lower specification limit
t is the target value which is typically
the center of the tolerance
x i is the sample reading and n is the
number of sample readings
we will look at the key terms in process
capability in this screen
zst or short term capability
is the potential performance of the
process in control
at any given point of time it is based
on the sample collected in the short
term
the long term performance is denoted by
zlt
it is the actual performance of the
process over a given period of time
subgroups are several small samples
collected consecutively
each sample forms a subgroup the
subgroups are chosen so that the data
points are likely to be identical within
the subgroup
but different between two subgroups the
process shift is calculated by
subtracting
the long-term capability from the
short-term capability
the process shift also reflects how well
a process is controlled
it is usually a factor of 1.5
let us look at short-term and long-term
process capability
in the next screen the concept of
short-term and long-term process shift
is explained graphically
on this screen there are three different
samples taken at time 1
time 2 and time 3. the smaller waveforms
represent the short-term capability
and they are joined with their means to
show the shift in long-term performance
the long-term performance curve is shown
below with the target value
marked in the center it is important to
note that
over a period of time or subgroups a
typical process will shift by
approximately 1.5 times
the standard deviation also long-term
variation
is more than short-term variation this
difference is known as the
sigma shift and is an indicator of the
process control
the reasons for a process shift include
changes in operators
raw material used wear and tear and time
periods
we will discuss the assumptions and
conventions of process variations
in the following screen long-term
variation
is always longer than short-term
variation click each term to know more
short-term variations are due to the
common causes
the variance is inherent in the process
and known as the natural variation
short-term variations show variation
within subgroup
and are therefore called within subgroup
variation
they are usually a small number of
samples collected at short intervals
in short-term variation the variation
due to common causes are captured
however common causes are difficult to
identify and correct
the process may have to be redesigned to
remove common causes of variation
long-term variations are due to common
as well as special causes
the added variation or abnormal
variation is due to factors external to
the usual process
long-term variation is also known as the
overall variation
and is a sample standard deviation for
all the samples put together
long-term variation shows variations
within the subgroup
and between subgroups special causes
increasing variation include changes in
operators
raw material and wear and tear the
special causes need to be identified and
corrected for
process improvement this screen explains
how the factors of stability
capability spread and defect summary are
used to interpret the process
condition this table gives the process
condition for different levels or types
of variation
with reference to common causes and
special causes
the table is read as follows in the
first scenario
the process has lesser common causes of
variation or
ccv and no special causes of variation
or
scv in this case the variability is less
the capability is high the possibility
of defects
is less and the process is said to be
capable
and in control next if the process
has lesser ccv and some scb are present
then it has high variability low
capability
and a high possibility of defects the
process is said to be
out of control and incapable
the third possibility is that the
process has
high ccv and no scv
in this case the variability is moderate
to high
the capability is very low and
possibility of defects
is very high although the process is in
control
it is incapable finally at the other
extreme
is the situation where the process has
high ccv
and scv is also present here the process
has high variability low capability
high possibility of defects and is out
of control
and incapable this table is a quick
reference to understand
process conditions in the next screen we
will compare the
cpk and cp values
when cpk and cp values are compared
three outcomes are possible
when cpk is lesser than cp it can be
inferred that the mean
is not centered when cpk is equal to cp
the inference is that the process is
accurate
the process is considered capable if cpk
is greater than one
this will happen only if variations are
in control
cpk can never be greater than cp
if this situation occurs the
calculations have to be
rechecked we will look at an example
problem for calculating process
variation
in the following screen the table on
this screen
shows data for customer complaint
resolution time over a period of three
weeks
each week's data forms a sub group for
example
the resolution time is 48 hours for a
particular case in week 1.
in week 2 the case takes up 50 hours and
in week 3 it takes about 49 hours
the subgroup size is 10. let us
understand how to calculate long-term
and short-term standard deviations are
calculated for this data
the average for each week is calculated
by dividing the total number of
complaints resolved
by the subgroup size a grand average is
also calculated for all the three weeks
the variations within subgroups and
between subgroups for each week are
calculated
this is followed by calculating the
total variations within and between
subgroups overall variation is given by
the sum
of total variation within subgroups and
total variation
between subgroups finally the standard
deviations for the short term
and the long term are calculated using
the formula given on the screen
the results for the process variation
calculations are as follows
the grand average for all three weeks is
47.5
the total variation within subgroups is
1023.8
the total variation between subgroups is
161.67
both these variations are added to give
the overall variation
of 1185.5
the short-term standard deviation is 6.2
and the long-term standard deviation is
6.4
note that the overall variation can also
be calculated with the usual sample
variance formula
let us discuss the effective mean shift
on the process capability in this screen
the table given here shows the defect
level at different sigma
multiple values and different mean
shifts from the table
it can be seen that when the mean is
centered within the specification limits
and the process capability is 1 that is
plus or minus 3s fits within the
specification limits
the dpmo is 2700 percent
and the probability of a good result is
99.73 percent
if the mean shifts by 1.5 sigma then a
tail moves outside the specification
limit to a greater extent
now the dpmo increases to over sixty six
thousand this is almost a twenty five
hundred percent increase in defects
if the process has a process capability
of two
that is plus or minus six s fits within
the specification limits
and the mean shifts by 1.5 sigma then
the probability of a good result is
99.99966 percent
this is the same as a process with a
capability of 1.5
that is plus or minus 4.5 s
fitting within the specification limits
and no shift in the mean
the long-term and short-term capability
table shows the variations in
capabilities
for the purposes of six sigma the
assumption is that the long-term
variability
will have a 1.5 s difference from the
short-term variability
as seen in statistical process control
this assumption can be
challenged if control charts are used
and these
kinds of shifts are detected quickly in
the chart
it can be seen that the mean shift is
negligible as the process capability
increases
therefore for a six sigma process the
long-term variation
does not have much effect in the next
screen
we will look at key concepts in process
capability for attribute data
the customary procedure for defining
process capability for attribute data
is to define the mean rate of
non-conformity
defects and defectives are examples of
non-conformity
defects per million opportunities or
dpmo
is the measure of process capability for
attribute data
for this the mean and the standard
deviation for attribute data have to be
defined
for defectives p bar is used for
checking process capability for both
constant
and variable sample sizes for defects
c bar and u bar are used for constant
and variable sample sizes respectively
the p bar c bar and u bar are the
equivalent of the standard deviation
denoted by
sigma for continuous data in this topic
we will learn about the patterns of
variation in detail
let us start with the classes of
distributions
in the following screen when data
obtained from the measurement phase
is plotted on a chart it is observed
that it exhibits
a variety of distributions depending on
the data type
and its source these distribution
patterns
will help you understand the data better
probability statistics and inferential
statistics
are the methods used to describe the
parameters for the classes of
distributions
click each method to know more
probability is based on the assumed
model of distribution
and it is used to find the chances of a
certain
outcome or event to occur
statistics uses the measured data to
determine a model to describe the data
used
inferential statistics describe the
population parameters
based on the sample data using a
particular model
in this screen we will discuss the types
of distributions
there are two types of distributions
discrete distribution
and continuous distribution discrete
distribution
includes binomial distribution and
poisson distribution
continuous distribution includes normal
distribution chi
square distribution t distribution
and f distribution let us learn about
discrete probability distribution
in the following screen discrete
probability distribution
is characterized by the probability mass
function
it is important to be familiar with
discrete distributions while dealing
with
discrete data some of the examples of
discrete probability
distribution are binomial distribution
poisson
distribution negative binomial
distribution
geometric distribution and hyper
geometric distribution
we will focus only on the two most
useful discrete distributions
binomial distribution and poisson
distribution
like most probability distributions
these distributions
also help in predicting the sample
behavior that has been
observed in a population let us learn
about binomial distribution
in the following screen
binomial distribution is a probability
distribution for discrete data
named after the swiss mathematician
jacob bernoulli
it is an application of popular
knowledge to predict the sample behavior
binomial distribution also describes the
discrete data
as a result of a particular process like
the tossing of a coin for a fixed number
of times
and the success or failure in an
interview
a process is known as bernoulli's
process
when the process output has only two
possible values like
defective or okay pass or fail
and yes or no binomial distribution is
used
to deal with defective items defect is
any non-compliance with a specification
defective is a product or service with
at least one defect
binomial distribution is most suitable
when the sample size is less than 30
and less than 10 percent of the
population it is the percentage of
non-defective items
provided the probability of creating a
defective item
remains the same over a period let us
look at the equation
the probability of exactly r successes
out of a sample size of n is denoted by
p of r which is equal to ncr
whole multiplied by p to the power of r
and one minus p
whole to the power of n minus r
in the equation b is the probability of
success
r is the number of successes desired and
n is the sample size to continue
discussing the binomial distribution
let us look at some of its key
calculations in the following screen
the mean of a binomial distribution is
denoted by
mio and is given by n multiplied by p
the standard deviation of a binomial
distribution
is denoted by sigma which is equal to n
multiplied by p multiplied by one minus
p
the method of calculating factorials say
factorial of five
is the product of five four three two
and one
which is equal to one hundred twenty
similarly factorial of four is the
product of four
three two and one which is equal to
twenty four let us look at an example of
calculating binomial distribution
in the next screen suppose you wish to
know the probability of getting heads
five times in eight coin tosses you can
use the binomial equation for the same
click the answer button to see how this
is done
the tossing of a coin has only two
outcomes heads
and tails it means that the probability
of each outcome
is 0.5 and it remains fixed over a
period of time
additionally the outcomes are
statistically independent
in this case the probability of success
denoted by
p is 0.5 the number of successes desired
is denoted by
r which is five and the sample size is
denoted by
n which is eight therefore the
probability of five heads is equal to
factorial of eight
c r which is eight divided by factorial
of five and factorial of eight minus
five
whole multiplied by zero point five to
the power of five
multiplied by one minus zero point five
whole to the power of eight minus five
this calculation gives a result of zero
point two one
eight seven which is equal to twenty one
point eight
seven percent
let us learn about poisson distribution
in this screen
fuson distribution is named after simeon
denis posson
and is also used for discrete data
poisson distribution
is an application of the population
knowledge to predict the sample behavior
it is generally used for describing the
probability distribution of an event
with respect to time or space some of
the characteristics of poisson
distribution
are as follows poisson distribution
describes the discrete data resulting
from a process like the number of calls
received by a call center agent
or the number of accidents at a signal
unlike binomial distribution which deals
with binary discrete data
poisson distribution deals with integers
which can take any value
poisson distribution is suitable for
analyzing situations
wherein the number of trials similar to
the sample size in binomial distribution
is large and tends towards infinity
additionally it is used in situations
where the probability of success in each
trial
is very small almost tending towards
zero
this is the reason why poisson
distribution is applicable
for predicting the occurrence of rare
events like plane crashes
car accidents etc and is therefore
widely used in the insurance sector
poisson distribution can be used for
predicting the number of defects as well
given a low defect occurrence rate let
us look at the formula for calculating
poisson distribution
in the next screen the poisson
distribution for a probability of
exactly x occurrences
is given by p of x equals to lambda to
the power of x multiplied with log
e to the power of minus lambda whole
divided by factorial
of x in this equation lambda
is the mean number of occurrences during
the interval
x is the number of occurrences desired
and e is the base of natural logarithm
which is equal to 2.71828
the mean of the poisson distribution is
given by the lambda
and the standard deviation of a poisson
distribution
is given by sigma which is the square
root of lambda
let us look at an example to calculate
poisson distribution
in the next screen the past records of a
road junction which is accident prone
show a mean number of five accidents per
week at this junction
assume that the number of accidents
follows a poisson distribution
and calculate the probability of any
number of accidents happening in a week
click the button to know the answer
given the situation you know that the
value of lambda or mean
is five so p of zero that is the
probability of zero accidents per week
is calculated as five to the power of 0
multiplied by e to the power of minus 5
whole
divided by factorial of zero the answer
is 0.006 applying the same formula the
probability of one accident per week is
0.03 the probability of more than two
accidents per week
is one minus the sum of probabilities of
zero
one and two accidents which is 0.884
in other words the probability is 88.4
percent
let us learn about continuous
probability distribution in this screen
continuous probability distribution is
characterized by the probability density
function
a variable is said to be continuous if
the range of possible values falls along
a continuum
for example loudness of cheering at a
ball game weight of cookies in a package
length of a pen or the time required to
assemble a car
continuous probability distributions
help in predicting the sample behavior
observed in a population
let us learn about normal distribution
in this screen
the normal or gaussian distribution is a
continuous probability distribution
the normal distribution is represented
as n and depends on two factors
me u which stands for mean and sigma
which gives the standard deviation of
the data points
normal distribution normally has a
higher frequency of values
around the mean and lesser occurrences
away from it
it is often used as a first
approximation to describe
real valued random variables that tend
to cluster around a single mean value
the distribution is bell shaped and
symmetrical
the total area under the normal curve is
1 which is p
of x various types of data such as body
weight
height the output of a manufacturing
device etc
follow the normal distribution
additionally normal distribution is
continuous and symmetrical with the
tails asymptotic to the x-axis
which means they touch the x-axis at
infinity
let us continue to discuss normal
distribution in the following screen
in a normal distribution to standardize
comparisons of dispersion or the
different measurement units like
inches meters grams etc a standard
z variable is used the uses of z
value are as follows while the value of
z
or the number of standard deviations is
unique for each probability within the
normal distribution
it helps in finding probabilities of
data points
anywhere within the distribution it is
dimensionless as well
that is it has no units such as
millimeters liters
coulombs etc there are different
formulas to arrive at the normal
distribution
we will focus on one commonly used
formula for calculating normal
distribution
which is z equals y minus mu
whole divided by sigma here z is the
number of standard deviations between
y and the mean denoted by miu
why is the value of the data point in
concern me u
is mean of the population or data points
and sigma is the standard deviation of
the population
or data points let us look at an example
for calculating normal distribution
in the following screen suppose the time
taken to resolve customer problems
follows a normal distribution
with a mean of 250 hours and standard
deviation of twenty three hours
find the probability of a problem
resolution taking more than three
hundred hours
click the button to know the answer
in this case y is equal to three hundred
me u
equals 250 and sigma equals 23.
applying the normal distribution formula
z
is equal to 300 minus 250 whole
divided by 23. the result is 2.17
when you look at the normal distribution
table the z
value of 2.17 covers an area
of 0.98499 under itself
this means the probability of a problem
taking 0 to
300 hours to be resolved is 98.5 percent
and therefore the chances of a problem
resolution taking more than 300 hours is
1.5 percent let us understand the usage
of
z table in this screen the graphical
representation of z
table usage is given here the
probability of areas under the curve is
one
for the actual value one can identify
the z
score by using the z table
as shown this probability is the area
under the curve
to the left of point plus a to zero
using the actual data when you calculate
mean and standard deviation
and the values are 25 and 5 respectively
it is the normal distribution if the
same data is standardized to a mean
value of 0
and standard deviation value of 1 it is
the standard
normal distribution in the next screen
we will take a look at the z table
the z table gives the probability that z
is between zero
and a positive number there are
different forms of normal distribution z
tables followed globally the most common
form of z
table with positive z scores is shown
here
the value of a called the percentage
point
is given along the borders of the table
in bold
and is to two decimal places the values
in the main table are the probabilities
that z is between
zero and plus a note that the values
running down the table are to one
decimal place
the numbers along the column change only
for the second decimal place
let us look at some examples on how to
use a z table
in the following screen let us find the
value of p
of z less than zero the table is not
needed to find the answer once we know
that the variable z
takes a value less than or equal to zero
first the area under the curve is one
and second
the curve is symmetrical about z equals
zero
hence there is zero point five or fifty
percent
above chance of z equals zero and zero
point five
or fifty percent below chance of z
equals zero
let us find the value of p of z greater
than one point one two
in this case the chance of z is greater
than a number
in this case 1.12 you can find this by
using the following fact the opposite or
complement of an event of a
is the event of not a that is the
opposite or complement of event a
occurring is the event a not occurring
its probability is given by p of not a
equals one minus p of a in other words p
of z greater than one point one two is
one minus the opposite
which is p of z lesser than 1.12
using the table p of z less than 1.12
equals 0.5 plus p of 0
less than z less than 1.12 equals 0.5
plus 0.3686 which is
0.8686 hence the answer
is p of z greater than 1.12 equals 1
minus
0.86 which is 0.1314
note the answer is less than 0.5
let us find the value of p of z lies
between 0 and 1.12
in this case where z falls within an
interval the probability can be read
straight off the table
p of z lies between 0 and 1.12
equals 0.3686
we will learn about chi-square
distribution in this screen
chi-square distribution is also known as
chi
squared or chi-square distribution
chi squared with k-1 degrees of freedom
is the distribution of a sum of the
squares of k
independent standard normal random
variables
the chi-squared distribution is one of
the most widely used probability
distributions
in inferential statistics it is also
known as hypothesis testing
and the distribution is used in
hypothesis tests
when used in hypothesis tests it only
needs one sample for the test to be
conducted
degree of freedom is k1 where k
is the sample size click the button to
view the chi-square distribution formula
chi-square calculated or sigma or the
chi-square
index equals f of o minus f of e
the whole square divided by f of e
here f of o stands for an observed
frequency
and f of e stands for an expected
frequency
determined through a contingency table
we will learn about the chi-square
distribution in detail
in the later part of this lesson let us
proceed to the next screen
to discuss t distribution
the t distribution method is the most
appropriate method to be used in the
following situations
when you have a sample size of less than
30
when the population standard deviation
is not known
when the population is approximately
normal
unlike the normal distribution a t
distribution
is lower at the mean and higher at the
tails as seen in the image
t distribution is used for hypothesis
testing
also as seen in the image the t
distribution
is symmetrical in shape but flatter than
the normal distribution
as the sample size increases the t
distribution approaches normality
for every possible sample size or
degrees of freedom
there is a different t distribution
let us learn about f distribution in the
following screen
the f distribution is a ratio of two
chi-square distributions
a specific f distribution is denoted by
the ratio of the degrees of freedom
for the numerator chi square and the
degrees of freedom
for the denominator chi-square the
f-test is performed to calculate
and observe if the standard deviations
or variances of two processes
are significantly different the project
teams are
usually concerned about reducing the
process variance
as per the formula f calculated equals
s1 square divided by s2 square
where s1 and s2 are the standard
deviations of the two samples
if the f calculated is 1 it implies
there is no difference in the variance
if
s 1 is greater than s 2 then the
numerator
must be greater than the denominator in
other words
df1 equals n1 minus 1
and df2 equals n2 minus 1.
from the f distribution table you can
easily
find out the critical f distribution at
alpha
and the degrees of freedom of the
samples of two different processes
df1 and df2 let us proceed to the next
topic of this lesson
in the following screen in this topic
we will discuss exploratory data
analysis
in detail let us learn about
multivariate studies
in the following screen multivariate
studies or
multi-variable studies are used to
analyze variation
in a process analyzing variation
helps in investigating the stability of
a process
more stable the process less is the
variation
multivariate studies also help in
identifying areas to be investigated
finally they help in breaking down the
variation into components to make the
required improvements
multivariate studies classify variation
sources
into three major types positional
cyclical and temporal click each type to
learn more
positional variation occurs within a
single piece or a product
variation in pieces of a batch is also
an example of positional variation
in positional variation measurements at
different locations of a piece
would produce different values suppose a
company is manufacturing a metal plate
of thickness
one inch and the plate thickness is
different at many points
it is an example of positional variation
some of the other examples can be pallet
stacking in a truck
temperature gradient in an oven
variation
observed from cavity to cavity within a
mold
region of a country and line on invoice
cyclical variation occurs when
measurement differs from piece to piece
or product to product
but over a short period of time time is
important because certain measurements
may change if a product
such as a hot metal sheet is measured
after a long interval
if the measurement at the same location
in a piece varies with different pieces
it is an example of cyclical variation
other examples of cyclical variations
are match to batch variation
lot to lot variation and account
activity
week to week temporal variation
occurs over a longer period of time such
as machine
wear and tear and changes in efficiency
of an operator before
and after lunch temporal variations may
also be seasonal
if the range of positional variation in
a piece is more in winter than in summer
it is an example of temporal variation
the variation may occur because of
unfavorable working conditions in winter
process drift performance before and
after breaks
seasonal and shift based differences
month-to-month closings
and quarterly returns can be examples of
temporal variation
we will learn about creating a
multivariate chart in this screen
the outcome of multivariate studies is
the multivariate chart
it depicts the type of variation in the
product
and helps in identifying the root cause
there are five major steps involved in
creating a multivariate chart
they are select process and
characteristics
decide sample size create a tabulation
sheet
plot the chart and link the observed
values
click each step to learn more
the first step is to select the process
and the relevant characteristics to be
investigated
for example selecting the process where
the plate of one
inch thickness is being manufactured in
this process
four equipment numbered one to four
produce the one-inch plates
the characteristic to be measured is the
thickness of the plate
ranging from 0.95 inch to 1.05 inches
any plate thickness outside this range
is a defect
the second step is to decide the sample
size
and the frequency of data collection in
this example
the sample size is five pieces per
equipment
and the frequency of collecting data is
every two hours starting from
eight in the morning to two in the
afternoon
then the tabulation sheet is created
where the data will be recorded
so one should measure the thickness of
the plate being produced
by the four equipment at a data
collection frequency
of two hours the third step
is to create a tabulation sheet in this
example
the tabulation sheet with data records
contains the columns with
time equipment number and thickness
as headers the fourth step is to plot
the chart
in this example a chart can be plotted
with time on the
x-axis and plate thickness on the y-axis
the last step is to link the observed
values
in this example the observed values can
be linked by
appropriate lines we will continue to
learn about creating a multivariate
chart
in this screen the path to create a
multivariate chart in minitab
is by selecting stat then quality tools
followed by multivariate chart the
multivariate chart created from the data
recorded
is shown here the upper specification
limit of 1.05 inches
and the lower specification limit of
0.95
inches has been marked by green lines
data outside these lines are defects
the blue dots show the positional
variation
the dots are the measurements of pieces
in a batch of any
single equipment the black lines join
the mean of the data recorded from the
equipment
the mean of the data recorded from the
products of equipment number three
is much below the similar mean of other
equipment
this shows that equipment number three
is producing more defects than the other
equipment
the red line is the mean of the data
recorded at a particular time
the red line rises toward the right
which means
the data points shift up after 12 pm
this may be because of the change in
operator efficiency
after a lunch break at 12 pm
multivariate chart
helps us visually depict the variations
and establish
the root causes of variations in the
next screen
we will learn about simple linear
correlation
correlation means association between
variables
simple linear regression and multiple
regression techniques are
very important as they help in
validating the association
of x with y the coefficient correlation
shows the strength of the relationship
between y
and x to associate y
with a single x and statistically
validate the relationship
correlation is used in excel
use equals corel open bracket close
bracket
function to calculate correlation
coefficient
the dependent variable y may depend on
many independent variables x
but correlation is used to find the
behavior of y
as one of the x's changes correlation
helps us to predict the direction of
movement in values
in y when x changes statistical
significance of this movement
is denoted by correlation coefficient r
it is also known as pearson's
coefficient of correlation
in any correlation the value of the
correlation coefficient
is always between minus one and plus one
positive value of r denotes the
direction of movement in both variables
is the same
as x increases y also increases
and vice versa negative value of r
denotes that the direction of movement
in both variables is in
inverse fashion as x increases
y decreases and as x decreases
y increases when the value of
r is zero it means that there is no
correlation between the two variables
higher the absolute value of r stronger
the correlation between
y and x absolute value of a number
is its value without the sign plus
four has an absolute value of four and
minus four again has an absolute value
of four
an r value of greater than plus 0.85
or lesser than minus 0.85
indicates a strong correlation hence r
value of minus 0.95
shows a stronger correlation than the r
value of minus
0.74 the next screen will elaborate on
correlation with the help of an example
and illustrations through scatter plots
the four graphs on the screen are
scatter plots displaying four different
levels of correlation
correlation measures the linear
association between the dependent
variable
or output variable y and one independent
or input variable x as can
be deduced from the graphs a definite
pattern emerges as the absolute value of
correlation coefficient
r increases it is easy to see a pattern
in r
value of 0.9 and above than to see a
pattern in r
value of 0.07 it is difficult to find a
pattern below correlation coefficient
of 0.5 click the example button to know
more
to understand how correlation helps let
us consider
an example a correlation test was
performed on the scores of a set of
students from their
first grade high school and under
graduation
the undergraduation score was the
dependent variable
and first grade score the independent
variable
the value of correlation coefficient r
was calculated to be
0.29 and the correlation between
undergraduation scores and high school
scores was
0.45 this means
the high school scores have higher
correlation compared to the first grade
scores
this states the performance of students
in high school
is a better indicator of their
performance in undergraduation
than their performance in the first
grade although the correlation exists
as both the values of r are less than
0.85
it will be difficult to draw a straight
line on the scanner plot
in this screen we will learn about
regression
although correlation gives the direction
of movement of the dependent variable y
as independent variable x changes
it does not provide the extent of the
movement of y
as x changes this degree of movement can
be calculated
using regression if a high percentage of
variability in y
is explained by changes in x
one can use the model to write a
transfer equation
y is equal to f x and use the same
equation to predict future values of y
given x and x given y
the output of regression on y and x is a
transfer function equation that can
predict values of y
for any other value of x transfer
function is generally denoted by f and
the equation is written as
y equals to f of x y
can be regressed on one or more x's
simultaneously
simple linear regression is for 1x and
multiple
linear regression is for more than one x
the next screen will focus on key
concepts of regression
there are two key concepts of regression
transfer
function to control y and vital x
click each concept to learn more
the output of regression is a transfer
function
f of x although the transfer function
f of x gives the degree of movement in y
as x
changes it is not the correct transfer
function to control y
as there may be a low level of
correlation between the two
the main thrust of regression is to
discover whether a significant
statistical relationship exists between
y
and a particular x that is by looking at
p values based on regression one can
infer the vital x
and eliminate the unimportant x's
the analyze phase helps in understanding
if there is statistical relevance
between
y and x if the relevance is established
using metrics from regression analysis
one can move forward with the tests
the simple linear regression or slr
should be used as a statistical
validation tool in the beginning of this
phase
in this screen we will understand the
concept of simple
linear regression a simple linear
regression equation
is a fitted linear equation and is
represented by the equation
shown here in this equation y
is the dependent variable and x is the
independent variable
a is the intercept of the fitted line on
the y
axis which is equal to the value of y
at x equal to zero b is the regression
coefficient
or the slope of the line and c is the
error in the regression model
which has a mean of zero the next screen
will focus on the least
squares method in simple linear
regression
with reference to the error mentioned
earlier if correlation coefficient
of y and x is not equal to one
meaning the relation is not perfectly
linear
there could be several lines that could
fit in the scatter plot
notice the two graphs displayed for the
same set of five points
two different types of lines are drawn
and both of them
have errors error refers to the points
on the scatter plot that do not fall
on the straight line drawn the second
graph shows the y-intercept
statistical software like minitab fits
the line which has the least value of
error squared and added
as is clear from the graph error is the
distance of the point from the fitted
line
typically the data lies off the line
in perfect linear relation all points
would lie
on the line and error would be zero
the distance from the point to the line
is the error distance
used in the sse calculations
let's understand slr with the help of an
example
in the next screen consider the
following example
suppose a farmer wishes to predict the
relationship
between the amount spent on fertilizers
and the annual
sales of his crops he collects the data
shown
here for the last few years and
determines his expected revenue
if he spends eight dollars annually on
fertilizers
he has targeted sales of thirty one
dollars this year
the steps to perform simple linear
regression
in ms excel are as follows
copy the data table on an excel
worksheet
select all the data from b1 to c6
this is assuming the years table appears
in cells
a1 to a6 click insert
and choose the plain scatter chart it is
titled scatter
with only markers the basic scatter
chart will appear
as shown on the screen right click on
the data points in the scatter chart
and choose the option add trendline
then choose the option linear and select
the boxes titled
display r squared value and display
equation a linear line will appear
which is called the best fit line or the
least
squares line to use the data for
regression analysis
the interpretation of the scatter chart
is as follows
the r-square value or the coefficient of
determination conveys if the model is
good
and can be used the r-square value here
is 0.3797
it means 38 percent of variability in
y is explained by x the remaining
62 variation is unexplained
or due to residual factors other factors
like
rain amount and variability sunshine
temperatures seed type and seed quality
could be tested the low value of
r square statistically validates poor
relationship
between y and x thus the equation
presented cannot be used for
further analysis in a similar situation
one should refer to the cause and effect
matrix
and study the relationship between y and
a different
x variable we will discuss
multiple linear regression in this
screen
if a new variable x2 is added to the r
square model the impact of x1 and
x2 on y gets tested this is known as
multiple linear regression the value of
r square changes due to the introduction
of the new variable
the resulting value of r square which
can be used in cases of multiple
regression
is known as r square adjusted
the model can be used if r square
adjusted value
is greater than seventy percent we will
look at the key concepts
in the next screen the key concepts in
multiple linear regression are as
follows
the residuals or the differences between
the actual
value and the predicted value give an
indication
of how good the model is if the errors
or
residuals are small and predictions use
x's that are within the range of the
collected data
the predictions should be fine the sum
of squares total can be calculated
as follows sum of squares total
or sst equals the sum of squares of
regression
or ssr plus sum of squares
of error or sse
to arrive at sum of squares of
regression ssr
use the formula ssr equals
sum of squares total or sst
minus sum of squares of error or sse
since ssr is sse subtracted from
sst value of sse should be less than
sst r squared is
sum of squares of regression or ssr
divided by
sum of squares total or sst
calculating sst and sse
helps in determining ssr and
r square to get a sense of the error in
the fitted model
calculate the value of y for a given
data
using the fitted line equation to check
for error
take two observations of y at the same x
the most important thing to remember in
regression analysis
is that the obtained fitted line
equation cannot be used to predict y for
values
of x outside the data for example
it would not be possible to predict the
amount spent on fertilizers
for a forecasted sales of 15 or
sixty dollars both data points lie
outside the data set
on which regression analysis is
performed
if y is dependent on many x's
then simple linear regression analysis
can be used to prioritize
x but it requires running separate
regressions
on y with each x if an x does not
explain variation
in y then it should not be explored any
further
these were the interpretations of the
simple linear regression equation
in the next screen we will learn that
despite a relationship
being established between two variables
the change in one
may not cause a change in the other
let us discuss the difference between
correlation and causation
in the following screen a regression
equation denotes only a relationship
between the y and the x this does not
mean that a change in one variable
will cause a change in the other if
number of schools and incidents of crime
in a city
rise together there may be a
relationship but no causation
the increase in both the factors could
be due to a third factor
that is population in other words
both of them may be dependent variables
to an independent variable
consider the graphs shown on the screen
the graphs on the left
show the relations between number of
sneezes
and incidence of death with respect to
population
both have a positive correlation finding
a positive correlation between
incidents of deaths and number of
sneezes
does not mean we assume sneezing is the
cause of somebody's death
despite the correlation being very
strong as depicted in the graph on the
right
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will discuss hypothesis
testing
in detail let us learn about statistical
and practical significance of hypothesis
test
in the following screen the differences
between a variable
and its hypothesized value may be
statistically significant
but may not be practical or economically
meaningful
for example based on a hypothesis test
nutra worldwide inc wants to implement a
trading strategy
which is proven to provide statistically
significant returns
however it does not guarantee trading on
this strategy would result
in economically meaningful positive
returns
when the logical reasons are examined
before implementation the returns are
economically significant
the returns may not be significant when
statistically proven strategy
is implemented directly the returns may
not be economically significant
after accounting for taxes transaction
costs
and risks inherent in the strategy
thus there should be a practical or
economic significant study
before implementing any statistically
significant data
the next screen will briefly focus on
the conceptual differences
between a null and an alternate
hypothesis
the conceptual differences between a
null and an
alternate hypothesis are as follows
assume the specification of the current
process is
itself the null hypothesis null
hypothesis
denoted as the basic assumption for any
activity or experiment
is represented as h o
no hypothesis cannot be proved it can
only be rejected
or disproved it is important to note
that if null hypothesis
is rejected alternative hypothesis
must be right for example assuming that
a movie is good
one plans to watch it therefore the null
hypothesis
in this scenario will be movie is good
alternative hypothesis or h a challenges
the null hypothesis
or is the converse of the null
hypothesis
in this scenario alternate hypothesis
will be
movie is not good in the following
screen
we will discuss type 1 and type 2 error
rejecting a null hypothesis when it is
true
is called type 1 error it is also known
as
producer's risk for example the
rejection of a product by the qa
team when it is not defective will cause
loss to the producer suppose when a
movie is good
it is reviewed to be not good this
reflects
type 1 error in this case the null
hypothesis
is rejected when it is actually true
the two important points to be noted are
significance level or alpha is the
chance of committing a type 1 error
the value of alpha is 0.05 or
5 percent accepting a null hypothesis
when it is false is called type 2 error
it is also known as consumer's risk
for example the acceptance of a
defective product by the quality analyst
of an organization
will cause loss to the consumer who buys
it
minimizing type 2 error requires
acceptance criteria to be very strict
suppose when a movie is not good it is
reviewed to be good
this reflects type two error in this
case the alternate hypothesis
is rejected when it was actually true
the two
important points to be noted are beta is
the chance of committing a type 2
error the value of beta is 0.2
or 20 percent any experiment should have
as less beta value as possible
the next screen will cover the key
points to remember about type 1
and type 2 error
as you start dealing with the two types
of errors
keep the following points in mind
the probability of making one type of
error can be reduced when one is willing
to accept a higher probability
of making the other type of error
suppose the management of a company
producing pacemakers
wants to ensure no defective pacemaker
reaches the consumer
so the quality assurance team makes
stringent guidelines to inspect the
pacemakers
this would invariably decrease the beta
error
or type 2 error but this will also
increase the chance that a non-defective
pacemaker is declared defective
by the quality assurance team thus alpha
error
or type 1 error increases
if all null hypotheses are accepted to
avoid rejecting true
null hypothesis it will lead to type 2
error typically alpha is set at 0.05
which means that the risk of committing
a type 1 error
is 1 out of 20 experiments in case of
any product
the teams must decide what type of error
should be less
and set the value of alpha and beta
accordingly
in the next screen we will discuss the
power of test
the power of a hypothesis test or the
power of test
is the probability of correctly
rejecting the null hypothesis
when it is false power of a test is
represented by
1 minus beta which is also the type 2
error
the probability of not committing a type
2 error is called the power of a
hypothesis test
the power of a test helps in improving
the advantage of hypothesis testing
the higher the power of a test the
better it is for purposes
of hypothesis testing given a choice of
tests
the one with the highest power should be
preferred
the only way to decrease the probability
of a type 2 error
given the significance level or
probability of type 1 error
is to increase the sample size
it is important to note that quality
inspection is done on sample pieces
and not on all the products so beta
error is a function of the sample size
if the sample size is not appropriate
the defects in a product line could
easily be missed out
giving a wrong perception of the quality
of the product
this will increase the type ii error
to decrease this error the quality
assurance team has to
increase the sample size in hypothesis
testing
alpha is called the significance level
and one
minus alpha is called the confidence
level of the test
in the next screen we will focus on the
determinants of sample size for
continuous data
the sample size can be calculated by
answering three simple questions how
much variation
is present in the population at what
interval does the true population mean
need to be estimated and how much
representation error
is allowed in the sample continuous data
is data which can be measured
the sample size for continuous data can
be determined by the formula
shown on the screen we will learn about
the standard sample size formula for
continuous data
in the next screen
representation error or alpha error is
generally assumed to be
5 or 0.05
hence the expression of 1 minus alpha
divided by 2
amounts to 0.975 or 97.5 percent
looking up the value of z 97.5
from the z table gives the value 1.96
the expression reduces to the one shown
on screen
when alpha is 5 z is 1.96
to detect a change that is half the
standard deviation
one needs to get at least 16 data points
for the sample
click the example tab to view an example
of continuous data calculation
using standard sample size formula
the population standard deviation for
the time to resolve
customer problems is 30 hours
what should be the size of a sample that
can estimate the average
problem resolution time within plus or
minus 5 hours tolerance
with 99 percent confidence to know with
99
confidence that the time to resolve a
customer problem
ranges between 25 and 35 hours
the value of z for 99.5 must be
two point five seven five a good result
should fall outside the range of zero
point five percent
which is one in two hundred trials it is
expected
that one hundred ninety nine out of two
hundred trials will confirm
a proper conclusion the calculation
gives a result of 238.70
one cannot have point seven zero of a
sample
so one needs to round up to the nearest
integer
if there are 239 samples the
significance level is greater than 0.01
which indicates the confidence is less
than 99
using 239 reduces alpha and
increases the confidence level the
rounded up value
239 means the expectations are being met
for the confidence level
of the test
we will learn about the standard sample
size formula for discrete data in this
screen
like continuous data one can find out
the sample size required
while dealing with discrete population
if the average population proportion
non-defective is p then population
standard deviation can be
calculated by using the expression shown
on the screen
the expression for sample size is
present
it is important to note that in this
expression the interval or tolerance is
in percentage click the example tab to
view an example of discrete data
calculation
using standard sample size formula
the non-defective population proportion
for pen
manufacturing is eighty percent what
should be the sample size to
draw a sample that can estimate the
proportion of compliant pans
within plus or minus five percent with
an alpha of five percent
consider calculating the sample size for
discrete data
for which the population proportion
non-defective
is eighty percent and the tolerance
limit is within plus or minus five
percent
substituting the values it is found the
sample size
should be 246. in this example
to know if the population proportion for
good pens is still within 75 to 85
percent
and to have 95 percent confidence that
the sample
will allow a good conclusion one needs
to inspect 245.86 pounds
0.86 of a pen cannot be inspected
so the value is rounded up to maintain
the confidence level
inspecting 245 or fewer pens
reduces the confidence level this means
the z value would be lower than 1.96
and alpha would be greater than 0.05
suppose one is willing to accept a
greater range in the estimate
the proportion is within 20 percent of
the past results
and approximately within one standard
deviation of the proportion
delta changes to 0.20 and the number of
needed samples is
15.4 is approximately equal to
16.
this screen will focus on the hypothesis
testing roadmap
though the basic determinants of
accepting or rejecting a hypothesis
remain the same
various tests are used depending on the
type of data
from the figure shown on the screen you
can conclude the type of test to be
performed
based on the kind of data and values
available
for discrete data if mean and standard
deviation are both
known the z-test is used and if mean is
known
but standard deviation is unknown the
t-test
is used if the standard deviation is
unknown and if the sample size is less
than 30
it is preferable to use the t-test if
variance is known
one should go for chi-squared test if
mean and standard deviation
are known for a set of continuous data
it is recommended to go
for the z-test for mean comparison of
two with standard deviation unknown
go for t-test and for mean comparison of
many with standard deviation
unknown go for f-test also
if the variance is known for continuous
data go for f-test
the next few screens will discuss in
detail the tests for
mean variance and proportions let us
understand hypothesis test for means
theoretical
through an example in the next screen
the examples of hypothesis testing based
on the types of data and values
available are discussed here
the value of alpha can be assumed to be
5
or 0.05 suppose you want to check for
the average
height of a population north american
males are selected as the population
here
from the population 117 men are gathered
as the sample
and the readings of their height are
taken
the null hypothesis is that the average
height of north american males
is 165 centimeters and the alternate
hypothesis
is that the height is lesser or greater
than 165 centimeters
consider the sample size n as 117
for z test and sample size n is 25
for t test sample average or x bar
is 164.5 centimeters
using the data given let us calculate
the z
calc value and t calc value the
population height
is 165 centimeters with a standard
deviation of 5.2 centimeters
and the average height of the sample
group is 164.5 centimeters
the test for significant difference
should be conducted
first let us compute z calc value using
the formula given on the screen
hence the z calc is 1.04
which is less than 1.96 or t
critical therefore the null hypothesis
cannot be rejected
since z 0.05 equals 1.96
the null hypothesis is not rejected at
five percent level of significance
the statistical notation is shown on the
screen
thus a conclusion based on the sample
collected is that the average height of
north american males
is 165 centimeters if the population
standard deviation is not known
a t-test is used it is similar to the
z-test
instead of using the population
parameter or sigma
the sample statistic standard deviation
or s
is used in this example the s value is
5.0
let us now compute t value using the
formula
given on the screen the statistical
notation to reject null hypothesis
is shown on the screen the t critical
value is 2.064
and we know the t calc value is 0.5
which is less than 2.064
therefore the null hypothesis cannot be
rejected at five percent
level of significance thus a conclusion
based on the sample collected is that
the average height of north american
males
is 165 centimeters the conclusion of not
rejecting the null hypothesis
is based on the assumption that the 25
males
are randomly selected from all males in
north america
null and alternative hypotheses are same
for both
z-test and t-test in both the examples
the null hypothesis is not rejected
in the next screen we will understand
the hypothesis test for variance
with an example in hypothesis test for
variance
chi-square test is used in the case of a
chi-square test
the null and alternate hypotheses are
defined
and the values of chi-square critical
and chi-square
are calculated to understand this
concept with an example
click the button given on the screen
the null hypothesis is that the
proportion of wins in australia or
abroad
is independent of the country played
against
the alternate hypothesis is that the
proportion of wins in australia or
abroad
is dependent on the country played
against
chi-square critical is 6.251
and chi-square calculated is 1.36
since the calculated value is less than
the critical value
the proportion of wins of the australia
hockey team
is independent of the country played or
place in this screen
we will discuss hypothesis test for
proportions with an example
the hypothesis test on population
proportion can be performed
to understand this with an example click
the button given
on the screen let us perform hypothesis
test on population proportion
the null hypothesis is that the
proportion of smokers among males
in a place named r is 0.10
represented as p 0. the alternative
hypothesis
is the proportion is different than 0.10
in notation it is represented as null
hypothesis
is p equals p zero against alternative
hypothesis
is p different than p zero
a sample of 150 adult males are
interviewed
and it is found that 23 of them are
smokers
thus the sample proportion is 23 divided
by
150 which is 0.153
substituting this value in the
expression of z
given on the screen gives the result of
1.80
you can reject the null hypothesis at
level of significance
alpha if z is greater than z alpha
for five percent level of confidence the
z value should be 1.96
since the calculated z value is more
than what is required for five percent
level of confidence
the null hypothesis is rejected
hence it can be concluded that the
proportion of smokers in
r is greater than 0.10
in this screen we will focus on
comparison of means of two processes
means of two processes are compared to
understand whether the outcomes of the
two processes
are significantly different this test
is helpful in understanding whether a
new process is better than an old
process
this test can also determine whether the
two samples belong to the same
population
or different populations it is
especially required for benchmarking
to compare an existing process with
another benchmarked process
let us proceed to the next screen to
learn about the paired comparison
hypothesis test
for means the example of two mean
t-tests with unequal variances is
discussed here
null and alternate hypotheses are
defined
the average heights of men in two
different sets of people
are compared to see if the means are
significantly different
for this test the sample sizes means and
variances
are required to calculate the value of t
two samples of sizes n one of one
hundred twenty five
and n two of one hundred ten are taken
from the two populations
the mean value of sample size one is one
hundred 167.3
and sample size 2 is 165.8
the standard deviation for sample sizes
1 and 2
are 4.2 and 5.0 respectively
using the formula given on the screen
the t
value is derived as 2.47
the null hypothesis is rejected if the
calculated value of t
is more than the required value of t
in other words reject null hypothesis at
level of significance
a if computed t value is greater than t
of df a divided by two
with a t-test we're comparing two means
and the population parameter
sigma is unknown therefore we're pulling
the sample
standard deviations in order to
calculate t
the variances are weighted by the number
of data points
in each sample group since t 223
and 0.025 equals 1.96
the null hypothesis is rejected at 5
level of significance the test used here
is known as the paired t-test and is
considered
a very powerful test in the next screen
we will look into the example
of the paired comparison hypothesis test
for variance of
f-test it is important to understand the
different types of tests
through an example susan is trying to
compare the standard deviation of two
companies
according to her the earnings of company
a
are more volatile than those of company
b
she has been obtaining earnings data for
the past 31 years for company a
and for the past 41 years for company b
she finds that the sample standard
deviation of company a's
earnings is four dollars forty cents and
of company
b's earnings is three dollars ninety
cents
determine whether the earnings of
company a have a greater standard
deviation
than those of company b at five percent
level
of significance click the button given
on the screen
to know the answer
susan has the data of the earnings of
the companies
distributions rarely have the same
spread or variance
when processes are improved one of the
strategies is to reduce the variation
it is important to be able to compare
variances with each other
a null hypothesis would indicate no
change has occurred
if it can be rejected and the variance
is lower
one can claim success the statistical
notation for this example
is given on the screen suppose one has
to compare two sets of company data
susan has looked at the earnings of two
companies
she has been studying the effects of
strategy management styles
and leadership profiles on the earnings
of these companies
there are significant differences in
these kpiv's
she wants to know if they have an effect
on the variance in the earnings
she has sample data over several decades
for each company
by the given data it can be concluded
that earnings of company a
have a greater standard deviation than
those of company b
in calculating the f-test statistic
always put the greater variance in the
numerator
let us look at the f test example of
hypothesis test for equality of variance
in this screen the degrees of freedom
for company a
and company b are 30 and 40 respectively
the critical value from f table equals
1.74
the null hypothesis is rejected if the f
test statistic
is greater than 1.74 the calculated
value of
f test statistic is 1.273
and therefore at the 5 significance
level
the null hypothesis cannot be rejected
the next screen will focus on hypothesis
tests f-test
for independent groups
a restaurant which wants to explore the
recent overuse of avocados
suspects there is a difference between
two chefs
and the number of avocados used to
prepare the salads
the data shown in the table is the
measure of avocados in ounces
the weight of avocado slices used in
salads
prepared by two different chefs is to
determine if
one chef is using more avocados than the
other
perhaps the restaurant's expenditures on
avocados
is greater this month than the average
of the past 12 months
this is assuming there is no change in
avocado prices
or the amount of avocados being used
click the tab to learn to conduct an
f-test in ms excel
the f-test is conducted in ms excel
through the following steps open ms
excel
click data click data analysis
please follow the facilitator
instruction on how to install
add-ins select f-test to sample for
variances
in variable one range select the data
set for group
a and select data set for group b in
variable 2 range
click ok the screen shot of the f test
window
is also shown here in this screen
we will discuss the f test assumptions
before interpreting the f test the
assumptions to be considered
are null hypothesis there is no
significant statistical difference
between the variances of the two groups
thus concluding any variation could be
because of chance
this is common cause of variation
alternate hypothesis there is a
significant statistical difference
between the variances of the two groups
thus concluding that variations could be
because of assignable causes too
this is special cause of variation
the following screen will focus on
f-test interpretations
the interpretations for the conducted
f-test are
from the excel result sheet the p-value
is
0.03 if p-value
is low or below 0.05 the null
must be rejected thus no hypothesis
with 97 confidence is rejected
also the fact that variation could only
be due to common cause of variation
is rejected it is inferred from the test
that there could be assignable causes of
variation
or special causes of variation
excel provides the descriptive
statistics for each variable
it also gives the degrees of freedom for
each
f is the calculated f statistic f
critical is a reference number found in
a statistics book table
p of f less than or equal to f
is the probability that f really is less
than f
critical or that the null hypothesis
would be falsely
rejected since the p-value is less than
the alpha
the null hypothesis can be confidently
rejected
alongside conducting a hypothesis test
a meaningful conclusion from the test
has been drawn
the following screen will focus on
hypothesis test
t-test for independent groups
as discussed earlier the table shows the
measure of avocados in ounces
and the significant difference in their
means needs to be inspected
if a significant amount of difference is
found it can be concluded that there is
a possibility of special cause of
variation
the next screen will demonstrate how to
conduct the two-sample
t-test the two-sample
independent t-test inspects two groups
of data for significant difference in
their means
the idea is to conclude if there is a
significant amount of difference
if there is a statistical evidence of
variation
one can conclude a possibility of
special cause of variation
the steps for conducting a two-sample
t-test are
open ms excel click data and click
data analysis select two-sample
independent t-test assuming unequal
variances
in variable 1 range select the data set
for group
a and select the data set for group b in
variable 2 range
keep the hypothesized mean difference as
0.
click ok in the following screen
we will focus on two sample independent
t test
assumptions the assumptions for a two
sample
independent t test are null hypothesis
there is no significant statistical
difference between the means of the two
groups
thus concluding any variation could be
because of chance
this is common cause of variation
alternate hypothesis there is a
significant statistical difference
between the means of the two groups
thus concluding that variations could be
because of assignable causes too
this is special cause of variation the
null hypothesis states the mean of group
a
is equal to the mean of group b
the alternate hypothesis states that the
mean of group a
is not equal to the mean of group b
note that alternate hypothesis tests two
conditions
mean of a is less than mean of b and
mean of a
is greater than mean of b thus a
two-tailed probability
needs to be used before we interpret the
t-test results
let us compare the two-tailed and
one-tailed probability
in the next screen two-tailed
probability
and one-tailed probability are used
depending on the direction of the
alternate hypothesis
if the alternate hypothesis tests more
than one direction
either less or more use a two-tailed
probability value
from the test example if mean of
a is not equal to mean of b then it is
two-tailed probability if the alternate
hypothesis
tests only one direction use a
one-tailed probability value from the
test
example if mean of a is greater than
mean of b then it is one-tailed
probability
in the next screen let us look at the
two-sample independent t-test results
and interpretations the results are
shown in the table on the screen
the inference is as the two-tailed
probability is being tested
the p-value of two-tailed probability
testing is 0.24
which is greater than 0.05
if p-value is greater than 0.05
the null hypothesis is not rejected
this means one cannot reject the fact
that there is no
significant statistical difference
between the two means
similar to the f-test excel provides the
descriptive statistics for each group or
variable
the t stat is shown excel also shows
one-tailed
or two-tailed data for the one-tailed
test
the alpha is 0.05 the error
is expected to be in one direction for
the two-tailed test
the error is alpha slash two or
zero point zero two five in this example
t stat or t calculated is less than
either t
criticals therefore the null hypothesis
cannot be rejected
thus it can be inferred that both the
groups are statistically
same we will discuss the paired t-test
in the next screen paired t-test is
another hypothesis
test from the family of t-tests the
following points will help in
understanding the paired t-test
in detail the paired t-test is one of
the most powerful tests
from the t-test family the paired t-test
is conducted before
and after the process to be measured for
example
a group of students score x in cssgb
before taking the training program post
the training
program the scores are taken again one
needs to find out if there is a
statistical difference between the two
sets of scores
if there is a significant difference the
inference could be that the training was
effective
it is important to note that the paired
t-test interpretation
shows the effectiveness of the
improvement measures
this is the main reason why paired
t-tests are often used in the improve
stage
let us learn about sample variance in
the following screen
sample variance is defined as the
average of the squared differences from
the mean
the sample variance that is s square can
be used to calculate
and understand the degree of variation
of a sample
it can also be used in statistics
however
it cannot be used or explained directly
because its value does not provide any
information
to use the value you have to first
convert it into standard deviation
and then combine it with the mean click
the button to know the steps for
calculating the sample variance
step one calculate the mean or average
of the sample
step two subtract each of the values
from the mean
step three calculate the square value of
the results
step four take the average of the
squared differences
let us understand how to calculate the
sample variance with the help of an
example
in this screen consider the sample of
weights
the mean value is one hundred forty when
you subtract the individual values from
the mean
take the square value of the results and
then take the average of the squared
differences you will get 1936
as the sample variance this number is
not useful as it is
in order to get the standard deviation
take the square root of the sample
variance
square root of 1936 equals forty four
the standard deviation in combination
with the mean
will tell you how much the majority of
the people weigh
in this example if your mean is one
hundred forty
and your variance is forty four you can
conclude
that the majority of people weigh
between 96 pounds
mean minus 44 and 184 pounds
mean plus 44. let us proceed to the next
screen that focuses
on the analysis of variance or anova
which is the comparison of more than two
means
a t-test is used for one sample two
sample tests are used for comparing two
means to compare the means of more than
two samples
use the anova method anova stands for
analysis of variance anova does not tell
the better mean
it helps in understanding that all the
sample means are not equal
the shortlisted samples based on anova
output can further be tested
one important aspect of anova is it
generalizes the t
test to include more than two samples
performing multiple
two-sample t-tests would increase the
chance of committing a type one error
hence anovas is useful in comparing two
or more means
the next screen will help in
understanding this concept through an
exam
as an example consider the takeaway food
delivery time
of three different outlets is there any
evidence that the averages for the three
outlets are not equal
in other words can the delivery time be
benchmarked on the outlet
the null hypothesis will assume that the
three means are equal
if the null hypothesis is rejected it
would mean that there are
at least two outlets that are different
in their average delivery time
in minitab one can perform anova in one
of the statistics packages
ensure that the data of the table is
stacked in two columns
in the main menu go to stat anova and
then one way
the left column of the table will have
the outlets and the right column will
have the time
in minutes this is similar to the table
shown on the screen
in the one-way analysis of variance
window
select the response as delivery time and
factor as
outlet and click ok
the output of this process is shown here
notice the p value which is much higher
than 0.05
the steps to perform anova in excel are
as follows
after entering the data to a spreadsheet
select the anova
single factor test from the data
analysis tool pack
select the array for analysis designate
that the data is in columns
and select an output range excel
shows the descriptive statistics for
each column in the top table
in the second table the anova analysis
shows whether the variation is greater
between the groups
or within the groups it shows the sum of
squares or
ss degrees of freedom df
means of squares ms or sum of squares
divided by
n minus 1 or variance the f statistic
ms between divided by ms within
p-value and f-critical from a reference
table
the f and p are calculated for the
variation that occurs within each of the
groups
and between the groups if the conditions
in the groups are significant
it would be expected to see the between
groups ss much higher
and the ms slightly higher
let us now interpret the minitab anova
results
since the p-value is more than 0.05
the null hypothesis is accepted
this means there is no significant
difference between
means of delivery time for the three
outlets
based on the confidence intervals it is
found that the intervals overlap
which means there is little that
separates the means of the three samples
in one-way anova where there was only
one factor to be benchmarked
that is the outlet of delivery if there
are two factors
you may use the two-way anova
in this screen we will learn in detail
about chi-square distribution
the chi-square distribution is one of
the most widely used probability
distributions
in inferential statistics it is also
known as hypothesis testing
and the distribution is used in
hypothesis tests
when used in hypothesis test needs one
sample for the test to be conducted
the chi-squared distribution is also
known as chi
squared it has k1 degrees of freedom
and is the distribution of a sum of the
squares of k independent standard
normal random variables suppose in a
field for
nine players player one comes in and can
choose amongst all nine positions
available
player two can choose only amongst eight
and so on
after all the eight players have chosen
their positions
the last player gets to choose the last
position left
the eight players are free to choose in
a playing field of nine
eight is the degree of freedom for this
example conventionally
degree of freedom is n1 where n is the
sample size
for example if w x y and z are four
random variables
with standard normal distributions the
random variable
f which is the sum of w square x square
y square and z square has a chi-square
distribution
the degrees of freedom of the
distribution or the df
equals the number of normally
distributed variables used
in this case df equals four
the formula for chi-squared distribution
is shown on the screen
it is important to note that f of o
stands for an observed frequency
and f of e stands for an expected
frequency
the next screen will explain chi-square
test through an example
suppose the australian hockey team
wishes to analyze its wins at home
and abroad against four different
countries
the data has two classifications and the
table
is also known as a two by four
contingency table
with two rows and four columns the
expected frequencies can be calculated
assuming there is a relationship
thus expected frequency for each of the
observed frequency
is equal to product of row total and
column total
divided by overall total one has to find
out how to calculate the expected
frequency
if the observed frequency is three wins
against south africa
in australia then it would convert to
total winds at home which is 21 divided
by the total number of wins or
31 and is the result multiplied by
five the result is 3.39
similarly the expected population
parameters for all cases
are found in this step all the
information of the previous screen is
combined
and the table is populated the estimated
population parameters are calculated
and added the formula estimates the
observed frequency
to calculate the final chi-square index
which in this case is 1.36
it is important to note that there is a
different chi-squared distribution
for each of the different numbers of
degrees of freedom
for the chi-square distribution the
degrees of freedom are calculated as per
the number of rows and columns in the
contingency table
the equation for degrees of freedom
should be noticed
the number of degrees of freedom is
equal to three
assuming an alpha of ten percent the
chi-squared distribution in the
chi-square table
is noticed and a critical chi-square
index of
6.251 is arrived at
chi-square calculated value is 1.36
both the values of the chi-square index
should be plotted
the critical chi-square distribution
divides the whole region into acceptance
and rejection while the calculated
chi-square distribution
is based on data and conveys whether the
data falls into
an acceptance or rejection region
therefore as the calculated value is
less than the critical value
and falls in the acceptance region the
proportion of wins of the aussie team at
home or abroad
has nothing to do with the opponent
being played against
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the next screen
in this topic we will learn in detail
about hypothesis testing with non-normal
data
let us begin with the mon whitney test
in the next screen
the mon whitney test also known as the
wilcoxon
rank sum test is a non-parametric test
which is used to compare two
unpaired groups in this test the value
of alpha is by default
set at 0.05 and the rejection
and acceptance condition remains the
same for different cases
that is if p is less than alpha reject
the null hypothesis
if p is greater than alpha reject the
alternate hypothesis
the aim of this test is to rank the
entire data available for each condition
and then compare the total outcome of
the two ranks
click the button to know the steps to
perform the mon whitney test
to perform the mon whitney test first
rank all the values from low to high
without paying
any attention to the group to which each
value belongs
the smallest number gets a rank of one
the largest number gets a rank of n
where n is the total number of values in
the two groups
if there are ties continue to rank the
values anyway
pretending they are slightly different
then
find the average of the ranks for all
the identical values
and assign that rank to all these values
continue this till all the whole number
ranks have been used
next sort the values into two groups
these can now be used for the mon
whitney u test
summate the ranks for the observations
from sample one
and then summate the ranks in sample two
larger group
let us look at an example of the mon
whitney test in this screen
suppose you have two sets of data g1
and g2 the g1 values are
14 2 5 16 and 9
and the g2 values are 4 2 18
14 and 8. now combine
the g1 and g2 values sort them in
ascending order
and mention the group name against each
value
next rank the groups from 1 to 10 and
check if any values are identical
take an average of the ranks of the
identical values
and place it against the identical
values in the final rank column
hence the average final rank is 1.5 for
ranks 1 and 2.
similarly the average final rank is 7.5
for ranks 7 and 8. next calculate
r1 and r2 by adding the ranks of the
groups 1 and 2 respectively
in this example the r 1 value is 28
and our 2 value is 27 from the given
data
5 is the value of both n1 and
n2 the formula for the mon whitney u
test for n one and n
two values is u one equals n one
multiplied by n two plus n one
multiplied by
n one plus one whole divided by two
minus r one
similarly u2 equals n1 multiplied by n2
plus n2 multiplied by n2 plus 1 whole
divided by 2 minus r2 in this example
the value of u1 is 12 and u2
is 13. now the u value can be calculated
by taking the minimum value among 12 and
13
which is 12. look up the mon whitney u
test table
for n 1 equals five and n two equals
five
you will get the critical value of u as
two
to be statistically significant the
obtained u
has to be equal to or less than this
critical value
our calculated value of u is 12 which is
not less than two
that means there is no statistical
difference between the means
of the two groups in this screen we will
learn about the kruskal-wallis test
the kruskal-wallis test is named after
william kruskal
and w alan wallace it is also a
non-parametric test
used for testing the source of origin of
samples for example
whether the samples originate from the
same distribution or not
the characteristics of the
kruskal-wallis test are as follows
it is the only way to analyze variants
by ranks
this test compares the medians of two or
more samples
to find out if the samples are from
different populations
since this test is a non-parametric
method
it does not assume the normal
distribution of the residuals
unlike the analogous one-way analysis of
variance
for this test the null hypothesis is
that the medians of all groups are equal
and the alternate hypothesis is that at
least
one population median of one group is
different from the population median
of at least one other group let us learn
about the moods median
in the next screen the mood's median
is also a non-parametric test that is
used to test the equality of medians
from two or more different populations
this test works when the output y
variable is continuous
and discrete ordinal or discrete count
while the input x variable is discrete
with two
or more attributes click the button to
view the steps involved in the mood's
median test
following are the steps in the mood's
median test
first find the median of the combined
data set
next find the number of values in each
sample that are greater than the median
and form a contingency table then find
the expected value for each cell
and finally find the chi-square value
we will learn about the freedmen test in
this screen
the friedman test is another form of a
non-parametric test
it does not make any assumptions about
the specific
shape of the population from which the
sample is drawn
and therefore allows smaller sample data
sets to be
analyzed unlike anova the friedman test
does not require the data set to be
randomly sampled
from normally distributed populations
with equal variances
this test uses a two-tailed hypothesis
test
where the null hypothesis is that the
population medians of each treatment
are statistically identical to the rest
of the group
in the next screen we will learn about
the one sample sign
test the one sample sign test is the
simplest of all the non-parametric tests
that can be used
instead of a one-sample t-test it is
similar to the concept of testing if a
coin is fair
in showing heads or tails here the null
hypothesis
represented as h o is the hypothecated
median
or assumed median of the sample which
belongs to the population
click the button to view the steps
involved in the one sample sign
test following are the steps in a one
sample sign
test first count the number of positive
values
these are the values that are larger
than the hypothesized median
next count the number of negative values
these are the values that are smaller
than the hypothesized median
finally test the values to check if
there are significantly
more positive values or negative values
than expected this screen will focus on
the one sample wilcoxon test
the one sample wilcoxon test also known
as the wilcoxon
signed rank test is another form of a
non-parametric test
this test is equivalent to the
parametric one-sample t-test
and more powerful than the
non-parametric one-sample
sign test let us discuss the
characteristics of this test
in the following screen some of the
characteristics of this test
are as follows this test assumes that
the sample
is randomly taken from a population with
a symmetric frequency distribution
around the median also in this test
the symmetry can be observed with the
histogram or by checking if the median
and mean are approximately equal the
conclusion in this test
is that if the value is on the midpoint
you can continue and
accept the null hypothesis if not you
need to reject
the alternate hypothesis click the
button given on the screen
to view an example let us consider
an example the median customer
satisfaction score of an organization
has always been 3.7 and the management
wants to see
if this has changed they conduct a
survey
and get the results grouped by the
customer type
the conclusion will be as follows if the
median value is 3.7
the null hypothesis h o can be accepted
if not the alternate hypothesis needs to
be rejected
the alpha value will be 0.05
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description
to know more this lesson will focus on
the improved phase of the dmacc
process the improved phase comes after
the analyze phase
in the analyze phase the data was
analyzed
and some patterns were found to identify
where the problem lies
design of experiments or doe consists of
a series of planned and scientific
experiments
that test various input variables and
their eventual impact on the output
variable
design of experiments can be used as a
one-stop alternative for analyzing all
influencing factors
to arrive at a successful model doe is
applicable where
multiple input variables known as
factors affect a single response
variable an output variable is the
variable which may get affected due to
multiple input variables
doe is preferred over one factor at a
time or
o fat experiments because it does not
miss interactions
with techniques like blocking
experimental error can be eliminated
the trials should be randomized to avoid
concluding that a factor is significant
when the time at which it is measured or
the sequence followed may have
influenced the responses result
an example of blocking is highlighted in
the table given on the screen
with techniques like replication many
experiments can be conducted to ensure a
robust model
we will understand the concept of design
experiments through an example
in the upcoming screen to understand doe
and the main effects consider the
following example
suppose the objective of the experiment
is to achieve
uniform part dimensions at a particular
target value
to reduce variations the inputs x
or factors that affect the output are
cycle time
mold temperature holding pressure
holding time
and material type the process is the
molding process
and the output or the response of the
experiment is the part
hardness the components of the doe
in this example will be described in the
next screen
output response factors levels and
interactions are the components of the
doe
in the given example click each
component to learn more
the response variable is the part
hardness and is measured as a result of
the experiment
and is used to judge the effects of
factors
factors of this experimental setup are
cycle time
mold temperature holding pressure
holding time
and material type factors can be varied
and are called levels
the molding temperature can be set at
600 degrees fahrenheit
or 700 degrees fahrenheit plastic type
can be
fillers and no fillers and the material
type has two levels of
nylon or acetyl
interactions refer to the degree to
which factors depend on one another
some experiments evaluate the effect of
interactions
in the molding example the interaction
between
cycle time and molding temperature is
critical
the best level for time depends on what
temperature is set
if the temperature level is higher the
cycle time may have to be decreased
to achieve the same response from the
experiment
let us understand full factorial
experiments through
an example full factorial experimental
design
contains all combinations of all levels
of all factors
this experimental design ensures no
possible treatment combinations get
omitted
hence full factorial designs are often
preferred over
other designs the table shown here is
for a two-way
heat treatment experiment there are two
factors
oven time x2 and the temperature x1
at which the material is drawn out of
the oven
the output y of the experiment is the
hardness of the material
each of the factors has two levels this
example illustrates the concepts of
main factor and interaction effects from
the table
it is clear that without repetition the
experiment will have four
different outcomes based on the changes
in levels of factors
each experimental trial here is repeated
to give a total of eight values
let us now analyze the mean effect
an analysis of the means helps in
understanding how a change in
temperature at which the material is
drawn
creates a difference in the average part
hardness
this affects the output and is called
the main effect
analysis of means also tells how a
change in oven time
creates a difference in the average part
hardness this is also
the main effect analysis of means
explains how interaction between
temperature and time
affects the average part hardness this
is known as the
interaction effect let us next
understand the concept
of main effect for calculating the main
effect
the means have to be calculated hence to
calculate the main effect
of draw temperature the mean of the
hardness values has to be calculated
the values are populated in the
corresponding columns of draw
temperatures
the columns have been labeled a1 and a2
the value of the mean of a1 is 91
and of a2 is 82. plotting the data on a
graph
shows that changing draw temperatures
changes the average hardness
similarly we calculate the mean of
hardness values in
b1 and b2 the values are
87 and 86 which are plotted on a graph
it can be seen that changing the oven
time does not affect the average
hardness
now let us understand how the
interaction between temperature and time
affects the average part hardness to
check how
draw temperature and oven time interact
the mean values are calculated by taking
the repetition response
hence the cell a1 b1 has the mean of the
values
90 and 87. the cell a2
b1 has the mean of the values 84 and 87.
after the mean values are calculated
they are plotted on a graph
the graph shows that to reduce
interactions
low temperature and high oven time
should be selected to have the desired
output of
high hardness also called renault
hardness
if low hardness is the desired output
the experimental setup should have
high draw temperature and high oven time
the ideal case is represented by the
parallel lines
which give the desired output based on
the main effect
without being affected by the
interaction between the factors
the parallel lines are shown as a dotted
line
the mean of the factors are also
calculated and shown in the small table
in this we will introduce the concept of
runs
in design of experiments the numbers of
experiments in a doe setting is known as
runs a full factorial experiment
without replication on five factors and
two levels
is two raised to the power of five which
equals
32 runs a full factorial experiment with
one replication on five factors and two
levels
is 32 plus 32 which equals
64 runs a half fractional factorial
experiment without replication on five
factors and two levels
is two raised to the power of five minus
one
which equals sixteen runs a half
factorial experiment
with one replication on five factors and
two levels
is 16 plus 16 which equals 32 runs
the number of combinations can be
determined using the formula
l to the power of f where l is the
number of levels
and f is the number of factors half
fractional factorial
is calculated using the formula l to the
power
f minus one at three levels
five factors full factorial experiment
would amount to 243 trials
and half factorial experiments would
require 81
trials the difference between full
factorial
and half fractional factorial
experiments can be seen from the number
of runs
let us proceed to the next topic of this
lesson in the following screen
in this topic we will discuss root cause
analysis in detail
we will learn about residuals analysis
in the following screen
while performing the regression analysis
of a linear or
non-linear model you will get a model
with the predicted values
some of the data might fit within that
model whereas
others may be scattered across the
modeled equation predicts one value for
y
at level x however the actual value for
y
observed at that level of x is different
from the predicted value
this difference between the observed
value of the dependent variable y
and the predicted value is called
residual
the formula to calculate residual is
observed value
minus predicted value residuals are
considered to be errors
and each data point has one residual you
can validate the assumptions on random
errors
as they are independent exhibit normal
distribution
have a constant various sigma square for
all the settings
of the independent variables and finally
have a mean
as zero in the next slide we will
continue to discuss
residuals analysis as discussed in the
previous screen
while performing any regression analysis
you will observe that not all the data
fits into the linear model
as the linear regression model is not
always appropriate for the data
therefore you should assess the
appropriateness of the model
by defining residuals and examining the
residual plots
if all assumptions are satisfied the
residuals
should randomly vary around zero and the
spread of the residuals
should be the same throughout the plot
that is
no systematic patterns are observed
remember in residuals analysis both the
sum
and the mean of the residuals are zero
residuals and diagnostic statistics
allow you to identify patterns that
either poorly fit in the model with a
strong influence on the estimated
parameters
or have a high leverage it is helpful to
interpret these diagnostics together to
understand
any potential problems with the model
in the next screen we will learn about
data transformation
using the box cox method the available
data must be transformed when it does
not exhibit the normal distribution
box and cox in the year 1964 developed a
procedure for estimating the best
transformation to normality
within the family of power
transformation it works by taking the
current y
data and raising it to the power known
as lambda
the formula for transformation of y is
represented as
y asterisk equals y to the power lambda
minus one the whole divided by lambda
this formula is used where the value of
lambda is not
zero if the value of lambda is zero
you can use natural logarithm to
transform y
the family of power transformations can
be used for the following
for converting a data set so that
parametric statistics can be used
here lambda is a parameter to be defined
from the data
for any continuous data greater than
zero this will not work when the values
are less than
or equal to zero transforming specs
note that the use of the transformation
does not guarantee normality
in the next screen we will continue the
discussion on data transformation
using box and cox
the table on the screen shows how the
data can be transformed
using lambda the first column lists down
values of lambda and the second column
shows the transformed value if the value
of lambda is negative 2
it becomes y to the power negative two
after the transformation
which is one divided by y square
similarly
if the value of lambda is negative one
after transformation
it becomes y to the power of negative
one which is one divided by y
and so on note that you will use a
different formula when you have the
value of lambda as
zero wherein you will take natural log
of the value y
similarly transform values are also
shown on the screen
click the example button to know more
let us look at an example of how data
transformation is done
using box [ __ ] the difference between
original data
and the data transformed using box [ __ ]
is shown on the screen
figure one shows the original data
plotted on a histogram
here you can see that this data is
abnormal
in figure two the box and cox procedure
is applied on the original data
and it is transformed you can see that
the data in the second figure
is more normal than figure one let us
learn about
process input and output variables in
the following screen
process improvement has a few
prerequisites
before a process can be improved it must
first be
measured to assess the level of
improvement required
the first step is to know the input
variables and output variables
and check for any relationship the sipoc
map and the cause and effect matrix are
very helpful
there are many ways to measure the key
process variables
metrics such as the percent defective
operation costs
elapsed time backlog quantity and
documentation errors can be used
critical variables are best identified
by the process owners
once they are identified cause and
effect tools are used
to establish the relationship between
variables
a cause and effect matrix is shown on
the screen
the key process input variables have
been listed vertically
and the key process output variables
horizontally
for each of the output variables a
prioritization number
is assigned numbers which reflect the
effect of each input variable
on the output variable are entered in
the matrix
the process output priority is
multiplied with the input variables to
arrive at the results for each
input variable the values are added to
determine the results for each input
variable
for process input variable 1 the output
variables are
3 4 and 7 with a prioritization value of
4
7 and 11 respectively therefore
multiplying the output variables with
their corresponding prioritization
numbers
and adding those gives one hundred
seventeen
which is around thirty three percent of
the total effect
the process input variables results are
compared to each other
to determine which input variable has
the greatest effect
on the output variables click the cause
and effect matrix template button
to view another template
a sample of the cause effect matrix or
ce matrix is
shown here the ce matrix gives the
correlation between
input and output variables
in this screen we will discuss the steps
to update the ce matrix
the steps for updating the cause and
effect matrix r
list the input variables vertically
under the column process inputs
list the output variables horizontally
under the numbers
1 to 15. these output variables are
important from the customer's
perspective
one can refer to either the qfd or the
ctq tree
to know the key output variables rank
the output variables
based on customer priority these numbers
can also be taken from the qfd
the input variables with the highest
score become the point of focus
in the project another method to
establish the cause effect relation
is the cause and effect diagram this is
explained in detail
in the following screen the cause and
effect diagram
is used to find the root cause and the
potential solutions to a problem
a cause and effect diagram breaks down a
problem into bite-sized pieces
and also displays the possible causes in
a graphic manner
it is also known as the fishbone the 4m
or the ishikawa diagram it is commonly
used to examine effects or problems to
find out the possible causes
and to indicate the possible areas to
collect data
the steps involved in the cause and
effect diagram are
all the possible causes of the problem
or effects selected for analysis
are brainstormed the major causes are
classified under the headings of
materials methods machinery and
manpower the cause and effect diagram is
drawn
with the problem at the point of the
central access line
and the causes on the diagram are
written under the classifications chosen
the next screen illustrates the cause
and effect diagram
with the help of an example
the diagram shows the cause and effect
diagram for the possible causes of
solder defects on a reflow soldering
line
this diagram helps in collecting data
and discovering the root cause
during brainstorming the group looked at
all the major causes
and then grouped them under the main
headings under materials
causes like types of solder paste
components
and the components packaging used are
considered
the major causes under methods are
technology
and preventive maintenance similarly
operator and schedule are placed under
manpower
while tools and oven are grouped under
machinery causes
the next screen will discuss another
root cause analysis tool
in detail 5y is one of the tools used to
analyze the root cause of a problem
the responsibility of the root cause
analysis lies with the 5y analysis team
the technical experts have a great
responsibility
as the conclusion will be drawn from the
way the drill down of the symptoms
is carried out the 5y is a very simple
tool
as it poses the y question to every
problem
till the root cause is obtained it is
important to know that the 5y
tool does not restrict the interrogation
to 5 questions
y can be asked as many times as required
till the root cause for the problem is
found
it can be used along with the cause and
effect diagram
the following screen will explain the
process of the five
why technique the process
for the 5-y technique is identify the
problem
and emphasize the problem statement
arrange for a brainstorming session with
the team
including subject matter experts process
owners
and team members explain the purpose and
the problem statement
analyze scenarios working backwards from
the problem
ask why for the answers obtained until
the root cause is found
normally reasons like insufficient
resources and time
become the root causes if the drill down
in brainstorming is carried out in the
right direction
it is often found that the root cause is
related to the process
therefore the occurrence of a problem is
often due to the process
and not an individual or a team
in the next screen we will understand
the concept of the five-wide technique
with the help of an example the process
for the 5y technique
is identify the problem and emphasize
the problem statement
arrange for a brainstorming session with
the team including
subject matter experts process owners
and team members explain the purpose
and the problem statement analyze
scenarios working backwards from the
problem
ask why for the answers obtained until
the
root cause is found normally reasons
like
insufficient resources and time become
the root causes
if the drill down in brainstorming is
carried out in the right direction
it is often found that the root cause is
related to the process
therefore the occurrence of a problem is
often due to the process
and not an individual or a team
in the next screen we will understand
the concept of the five why technique
with the help of an example in this
topic
we will discuss lean tools in detail
let us learn about lean techniques in
the following screen
the eight lean techniques are kaizen
bokayoke
5s just in time kanban
jadoka tactime and hijanka
click each technique to know more
kaizen or continuous improvement is the
building block of all lean production
methods
kaizen philosophy implies that all
incremental changes
routinely applied and sustained over a
long period of time
results in significant improvements
the second technique is pokayoka it is
also known as mistake proofing
it is good to do it right the first time
and even better to make it
impossible to do it wrong the first time
the prompt received to save the word
document before closing it without
saving
is an example of bokoyoka
5s is a set of five japanese words which
translate to
sort set in order shine standardize
and sustain this is a simple and yet
powerful tool
of lean the sort principle refers to
sorting items according to a rule the
rule could be
frequency of use or time of use after
sorting
the objects are set in order the place
for everything is defined
and everything is placed accordingly
cleaning of the area
refers to the shine principle the fourth
step requires formation and circulation
of a set of written standards
the last step refers to sustaining the
process
by following the standards set earlier
5s is useful as a framework to create
and maintain the workplace
just in time or jit is another lean
technique
this technique philosophizes about
producing the necessary units
in the necessary quantity at the
necessary time
with the required quality as an item is
removed from a shelf of a super mart
the system confirms it and automatically
sends a note for replenishment
this kind of technique can be used in an
organization to prevent accumulation of
inventory the fifth technique is known
as kanban
which means signboard in japanese
kanban utilizes visual display cards to
signal movement of material between the
steps of a product
process this is one of the examples of
visual control in lean
the next technique is jiduka it means
automation with human touch and is
sometimes known as
autonomation jiduka implements
supervisory function in the production
line
and stops the process as soon as a
defect is encountered
the process does not start again till
the root cause of the defect is
eliminated tack
time is the maximum time in which the
customer demands
need to be met for example a customer
needs 100 products
and the company has 420 minutes of
available production time
tax time equals time available divided
by
demand in this case the company has a
maximum
of 4.2 minutes per product this will be
the target for the production
line the final technique is
hijanka which means production leveling
and smoothing
it is a technique to reduce waste
occurring due to fluctuating customer
demand
let us understand the concept of cycle
time reduction
in this screen cycle time reduction
refers to the reduction in the time
taken for a complete process
implementing
lean techniques reduces cycle time and
releases
resources faster than any other method
low cycle time increases productivity
and throughput
lean techniques release resources early
achieving more production with the same
machinery
internal and external waste is reduced
and the operational process is
simplified
with a decrease in product damage all
these factors help in satisfying the
customer
and staying ahead in competition the
following screen describes the concept
of cycle time reduction
through an example the changes brought
by
implementing lean techniques on an
existing process
are illustrated in the given diagram
things to be noticed are
number of operators used work allocation
to the operators
path or the movement in the process and
flow of the process
notice the changes brought about by
implementing lean techniques on the old
process
first the path followed by the material
in between the process
is considerably reduced this decreases
the cycle time for the entire process
second the number of operators is
reduced to 3
when compared to 5 in the old process
operator 1 can now work on process 1 and
process 4. similarly operator 2 can work
on process 2
and process 3. there is an increased
productivity of the operators
and the remaining skilled operators can
be used in some other process
or system the next screen will introduce
the concept of kaizen
and kaizen blitz kaizen
means good change in japanese kaizen is
a continuous improvement method to
improve the functions of an organization
the improvements could be in process
productivity
quality technology and safety
it brings in small incremental changes
to the process
kaizen blitz is known as kaizen event
or kaizen workshop if the event is
tightly defined and the scope is evident
for
implementation processes can be easily
changed and improved teams could improve
processes through creative problem
solving methods in structured workshops
over a short time scale the next screen
will provide the differences between
kaizen
and kaizen blitz the differences between
kaizen
and kaizen blitz are kaizen
is a method that brings continuous
improvement in the organization
while kaizen blitz is a workshop or an
event that brings in change
kaizen brings in small incremental
changes in the organization
there are no major changes made within
the processes
kaizen blitz is applied when a rapid
solution is required
the kaizen method follows a step-by-step
process
it standardizes measures and compares
the process
with the requirement before improving it
kaizen blitz plans for the event
executes it arrives at a solution and
follows it through
all the people of the organization are
involved in kaizen
whereas kaizen blitz is led by the top
management
and others are invited to participate
the decision making lies with the upper
management
in kaizen the process is standardized
and measurements are regularly collected
and compared before the decision is
taken this
relatively delays the process of
decision making
in kaizen blitz decisions are taken soon
and the process change is wrapped in
three to five days
kaizen is a continuous improvement
method whereas the kaizen blitz is part
of the improving process
kaizen follows pdca in essence
plan do and check and act for the
improvement process
kaizen blitz uses pdca for execution
where the events are planned conducted
decided
implemented and followed up the
following screen will elaborate on the
concepts of kaizen
and kaizen blitz through examples
kaizen and kaizen blitz are practiced in
many organizations across the world
the examples of kaizen and kaizen blitz
method are shown here
click each tab to know more
the toyota production system is known
for kaizen practices
in toyota if any issue arises in the
production line
the line personnel sees all the
production until the issue is resolved
once the solution is implemented the
team resumes
the production cycle
a wood window company in the state of
iowa us
uses the kaizen blitz method to redesign
their shop floor
and replace expensive non-flexible
automation
with low-cost highly flexible cellular
applications
eliminating scraps reorganizing work
areas
and reducing inventory are some of the
examples of quick
implementation through kaizen blitz
the term lien refers to creating more
value to customers with fewer resources
it means reducing unwanted activities or
processes
that do not add value to the product or
service for the customer
the lean philosophy is to provide
perfect value to the customer
through a perfect value creation process
that has zero waste
while the ultimate goal is to achieve
zero waste you may not always get that
in the first couple of tries
however you will achieve minimum waste
and continue to move towards zero waste
eventually
hence lean is the path towards
perfection
lean is about optimizing the process
from beginning to end
eliminating non-value-adding activities
in vas
and increasing flow to ensure that parts
and services are provided to customers
more quickly
if quality is the word to describe six
sigma
then speed is the word to describe lean
let's understand the importance of lean
there are many benefits of lean and some
of them are reduced cost
reduced cycle time more throughput and
increased productivity
despite all of these benefits lean is
not implemented by most of the
organizations
because of the misconception that it is
only suited in manufacturing areas
the reason for this misconception is the
beginning of lean
it began and grew in popularity in the
manufacturing areas
starting with toyota in recent years
one can notice more applications of lane
in other areas
such as healthcare and the transactional
space
however the truth is that lean concepts
can be applied in
any business and in any process on the
next screen
let's discuss how lean and six sigma
combine
lean and six sigma are two different
principles or methodologies
that combine to form and create one
powerful continuous improvement
methodology
they have various overlapping goals
toward the improvement
with the aim of creating the most
efficient system though the approaches
are different
the methods complement each other lean
six sigma takes the power
and rigor of six sigma methodology and
combines it with lean concepts
leading to faster results better quality
and improved customer satisfaction
let's look at the differences between
lean and six sigma
lean focuses on efficiency by
identifying value
from the customer's point of view
removing unnecessary
steps in the process and improving
process speed or velocity
on the other hand six sigma focuses on
effectiveness
with the help of breakthrough processes
identifying root causes
and reduction in variation therefore
when six sigma is combined with lean it
is possible to achieve business
transformation
so remember lean is about speed with a
focus on efficiency
six sigma is about quality with a focus
on effectiveness
and lean six sigma brings the best of
both together
to yield a better result first implement
lean to streamline the process
this helps to understand the chronic
problems and the ways to handle them
quickly
once the problem is identified use six
sigma methodology to analyze the issues
and provide business improvement
transformation in other words
lean is used to reduce the waste and six
sigma is used to reduce the variation
thanks to our training experts it was a
real pleasure having you with us
and with that we have come to an end of
this full course video on six sigma
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
related to the topics that we covered in
this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team of experts will be
delighted to hear it from you
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here